hey everyone
i welcome you all to the selenium full
course by simply learn
in this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to excel in
selenium
we have mathifs and anagna to guide us
through this journey
we shall begin with understanding the
advent of selenium followed by the
basics of selenium
after that we shall dive deeper and
learn about the selenium suit of tools
after knowing the basics of selenium and
what it comprises
we shall understand how to download and
install selenium on our system
both on windows and mac moving forward
we shall learn in detail about selenium
ide
and selenium webdriver in which we shall
see several demos to understand they are
working
after we have ample knowledge regarding
the selenium webdriver
we shall understand xpath and selenium
webdriver
and learn about the selenium chrome
driver towards the end
we will check out the test ng
annotations and the difference between
selenium
and qtp finally we shall look into some
selenium interview questions that might
increase your chances of cracking any
selenium interview
so before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and don't forget to hit that bell icon
so that you can never miss an update
from simply learn now
without further ado let's begin with our
introduction
hey there welcome into the world of
selenium if you're going to embark on a
journey of automation
i promise you this is the right place to
start so let me take you on the first
lap of this journey
this is a video tutorial what is
selenium from simply learn what is in it
for you
before you start understanding any
automation tool it's good to look back
into what manual testing is all about
what are its challenges
and how an automation tool overcomes
these challenges
challenges are always overcome by
inventing something new
so let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become
one of the most popular web application
automation tool
selenium suite of tools selenium is not
a single tool it has multiple components
and we will be looking into each of them
as you know every automation tool has
its own advantages
and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages
and limitations of selenium and how do
we work around it
selenium jobs and salary very important
isn't it
you are here to learn selenium you
definitely want to know what's the
market demand on the skill
what what you will be once you are
skilled on this automation too so what
we will do we'll just discuss some stats
on the job market
related to test automation and selenium
in particular
all right so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges
what is manual testing manual testing
mainly involves physical
execution of test cases against various
application
and to do what to detect bugs and errors
so as a definition if you can say
it is one of the primitive methods of
testing a software
execution of test cases without using
any automation tools
it does not require the knowledge of any
automation tools
and can practically test any application
this could be
as simple a definition can be let's do
one thing let's take an
example right before we start
understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example
say we have a simple use case as a user
i want to log into my web application
using username and password a very
common use case isn't it and this is a
common use case for any kind of web
application under test now let's say for
example
i have a web application here say i have
this community.simplylearn.com for me to
actually
enter into this application what i need
to do is first login into this
application so this is a simple login
page which accepts a user id or an email
id
a password and you click on the login
now as a tester
you would write multiple test cases to
test this use case
for example you will have multiple data
test cases like valid credentials
invalid credentials null value and so on
you will also test multiple links on
this page
probably the forget password link the
sign up now so whatever links are made
available you're going to test that then
you will say it as this check box
so you will check the remember me
functionality and when you log in back
again you want to validate if all your
previous data are
filled up you will also check for error
messages on an invalid login you will do
accessibility testing you will also do a
performance on this page like say for
example response time after you click on
login button and so on
so while you're doing a manual testing
literally you can do
any kind of test you want so this is
what you do in the first place
and then you start executing these test
cases one by one
you will find bugs your developers are
going to fix them and you will need to
rerun
all these test cases again and again
until all your bugs are fixed and your
application is ready to ship now this is
a very simple use case now let's look at
a little
complex use case now say you have an
account creation form like this so i
have this online pan
application form right this is still a
simpler form i would say
now look at the amount of data you need
to fill here
each and every field you need to test
and you need to test this with hundreds
of transactions
because you you're going to have those
kind of data sets with you and then
you're going to repeat them again and
again
until you are satisfied that your
application is working as per
it is designed so now if you go back to
our presentation now this
brings us to the first demerit of the
manual testing and what it is
this is very time consuming process and
hence it's going to get very boring for
any manual tester
also it is more error prone the risk of
error is pretty high
why because it is done manually and
human mistakes are bound to happen
requires presence of tester all the time
since it's manual execution
tester's presence is required all the
time one needs to keep doing manual
steps
over and over again and hence he needs
to be sitting in front of his pc manual
creation of logs and repositories
creating manual reports grouping them
formatting them so that they are like a
good looking reports
sending those reports manually to all
the stakeholders
say collecting logs from the various
machines after you execute the test
cases
consolidating all those results and logs
right creating repositories
maintaining them wow this is a huge long
list
of mundane tasks one needs to do and
this you need to do a
do again and again until your testing is
completed right so this is going to be a
manual process and it's going to be very
tedious
and as i said it was also error pro
limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited
for example say regression testing
ideally you would want to run
all the test cases which you have
written but since it's a manual process
you would not
have the luxury of time to execute all
of them and hence what you do you will
pick up
choose your test cases and then execute
that way you are kind of limiting the
scope of testing
also say working with large amount of
data which is manually
pretty impractical what about
performance testing so you want to say
collect certain metrics
on various performance measures as a
part of your performance testing you
want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test hence
performing this manually is definitely
not feasible and to top it all the say
you're working in an agile model
where your code is being churned out by
developers say every week testers are
building their tests and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
made available to them for testing now
this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run all the test cases which you have
created
multiple times during your development
process and doing this manually is going
to become definitely very tedious and
boring
and is this really effective way of
doing it not at all
so what do we do we automate it so this
tells us
why we want to automate one one is for
the faster execution two to be less
error prone and
the most importantly to help you run
your test cases
frequently as many times as you want so
there were many tools available in the
market today for automation so
one such tool is selenium advent of
selenium
much before selenium there were various
tools in the market
like rft qtp just to numb a few popular
ones
selenium was introduced by a gentleman
called jason huggins way back in 2004.
he was an engineer at thoughtworks he
was working on a web application which
needed
frequent testing and he realized the
inefficiency
manual testing his application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and
he named it as javascript test runner he
also made this open source which
later was renamed as selenium core and
this is how selenium came into existence
since then selenium has become one of
the most
powerful tool to test web application so
what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for
automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kinds of browsers like ie chrome
firefox safari
edge opera and even the headless browser
selenium is an
open source and it's platform
independent the biggest reason
why people are preferring this tool is
because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which i
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
tools
selenium is also a set of tools and
libraries to facilitate automation of
web application it is not a single tool
it has multiple components in
it which we will be seeing in detail in
some time and all these tools
together they help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform
it is platform independent as and why it
is platform independent because it is
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have
in-depth programming knowledge so the
selenium has a record and replay back
capability and this tool is called as
selenium ide which can be used to create
a set of actions
as a script and then you just have to
replay that script so mainly this is
used for demo purposes
because selenium itself is such a
powerful tool
and it offers so rich functionality you
would want to be
in a position to take the advantage of
all its future however
if you have testers who do not have
enough of programming knowledge to start
with there is still this id
which is a record replay tool which you
can use to create your test scripts
it also provides support for different
programming languages
like java python c ruby and so on so you
can literally write your test scripts in
any language you like or which you know
of so one need not again
know a complete in-depth or an advanced
knowledge of any of these languages
selenium supports different operating
systems and browsers
it supports windows max linux and say if
you want to run your test on ubuntu
machines yes that is also possible it's
on any platform of your choice selenium
you can run the test cases selenium
suite of tools so now let's go little
more deeper into the selenium so as i
said it is a suite of tools
and these are the major components of
the selenium selenium ide
selenium remote control which is in
short called as
rc selenium web driver and selenium grid
from selenium 3.0 version onwards you
will not find the remote control anymore
because it has been deprecated
but you still have your id webdriver and
grid components
now let's take a deeper look into each
of this components and understand
how they function in this suite of tools
selenium integrated development
environment which is called as selenium
ide
so it is the most simplest tool in the
suite of selenium it's an integrated
development environment it has a record
and playback functionality and it's
very very simple and easy to use too
however
it is mainly used as a prototyping and
not used for creating the actual
automation for your real-time projects
why because of its own limitations since
it's just a record and replay tool
so this ide is available as a firefox
plugin and a chrome extension so either
you can use firefox or the chrome
browser to
record your test scripts the commands
created in the scripts
where you are going to record are these
commands are called selenius commands
and these are the commands which
interact with your browser
you can also write some of these
commands manually while you're recording
your scripts and we'll see how to do
that when we talk about the id in detail
and it is again a platform independent
so you can deploy
id on any platform of your choice so you
can have it on your windows linux and
macros
however the only requirement is you
should have either chrome or firefox
browser support on that particular
platform earlier selenium ide was only a
firefox extension it died with the
firefox version 54 or i555 i guess so id
was not supported from the
55 version onwards and this was some
time during 2017. however
very recently all new brand selenium ide
has been launched by
apply tools and they have made it cross
browser that is it is available both on
chrome
and firefox now so you can install this
extension as a chrome extension or as an
add-on on your firefox browser it's a
completely revamped version
which was done by apply tools they
literally rewrote the complete code and
now they have made it available on the
github under the
apache 2.0 license and it also comes
with many new features now like
reusability of test cases
it has a better debugging technology now
and most importantly it supports
parallel test execution it has
introduced an utility called selenium
side runner that allows your test cases
to run on any browser so
you can create your automation using
your ide on chrome or firefox
however through the side runner from
your command prompt you can
execute any of your test cases on any
browser of your choice
and thus by achieving your cross browser
testing you can also run parallel
testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this again this can be done using the
selenium site runner and having the
grid installation done so let's look at
how ide looks like
and what are its components are and how
do we work with ide
let's go to the firefox browser now and
launch the ide and see how the id looks
so let me go to my firefox now on this
browser if you can see here there is an
icon here which says selenium id
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the
selenium id plugin so now i'll just go
click on this
and then i already have a project
created so this is the ide window which
gets open for me i have a pre-recorded
script here
and what the script does is i just open
amazon dot in website
and i am searching for the product
iphone also i have an
assertion statement here which asserts
for the web page title
and then i'm closing the browser so
let's first execute the script
and see how it works and then we will
get into the details of
what are the different components
available on this id so for me to
execute what i will do is it uh
id has a very beautiful feature here to
control the speed of the execution so
what i'll do is i'll reduce the speed a
little bit
so that you should be able to see the
complete execution step by step now to
execute the script i'll just go here and
say
run current test so this opens the
firefox window and the amazon dot in
website
it should search for iphone product now
then it is going to do the title
assertion and close the process so if
you look here
all the statements look in green now so
that means
every step has been executed
successfully and there are no errors
so now let's look at the components of
this id so the first component which you
need to understand is how do you record
the test
so there is a start recording button
made available to you clicking on which
you can launch any website
of the application under test and you
can start recording your steps
and once you have recorded you can use
this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test
so if you want to execute multiple tests
then you have an option to do so here
which is
run alt s this particular window what
you are seeing here
right so this is the window where you
have all your commands
which gets recorded when you record your
script and these are pretty simple
commands
and they're very self-explanatory let's
say for example open so it says open
and the target is amazon dot in that
means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size
clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have
and then typing what is the product
which you are searching for and then you
have multiple assert statements
made available to you in this id so
these are all called as the selling is
command
and as simple as a close browser command
and now if you look here
in this window this log window so every
step which gets executed
here there is a log generated showing
you the status
of the execution of that step so if at
all there is a failure
you would see a red failed mark against
that particular step
and the test case will not say completed
successfully it will say the failure
occurred
okay so it is very simple and a very
user friendly kind of an id
so let's go back to our presentation so
we saw the play button here and we saw
how to record it
i also showed you the commands the
command window what we have so these are
the selenium commands
and then we saw the log which indicated
the execution of each of this command
now saving the script so let me go back
to the id again so once you have
created your test scripts you have run
it successfully you need to save your
project
so for you to save the project when you
click on the save project
every ide project it is saved with an
extension
dot sid which is nothing but selenium id
so you just
go ahead and click on save since i've
already saved this project i'm going to
just say cancel so that's the text file
extension it uses to save your project
for more details on how to use ide you
can watch our video
on selenium id on simplylearn.com
selenium rc
this is selenium remote control so this
was developed by paul hammond
and he refactored the code and was also
credited with json as a co-creator of
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming language
the server itself is written in java
language it supports multiple
programming languages like java
c perl python and php it interacts with
the browser with the help of
rc server it uses a simple http get and
post request for communication
this rc server is also a selenium 1.0
version
but it got deprecated in selenium 2.0
and was completely removed in 3.0 and it
got replaced by
selenium webdriver we will see why this
happened when we talk about the
selenium webdriver this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was javascript program
and he called it as javascript test
runner and it is also called as
selenium core so every html has this
javascript statements which are executed
by this web browser
there is a javascript engine which helps
in executing this command
now this had a major issue of something
called a same origin policy now what is
the same origin policy same origin
policy
prohibits your javascript from accessing
elements
or interacting with the scripts from the
domain
different from where it is launched and
this was for the security measure
for example every web page in say
google.com domain
like say your search email google drive
can be accessible
but nothing outside this domain like say
if you want to access yahoo or an
amazon that was not possible due to
security reasons obviously
so the testers had to install the
selenium core
and the web server which contained your
web application which you are basically
testing
on the same system and this was not
feasible and effective all the time
now to overcome this to overcome the
same origin policy what paul hammond did
was he created something called as this
remote server which is selenium remote
control server
and it acted like a proxy to trick the
browser
in believing that your core which is
your selenium core
and your web application under test are
on the same domain
this thus by eliminating your same
origin policy
and this was called as your selenium
remote control which was a version one
of selenium now if you look at the
simple architecture of this
what are the things it has so one is
your script right first you need to
write your scripts using any supported
language like say php
java python and ruby as i mentioned now
before we
start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium one version
is you need to install the rc server
now this rc server is a separate
application
so once you install this this selenium
server is responsible
for receiving the salinist commands now
these are the salinist commands which
you have written in your scripts
it interprets them and it executes it on
your browser and the results are sent
back to your test scripts and this
browser interaction happens
only through this rc server again as i
said using a simple http get and post
request to communicate
now upon receiving these instructions
right from the selenium core
the response is sent back to this rc
server from your browser and back to
your test scripts
so the cycle starts from your test
scripts the selenius commands are
interpreted by your rc server those are
sent to the browser
and it's a simple javascript which
executed on your browser
and the results after the execution are
sent back to your
test scripts through your rc server this
is a simple cycle now
this cycle is repeated for every command
written in your test script
until your complete test case is
executed okay so this is how the rc
worked
now this rc had few shortcomings and
what are those
one is the architecture of this rc
itself was complicated
why because of this intermediate rc
server which we have between the browser
and your test script and this rc server
had to be installed before running any
test scripts
so that means this became an additional
setup and it acts as a mediator between
your selenium commands and your browser
also the execution of commands takes a
very long time
it is pretty slow why because every
command
it needs to make a full trip from your
test script to your rc server
to the core and to the browser execute
the script and then again
back in the same line which makes your
overall test execution very slow
and now because of this short falls web
driver
was introduced so selenium driver
selenium web drivers were introduced by
a gentleman called styman stewart
and it was developed in the year 2006.
it is the first cross-platform testing
framework
it is a programming interface to create
and run test cases
it makes provision to act on web
elements so basically there are
multiple locating techniques which
selenium webdriver provides us
for finding those elements and to
perform operations on those web elements
webdriver does not require a core engine
like rc and it
interacts natively with the browser
application so there is a direct
interaction with your browser
application
and it eliminates the need of having
that intermediate rc server
and that makes the architecture pretty
simple this web driver again it supports
multiple languages which we already
talked about and also
it has integration with multiple
frameworks so once you understand how
the web driver works what are its
functionalities and what are it
drawbacks
you will appreciate the fact that so how
the selenium webdriver
overcomes this even in web driver we
have test scripts
we also have a web browser here and then
we have a web driver
however what we do not have this
additional server which rc required
and this makes the architecture of the
web driver simpler
the browser is controlled directly from
the operating system level now due to
this direct communication the speed of
test execution is much faster than rc
now how does this web driver work
so we have something called as client
libraries or the language bindings
so we know now that selenium supports
multiple languages and you're free to
use any supported language to create
your automation script and where are
these libraries available
so if you go to seleniumhq.org so let me
go to the browser and show you that
so in the selenium hq dot r if you go to
the downloads
so here you will see something called as
selenium client and web driver language
binding
and depending on the language which you
want to work with or which you want to
create test scripts with you can
download this
client libraries so if you're working
with java download the client library
for java
so if you're working with python you
have a corresponding link
which you through which you can download
your client libraries and then
selenium provides a lot of apis for us
to interact with the browser
and these are called as a rest apis so
then we have the browser drivers
through which we interact with the
browser now what are these browser
drivers
so there are drivers specific to each
browser
so let me show you that on our selenium
hq dot org
so here if you just scroll down you have
something called as third party drivers
bindings and plugins
for every supported browser of selenium
you have a corresponding driver file
available now say for example if you
want to work with firefox
mozilla gecko driver is what you need to
download and these driver files so if
you go and click here
you'll get an executable driver file for
any of the platforms which you're
working
so if you're working on windows mac os
or linux you can
just download the corresponding driver
files here so these drivers
see these driver files are the ones
which interact with the actual browser
and how does this happen this driver
establishes the connection with the real
browser
without revealing the internal logic of
the browser functionality now what does
that mean
say we want to execute a test script and
how does this test script gets executed
first is it it sends an http request
which is generated and sent to this
browser driver which we just saw
for each of the command in your scripts
and then this driver receives the
request through your http server
and this hp http server does all the
execution directly on the browser
and then the execution status the
complete status is sent back to your
test script
so let me show you a simple use case how
it works with the web driver
so for that let's go to my eclipse here
so i already have a test script written
here
in webdriver and what this basically
does is it launches amazon.com
amazon.in website it uses the firefox
browser
and then i'm also fetching the page
title and printing it on the console
and then i'm closing the browser this is
a simple functionality
which i'm doing here so if you look here
so the eclipse is the id which i'm using
i've already installed selenium here and
i've written a simple java class
and this java class we have multiple
methods one is to launch browser
one is to fetch the title of the page
and one is to close the browser
now while launching the browser i said
every browser has its own driver files
so somewhere in this java class i need
to tell selenium as which
browser to use and how is that done that
is done by this first two statements
here
where i'm doing a system.set property
and where i'm indicating that this is my
driver file which is gecko driver to be
used
and using this i want the selenium to
launch the firefox browser
and after this all the operations any
operations which you want to perform on
your web application under test you can
do it here
now let's go ahead and execute this and
see how it works so simply what i need
to do is i'll just say
execute this as a java program so the
firefox browser is getting launched
so you can see amazon dot in being
launched here and since we are not doing
any operations here what i am simply
doing is printing the
title of the page and closing the
browser that is it so if you see here
you can see the page title is online
shopping site
so and so and this is what i am printing
through this method
which is fetch page title a very simple
way of
writing a automation script using
webdriver
so now you saw how we write a small test
script using the webdriver function
now say if i want to run the script on
multiple browsers
and on multiple operating system and i
do not have just one test case i say
say i've got hundreds of test cases now
with this approach
what you can achieve your best is you
can sequentially execute on every
browser available
and all your 100 or 200 test cases
whatever you have now this is going to
take quite a long time to execute
and hence to reduce the time taken for
the execution
selenium has something called as grid
selenium grid the main
objective of the grid is to minimize
your test execution time this grid is
designed
to distribute commands to different
machines simultaneously in real time
environment you always have the need to
run test cases in a distributed
environment for example a web
application for which say you have
automated thousands of test cases and
you want to run them as a regression
suite
across multiple browsers and os what you
need to do is you need to run them
parallelly and not really sequentially
so grid
allows this parallel execution of test
on different browsers and operating
system you
also want an integration with reporting
tools so that
you can get a consolidated report after
the tests have been executed on multiple
machines so grid can be integrated with
such
many other tools how does the grid work
so grid has this hub
and node concept which helps in
achieving the parallel execution
let's take an example say again your
application supports all browsers and it
also supports different os like the one
which you're seeing here like windows
mac and linux and your requirement is to
run
tests on all the supported browsers and
operating system like this one so what
you do here is you configure a master
machine that is this
which is also called as hub by running
something called a selenium standalone
server
and this selenium standalone server can
be download downloaded from your
selenium
hq website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see
selenium standalone server version
3.1.4.5
and this is what you need to download so
using the server you create
a hub configuration like this once you
do this you also need to create
nodes specific to your requirement like
a windows 10 like a mac machine with
firefox with the windows 8
with a chrome and mac say with safari
browser and the node configuration
is also done using the same server which
is the selenium standalone server so you
create a node configuration on this
node machines so once you have the setup
created through your master that is your
hub you can control on which nodes you
want to execute which test
say for example here say you want to run
some test
on your mac machine with safari browser
so you have
a kind of smoke dust which you need to
run now through the master
you can control this complete execution
so what master does it it selects this
particular node depending on the
configuration
which you have set on the master machine
also you could have multiple possible
combinations
like say i want to just run smoke test
on all my nodes i want to run specific
component test on say only windows 10
with an edge browser
or i can say i want to just run my
complete regression suite but only on
mac machine
and so on and all this is controlled
through your master so what happens on
the node
once it gets the command from the master
the node actually runs the specified
test on the browser so you can check out
our detailed video on selenium grid for
you to understand
how the grid works and how do we do this
configuration
and execute the test to summarize the
selenium versions
selenium version 1 comprised of an ide
rc
and grid as we discussed earlier rc was
on its path of deprecation
and webdriver was taking birth so
selenium 2 had an earlier version of
webdriver
and also rc existed from 3.0 onwards rc
was completely removed and web driver
took its place
also there is a four dot version around
the corner it has more features and
enhancement so some of the features
which is expected
are like w3c webdriver standardization
they have an improved idea and also i
believe there are some improvements done
to the
grid advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy
since there is no manual execution your
test can run faster and with grid
it helps in parallel execution so you
can actually execute
large volume of test cases within a
short frame for example let's say
before your release of product during
your last lap of testing you find a bug
and it has to be fixed so the developer
fixes the bug and what you want to do is
you want to run all the test cases
pertaining to that area can you imagine
the amount of time which will be
required if you have to do this manually
but
by automation you can achieve this in a
short duration of time and you can also
enable releasing your product
in time and with less or no human error
the second advantage is it's an open
source so it's available free of cost
and anyone can download and start using
it
supports a wide spectrum of programming
languages it is not restricted to any
particular programming language
whatever language you are comfortable
with you have an option to use that
and to write your selenium scripts
selenium has support for almost
all browsers and operating system
including a headless browser
so this helps you to create test cases
once and run them
across all browsers and operating system
and thus saving your time from manual
execution it also helps in achieving a
broad test coverage
it's a pretty easy to use tool you can
check out all our videos
and you can just master the skill of
writing automation scripts
reusability and add-ons of course like
any programming languages it provides
you a mechanism
to reuse your code and avoid redundancy
limitations
so like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also
since selenium is an open source you do
not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials
forums available which you can refer to
this tool is for automating web
application
it cannot handle mobile application or
desktop application automation
however what selenium provides is a
support for
integrating tools like apm tool for
mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation
but then we again have many other tools
which can be integrated with selenium
like autoit and securely
selenium again has a limited reporting
capability
it can help create basic reports but we
definitely need more so it provides
supports for tools like test ng
report ng extent reports which you can
integrate and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it of course it does not
have a test management capability a tool
need not have all these capabilities
but again you can integrate with the
test management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language
the developer of the automation script
need to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write
effective automation scripts of course a
deep advanced knowledge is not required
a basic knowledge is more than
sufficient so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation need
and that's the beauty of selenium and
that is what makes it the most popular
today
most popular tool today for automation
in this video we will look at how to
install selenium on windows system
selenium installation is a three-step
process so it has certain prereqs
the first prerequisite you need to have
java on your system so we will be
installing java first
and then we will be working with eclipse
id so we will be installing eclipse
and then we will install selenium for
java we will
install the version java 8 and for
eclipse we have a version 4.10
this was the last stable version which
was released in december last year so
i'll be using that version
and selenium we will download the latest
3.14 version okay so let's get started
with our first step which is the java
installation so to install java
let's go to the browser and simply just
search for java 8 download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be
downloading all your java package so go
ahead and click on that and for you to
download any jdk package from the oracle
site you need to create an account so if
you already have one you just need to
log in using that account and then you
can download any of the jdks
and if you do not have one please go
ahead create a new account on the oracle
login to that account and then you can
just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and
i have already downloaded the package
but i'll show you how and where to
download it from so in this page if you
scroll down
so you will see this java development
kit 8211. so this is the version we'll
be downloading it so click on the accept
license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this
the windows package so just click on
that and it will get downloaded in your
downloaded folder and as i said i've
already downloaded
the packages so here it is what i've
done is i've just created a directory
called installers
and i'm going to be keeping all my
installables here
so here i have a folder called java
installer and this is where my
installable is
so now that we have this file so we will
just go ahead double click on it and
launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java
the installer is launched now just click
on the next button here
so here for the installation directory
you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to
i would like to leave it as default here
and we just
go and click on next and then the java
installation is in progress
so let's wait until this is completed it
really shouldn't take
too much time maybe just a few more
minutes here
okay accept the license term just click
on next
we leave the destination folder as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8
and this tells us that the java is
installed successfully
now after this installation there are
couple of configurations which we need
to do and what are those configuration
one is you need to set the path variable
and then you we are also going to set a
java home directory so for that first
let's go ahead
and check where is the java installed
actually let's figure out the directory
first
so if you remember the directory
structure where the java got installed
was in program files
java i have there are certain previous
versions which had installed and then
uninstalled it so that is why you see
some residuals here sitting here let's
not worry too much about that
instead let me go to the latest one what
i have installed which is this
okay and there is a bin folder here and
this is the path which we need to set in
our path variable
so what i will do is i'll just copy this
path and then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting
and here in the environment variables
find the path variable okay
and then say edit now what are we doing
here in the path variable is we are
going to add the java bin directory to
the path
be very careful whenever you are editing
your path variable
do not overwrite anything always go into
the edit mode
go towards the end here and then just
say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it
now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next
one we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java
now what i'll do for that is i just say
new i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path
till your java directory that is this so
we'll just copy the path again
and paste it here that is all just say
okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt
and just say java minus version so
everything seems to be fine so
now successfully we have installed java
on the system so what is our next
installation step what we have
now we need to install the eclipse so
let's go back to the browser again
so to download eclipse we will be
downloading the package from the
eclipse.org so when you go here to
eclipse.r
you can see the latest version which is
available and the latest version
available when this video was made was
2090
0 6. so especially with eclipse since
it's an open source
i prefer to work with the last stable
version and so does most of the
developers do
and hence that is the reason why i have
picked up the version which is like last
year's version which is
4.10 which was released in last december
so you can always choose to go with the
latest version but then if there are any
issues and if you're like first time
working with the eclipse
you're going to get confused as where
these issues are coming from right so
i would still recommend that you use the
last stable version which is available
with your eclipse so now to get the last
table version what you need to do is
go and click on this download packages
and here
if you scroll down this page you can see
here
more downloads so there is a list of all
the previous releases of eclipse which
is available and this is what we need
to download so just click on that 4.10
version and then
click on the os on which you want to
install eclipse for us it is windows
so i'll just click here on the 64-bit
windows and then click on the download
and you will be
downloading the complete package so once
you download this is what it will look
like so let's go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the eclipse which i got
now what's the next step i need to do
just launch this installer and install
eclipse so i'll just say double click on
this
i'll say run so here you'll see multiple
options here for eclipse installation
so depending on your requirement you can
go ahead and install any of these
packages
so for us we just need an eclipse id for
java developer so i'll
select this and i'll say install so
again you'll have a choice of directory
where you want to install
so i have chosen d drive here this is
the default directory name it takes
which is ok we can leave it as it is
and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is
and go ahead and click on install so
this will take a while to install the
eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window
this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully
so let's go and click on this launch and
let's see the first window what
opens when you launch the eclipse
you need to specify a workspace
directory
now what is this workspace directory so
this is a directory or a folder
wherein all the java files or any
programs or any artifacts which you are
going to create through eclipse
will be stored in this particular folder
so this could be any location on your
system so this is you can go ahead
browse the location and change it so for
in our case what we will do is i'll go
to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then
create a folder called workspace i'll
say my workspace
and then i'll say launch so every time i
open the eclipse
right so this is going to take as my
default workspace and all my programs
all my javascripts or my automation
scripts are getting are going to be
stored in this particular location so
we'll say
launch so this is a welcome window which
opens we can just close this
and there we go the eclipse is open with
a certain perspective so there are
certain windows here which we do not
need let's just close them
so now the first thing what you do after
launching the eclipse is go ahead and
create a new project so i'll say file
new and since i'm going to be using java
with selenium i'll say
create java project so give a project
name let's say
my first project now you have an
option here to select the jre which you
want to use
so we just installed this jdk 1.8 okay
so i'm going to click on use default gre
otherwise you also have an option to use
a project specific jre
for example i could have two different
projects where one project i'm going to
be working with
gre 1.8 and there is another project
which i want to work with the latest
java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this gives
me an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here
it will show up in this list so and you
can just go ahead and select that now
since we have only one java installed on
our machine which is java 1.8 i will say
use default gre which is 1.8 and i will
click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created
see all the reference libraries to this
particular java have been created here
now we are ready to create any kind of
java programs in this project so now we
have successfully done the second step
of our installation which is the eclipse
installation
after this we need to install the
selenium so again let's go back to the
browser and see what files we need to
download to install selling it so let me
go to my browser and here
i will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org
is going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the
installables for selenium so here go to
the download tab now for you to install
selenium and start working with selenium
there are three things which are
required for you to download one is a
standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium
however when you start working with
remote selenium webdriver you would be
requiring this when you have a grid
setup you will be requiring the
standalone server so for that what you
can do is you can just download the
latest version available here so when
you click on that
it will download the file into your
download folder so this is one
particular file which you need to keep
next selenium client and web driver
language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java
so that means my client package of java
is what i need to download so whatever
programming language selenium supports
we have respective downloadables
available with that say if you're
working with python then you need to
download your client library for python
and since we are working with java you
need to download this
package so simply what you need to do
click on this link and it will download
the
java package for you which are basically
the jar files so we have client
libraries now
and then there is another component what
we need now
with selenium you're going to be
automating your web browser
applications correct and you also want
your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create
should be able to run on any browser
selenium works with multiple browsers
like edge safari chrome firefox
and other browsers even it has a support
for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its
own driver files now say for example we
want to say work with firefox driver so
that means for
us to start working with firefox browser
we need to download something called as
a gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome
browser you need to install the chrome
driver so depending on what browsers
you'll be testing with
go ahead click on each of this link and
download the latest driver files
now since we are going to be working
with firefox in this demo what i need to
do is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this
driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux
for mac and for windows so depending on
which operating system where you've been
running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file
i need because we are working on windows
machine so these are the three
different packages which we need to
download from the seleniumhq.org for us
to install selling so let me show you
the folder where i have already
downloaded all this so if you see here
selenium java 3.141.59 okay this is
nothing but our client library which we
saw here let's go back to the main page
here that is this
so once i download this this is a zip
file after i unzip the file
this is the folder structure i see and
let's see what is there at this folder
structure so there are two jar files
here
and then in the lips there are multiple
jar files and we will need all this
to work with selling it and then we also
downloaded the driver files so what i
did was after downloading those driver
files for the browser i created a
directory here called drivers and i've
kept all my browser drivers here so i
have
a driver file downloaded for chrome i
want to work with firefox so i have a
gecko driver here and
then for internet explorer that's it so
this is all we need
so once we have all this what you need
to do is go to your eclipse
in the eclipse right click on the
project which you have created
and then go to the build path and say
configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first
and now similarly we are going to add
the selenium jars to this library and
how do we add that
on your right you can see this add
external jars click on add external jars
go to your folder where you have
downloaded your selenium which is this
select all the jar files which is
available so i have two jar files here
i'll just say click open again i will
click on add external jar
now from the libs folder i will select
all this file
so select all the five jars and click on
open
so you should see all the seven jar
files here so once you have this
just say apply and close now if you look
into your project directory here you
will see some
a folder called referenced library and
this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here
this is a very simple installation in
eclipse when you want to install
selenium
you just need to export all the jars of
the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start
working with selenium scripts all right
so now
let's just test our installation by
writing a small selenium test script
so for that what i will do is i'll go to
the source folder
right click new and i'll say java class
so let's name this as say
first selenium test and i will select
this public static void main
and i will click on finish all right so
now let's
uh create a use case say we want to
launch a firefox browser and then we
want to launch the amazon site so this
will be
just two simple things which we will be
doing in this test script
so for me to do that what i usually do
is i create
a method for any functionality which i
want to create here so now i want to do
a launch browser so
i'll create a method here called launch
browser now whenever you start writing
your selenium scripts the first line
what you need to do is you need to
declare an
object of web driver class so here i'll
say
web driver driver so now if you hover
over this error what it is showing
it says import web driver from or dot
open qa dot selling in so if you
remember when we installed the selenium
we imported all these jars
right so that means so what whenever we
want to use a web driver we need to
import this class from these packages
so just go ahead and click on this
import state done now next step now for
us to launch a firefox browser
it is a two steps process which is
involved here one is you need to set the
system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that
i'll say system dot set property so use
this method set property so this takes
two arguments the key and the value bill
now what is the key i'm going to mention
here
i'm going to be mentioning the gecko
driver and the path for the gecko driver
okay because since i'm working with the
firefox so in double quotes
i'll say webdriver.geco.driver this is
my key
and the value is going to be sorry the
fully qualified path for your
driver files and you know where we have
kept our driver files let's go to that
driver files in d colon i have selenium
tutorial
in installers i have driver folder okay
so i'm just going to copy the complete
path from here
ctrl c and i paste it here
control v along with this i need to
provide the file name for the gecko
driver which is
geckodriver.exe and let's complete this
step
next so once i've set the property i
need to provide a command for
launching my firefox driver and how do i
do that i simply use this driver object
which i have created
driver equal to new firefox driver again
similarly the way we imported packages
for the web driver we also need to
import
the package for firefox driver so just
hover over the mouse over that and
select import firefox driver with these
two statements we will be able to launch
the firefox browser and as i said in our
use case what is the next thing we want
to do we want to
launch say amazon dot in website for
that
there is a command in selenium which
says driver dot
get and you pass the url here so for me
to write the url what i usually do is
i go to my browser i open the website
which i want to work with
in our case it's amazon dot in and i
just simply copy this fully formed url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
now this ensures that i don't make any
mistakes in typing out the url let's
complete the statement
and we are done and now in the main
function i'll just create an object of
this and
we will call this method so i'll copy
this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now i'll say obj
dot this is a function launch browser so
let's save this and execute this
ctrl c right click run as java
application okay so the mozilla firefox
has been launched
now it should launch your amazon.com
bingo so there goes our first test
script which runs successfully
in this session we will be looking at
how to install selenium
on your mac machines selenium
installation on mac
is a three-step installation one we need
to install
java which is a prereq and then we need
an id
to work with so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium and these are the versions of
the installers which we are going to use
so we will be using java 8.
eclipse version 4.10 which was released
in 2018
december and then selenium version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the java installation
so for us to install java let us go to
our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for java 8
download okay so
we would select the oracle site for
downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with
so in order for you to download you need
to have an oracle account
so since i already have one i have
directly been logged into that
so if you do not have an oracle account
please go ahead create an account for
yourself so that you can download
any of the java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to
click on accept license agreement and
then since we are going to be working on
mac this is the package which i am going
to download
so let's go ahead and click on that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package
and i have kept it in one of my folders
so let me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i've created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today
for us to work with selenium is what i
have downloaded it and kept it here
so we will go step by step so that you
understand what each of these packages
are
so as you see here i have the jdk 8
which i have
already downloaded so let's go ahead and
install jtk
so how do we install jdk so you have the
dmg file here you just go ahead and
double click on that
okay and then i will double click on
this package
and then we will say continue and
install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay i've given my password and i'll say
install the software
probably it will just take a couple of
minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed
so let me close this window let me close
this window tool
and then now i'll go to my terminal
window so let's open my terminal
and here let's say java
minus version bingo so there we have
java 1.8 installed on our system now
there are couple of other things which
you need to do apart from
installation of your jdk you also need
to set some system variables
right so in mac how do you set the
system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your
bash profile so let's see how we do that
all right so what i will do is i'll use
an editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file
for your bash cell this is mainly used
to export
variables in your shell like in windows
we are going to do the system variable
setting from the advanced setting right
so similarly we are going to do that
here
so i will say vi dot dash
underscore profile so this is the file
where i will be adding java home path
now i have other paths here already
written because i am working with other
multiple software on this machines
and now i'll go to the end of this file
and i'll say
export java home
equal now what is the path we need to
give for java home
we need to give the path where the java
has been
installed on your system okay first
let's go and find out that path
so let's go back to our finder and then
i have
a folder called library here so here
there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines
so if you have a single java or multiple
java versions installed so all those
versions you are going to see under
this directory which is java virtual
machines and java one dot is
is what we installed just now so let me
go and open that folder there is
something called as content
and then home and in this you have your
jre and bin folder so that means
i need to give my java home path until
here
till this home directory so simply what
i'm going to do is
i'll just go here say get info because i
want to just copy the path
and what you can do is you copy this
path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here i'm going to paste this path
plus
i want it till the home directory so i'm
just going to type out
h-o-m-e home that is it so you have now
set your java home
environment variable so simply you do
save the file escape colon wq and come
out of it
and now what you need to do for this
batch profile
to be activated you just exit out of
this terminal
okay close this terminal window and i
will go ahead and open
another terminal so let me close this
info text so here let me again give
java minus version okay so everything
seems to be working fine so this
completes our java installation now your
system is ready and you have your java
up and running other thing which you
also can do is go to your system
preferences
okay here you will see this java control
panel
this is another way of finding out that
your java has been
installed successfully on the machine so
you can just open this java control
panel and if there is any settings which
you want to do here you can do it
through your
control panel also all right
let's close this let's minimize this
window and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two
we need to go ahead and install the
eclipse now same thing what i will do
i'll go to my browser
okay and now i'll open another tab here
and i'll say eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here
my recommendation to you is instead of
if you're working first time
instead of working on the latest version
available i would suggest that you work
with the last stable version
and that's exactly what you are going to
do today so for me to go to the previous
versions i just need to go here
on this download packages click on it
okay so once you click on that on this
page if you scroll down you will see
something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions
so since today i'll be working with 4.10
version i will go ahead and click on
this 4.2
this 4.10 was released last year this is
2018 december
okay and now when you look at this
installer you have multiple packages
available here
so depending on your need you can choose
which package you want to work with
so today for our demo what i would be
using is eclipse id for java developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable and then i'll click on this
download which is going to download this
particular file
for me i've already downloaded this file
and kept it in my folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now
do you see this eclipse java 2018-12 are
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using
to install eclipse now as simple as what
we did for jdk
i'm going to double click on this and
install the eclipse
let's see how the eclipse gets installed
all right
so now i'll just move this folder into
applications done so my eclipse is ready
now so simply let's go ahead and launch
so what i'll do i just simply search for
that on my
system eclipse there you go and i'll
just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes
please go ahead and open it okay it is
launching it
so did you see how simple the eclipse
installation is it's just downloading
the package and just installing it on
your mac machine all right
when you start the eclipse for the first
time you need to set your workspace so
workspace is place where
you're going to keep all your folders
all your
java code or whatever you are going to
do in eclipse all under that particular
directory
so right now it gives me a default
directory rather what i will do is
since i have created a separate folder
for our demos i will go ahead and select
that folder
which is my simply demo and then
in this i will add a folder called
workspace okay so that means in this
particular location whatever files i am
going to create whatever code i am going
to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i will go ahead
and say
launch so it will take a minute to load
your workbench yeah there it goes
so when you launch your eclipse right so
let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the
welcome screen just go ahead and close
the welcome screen
and this is the first view of your
eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today
and i just need this main screen now
what is the first step you're going to
do once you have the eclipse i would go
ahead and create a project first
so i'll simply say open file new java
project
let's give a nice name to this since
this is a first project which is going
to be created so i'll say selenium
first project now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with
and what it is done while i create my
new project it has already given me an
option
to use the execution jre which you
already have in the system
that's why it is already chosen java one
dotted
in case you have multiple javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is
you can always go here select this and
select the java of your choice so say if
you have got the latest java which is
java 12
installed on your system it will give
you an option here along with java
software 8 it will give you java 12 here
so you can go ahead and select that for
this particular project
that option is also available now since
we have only one jtk
installed here i will go ahead and
create this project
so i just click on finish and it's going
to create a project from
so there are few default things which it
grades created one is definitely the gre
system libraries
right this is what we told eclipse when
we created project that my java is 1.8
so what it has done is it has imported
all this jar file which it requires
for our java programs to work in our
eclipse id and then it creates a
src which is your source directory
wherein we
will be creating all our java code or
selenium descripts
okay good so far so this is a simple way
of installing
your eclipse and getting your eclipse
ready to work with your selenium
all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium
right so what is that we need for
selenium let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq dot org so this
is going to be a bible for you if you're
going to be working with selenium
so in this website what i do is i go to
downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with selenium
one is the selenium standalone server so
when you are going to be working with
remote selenium web driver
is when you would require this however i
would suggest that we download whatever
is required
for us even though we might not use it
immediately
so what i just need to do is i need to
click on this and it's going to download
this
server for me so i have already
downloaded it and i'll show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay
we need a client so what is the client
which you are going to work in we are
going to working with
java client with the selenium and for
that i need to go ahead and download
this
if you are working on say c sharp or
ruby or python then you have the
respective packages which you can go and
download
now since we are going to be working
with java here i would go ahead and
click on this and this is going to
download the java client formula now as
i said since i've already downloaded it
so let's go ahead and look at what are
those downloadables what we have
so let's close out this window now if
you see here
uh one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded
and then when you download the client
libraries what it does it it creates
a zip file it downloads a zip file and
it unzips it and what is
contained in that particular folder so
if you look here
selenium java 3. in this folder you have
multiple jar files
with which is what we'll be working with
selenium
so here you have two jar files here and
then under the folder libs
you have other jar files now these are
the files which we will need
and now let's see how do we utilize this
file in our eclipse
so for that let's go back to our eclipse
okay so
let me maximize this window so in
eclipse first thing what you need to do
is click on your project okay
right click on that and then you have
something called as build path
go to the build path and say configure
build path
now here in this configure build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select
all your jar files from what you have
downloaded from the selenium site so
that is present in our selenium java 3.
so what i'll do is simply select
these two first okay
then again you click on the external jar
files what we have is ellipse
so select all the jar files in the list
say open okay you have all the java
files what we need
identified here go ahead and click on
apply and close once you do that how do
you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly go to the reference libraries
here you should be able to see all the
selenium jars which we have downloaded
to be listed out here and so it lists
here so that means we have successfully
imported selenium
to test our installation let's go ahead
and write a small test script
so for that i'll go to my source folder
right click
new and will create a java class so
let's name it
selenium first test
and i will also use a public static void
main here
and i'll click on finish let's
remove all this commands here which we
do not need so before when we write our
first line of code
first what we need to do is create an
object of webdriver
so i will say web driver driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to
import this particular web driver class
from a package
and that package is org dot open qa dot
selling
okay so now you can see this import
statement
now let's go ahead and write our
test case now for this test case what we
will do is uh we will simply launch a
browser say firefox browser and we will
also launch a website now i'll create a
method for that i'll say public
void launch browser
so if you have looked at our previous
videos on
selenium webdriver basics i have
explained there that every browser which
you want to work with in selenium
comes with its own driver and this
driver is what we need to download from
the
website of selenium and i'll show you
how to do that
so if we go to that seleniumhq.org
under the downloads tab if you go down
you will see something called as third
party drivers bindings and plugins
so all the browsers supported by
selenium are listed here
and their corresponding driver files are
available so now since we are going to
be working with firefox in this demo
i will go ahead and click on this latest
release of mozilla gecko driver so gecko
driver is the one which will be using
for
launching our firefox so just click on
this
and this will take you to the latest
version of the gecko driver available
so just scroll down and depending on the
os which you're working with
in our case it is a mac os so just click
on this file and download this file
similarly say if you are working with
the chrome driver
what you need to do is go to this chrome
driver go to the latest
click on that and select the release
which you want to work with
and just download it now i've already
downloaded this file and i'll just show
you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory i have another
directory
created called as drivers and what i do
is usually i keep all my driver files
under this folder
okay so i have a chrome driver and gecko
driver already downloaded and kept here
now let's go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to
launch our browser so there are two
steps which we need to do
for launching any browser which you want
to work with
first is you need to set a system
property so for that what i do is
system dot set property
and this accepts a key and value pair
now key for this is
gecko driver is what i need to provide
here and now that is in the course
because it's a string argument
i say web driver dot
gecko dot driver and the value is
nothing but the path to your gecko
driver which you have just downloaded
okay let's go to my finder so that's
here so what i do is i simply right
click on this file
get info and i copy this complete path
go to my eclipse paste this path here
and then the file name which is gecko
driver
done so this sets a path to my
gecko driver now next step is actually
launching the web browser
and how do i do that i say driver
equal to new firefox
driver now we need to do the same thing
again we need to import this class
so i say import firefox driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
firefox browser
and then let's go ahead and also launch
a website say amazon.com so for that i
have a command called
driver.get which accepts a url
now this url needs to be fully formed
url so for that what i do first is i go
to my any browser
i launch the amazon dot in website okay
and then i copy this complete url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.com so let's
quickly create a class here
object here of this class so selenium
first test
obj equal to new study name
first test
done and then i need to call the method
which is launch browser
okay so now i save this file i do a
right click on this
and i say run as java application
now this should launch our browser
okay which adjusted and then it should
take us to
amazon.com bingo there goes our first
script
so we have successfully executed our
first script so that means
your selenium is up and running
successfully
let's talk about automation frameworks
okay so guys to be precise with you
i'll be talking about mission framework
when we will start automation but as
that's a part of the automation
basics so i'll just give you a basic
knowledge of it that what automation
framework is and then we'll be seeing
how we'll be going to create a framework
so first of all what is automation
framework so it's a set of
protocols rules such as coding standards
object repository and data
and beneficial in terms of code reuse
portability maintenance the framework
provides the basis
of test automation simplifies the
automation effort
so what happens actually when we need
this automation
suppose you are automating only
one functionality you have written only
one test
script of course you don't require to
write an automation framework for this
because there's only one script if there
is any there is any change comes you can
go ahead and make the change and done
but when this one is this script one
one automation script becomes hundred
then it becomes very difficult to manage
them
suppose in hundred test case hundred
descripts there is a user name
there is a password so there is a
username and password in more than
10 test scripts if that happens
then and if there is any change comes
in the password or in the username you
may have to go to the 10 tips script
separately and make the change
which will be very cumbersome process
and it may be possible that you make
you made an error okay it may be
possible that
you know somewhere you have written
something different somewhere you'll be
something different or spelling error or
space
error may have also if i talk about what
you have done you have created your
scripts
but that is keeping in mind for windows
but what if you have to run it on linux
then you'll go back on all your scripts
and make that change
what if you have written your script for
firefox browser and you may have to run
it for
chrome browser then it will be difficult
to make multiple changes
so it's always suggested that you create
a
framework for that because framework is
the one which will help you out and
solve all these problems
instead of writing one thing again and
again we will write it
only at one place and reuse that again
and again it will be very
easy for us to maintain it because that
in terms of framework that's in the
framework where you can make changes
very easily portability so of course you
have written out of windows and you can
run it on any other operating system
the framework provides the basis of test
automation and simplifies
key automation effort it is actually
helpful when you have multiple scripts
for multiple test cases
so framework is very important and
that's the reason if you go
and say that you have done the
automation and you have a knowledge of
automation you will always ask you about
the framework
they will know they will not go in the
basics they will always
go with the automation so it's very
important
so what are the automation frameworks do
we have we have linear framework we have
structured framework data driven
framework
keyword driven hybrid there are multiple
types of frameworks we have
what is the methodology for automation
first of all uh you know mythology means
how
you decide whether you need to automate
or not so first of all you take a
decision whether this project needs to
be automated or not
because that is becoming very complex
you have 10 more
methodology you have less resources all
those things you have
less budget because of that you thought
to automate that
when you have part of automating it
what tool do you want to use you think
on that
so you pick three to four tools it
certainly depends
you pick three to four tools create a
proof of
concept create a proof of concept
guys are you all aware what is proof of
concept poc
obey is aware of that anyone who is not
aware of that
can just say engineers heard of it
kushal is aware of that
okay great not created on my own yes
that's perfectly fine of course
okay says no so guys what is proof of
concept
is whenever you are suppose you are
shortlisting some tools you have
multiple automation rules in the market
correct
so how do you decide whether which tool
is
best for you of course you can go ahead
and you know
take a list of tools you can see pros
and cons of those tools but those pros
and cons of the tools depending on the
blogger depending on the editor who is
writing about that particular tool
it may not be applicable it may not be
possible that those
advantages or disadvantages are actually
correct for your project so always what
we do
we shortlist few tools like three to
four rules
we develop or create a poc ready poc
means
you actually use those tools to
automate one simple use
all three tools what you have
shortlisted
to automate a simple script
and then figure out the pros
and cons of that tool
based on your experience and based on
what other people say
and then you create a ppt and show it
to the management and this is the tools
we have taken up this
is the poc this is how it works this is
the advantage this is a disadvantage and
then you shortlist one tool out of it
and that's what we call test tool
acquisition
and it does not like uh you are talking
and we are
learning scenario and you will go ahead
and face the reading and that's it they
will accept it no
you have to tell them that this is the
poc and this is the benefits of
opting selenium tool and then
if they are happy with that then they
will go ahead with that
they will say go away else they may ask
you to come back offer with more
details and all this stuff okay and it
becomes very difficult to
you know impress your management
when there is an existing tool running
like qtp is running and you wanted to
suggest them selenium tool then it
becomes
very difficult because they may say that
all the other projects are working
perfectly fine with the qtp
why should we go ahead with selenium
what is the best part so
that's what you need to highlight and
need to say that these are the things
which automate with qtp
selenium you can do that so that's where
tesla acquisition comes
then you do the test planning that what
all test cases should be automated
and start developing your test cases or
test scripts
then you execute them and manage them
then you show the result
of all those test cases and send it to
all the stakeholders
then this is the result so in this video
we will be looking in detail about how
the selenium id works so what is
selenium id selenium ide
was developed way back in 2006. it was
created to facilitate
a simple record and replay of the test
automation so record and replay tools
were pretty much invoked during this
time
and the main advantage of using such
tool was an automation engineer was not
really required to know any knowledge of
programming
he could just use this record replay
tool and create the automation
and this ide was available as a firefox
extension so for one to use it you need
to just go ahead and install the
extension on firefox and then use its
recording
and record the steps of your test
execution it is a very simple interface
which helps in building the automation
scripts
and how this works you just need to
start the recording on id
perform your test steps on the browser
and these steps gets recorded in the
script and then what you could do is you
could export the script into say a web
driver or a junit
ruby or any javascripts and then you can
use it now however
the record and replay tool is not a very
powerful automation tool and hence
this ide is mainly used for prototyping
or you could say demo purpose
now since selenium webdriver itself
offers such powerful capability of
creating
robust test scripts ide more or less
remains as a prototyping tool only so in
short as i said
ide is a part of overall selenium set of
tools
and mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases
and what is the other advantage of that
one need not really have any programming
knowledge
to use this tool and mainly it is used
for writing some quick test for
demo purposes advancements with the new
selenium id
back in 2017 selenium id development was
completely stopped the last supported
firefox version where this ide was
available as a plugin was firefox 54
and from 55 onwards the complete
integration point was
removed or it was completely broken
however recently
apply tools help revamp much of the
selenium id code they basically rewrote
the whole ide
code and then now they have released a
new version under the apache 2.0 license
and it is completely managed by the
selenium community now let's look at
some of the features of this
now traditionally the selenium ide was
only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it
cross browser so before even we start
looking at the other
features of the selenium ide i would
like to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser
so in the chrome browser what i'll
simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium
id so go ahead click on add to chrome so
this will add
this extension to your chrome browser so
now it says selenium id has been added
to the crew
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium
id so this is the way you can go ahead
and install it on the chrome
now on the firefox i have already
installed it since we want to use the
firefox as a browser for all the demos
in this video
so here again you can see the selenium
id so if i click on this ide
it is going to open a window for me and
the first window when it opens it says
either open a new project or open an
existing project
or simply you can start recording a new
test case in which case it creates a
default project for you first
so what i will do is i will say open an
existing project
and i've already got a project created
so let me go to my
folder where i have this project so i
have this project created and i've
opened it
i also have a simple test case written
now what this test case does
is let me show you here it simply goes
to google.com
and then here what i'm doing is i'm
searching for
selenium hq documentation and then
i click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs
so which should take us to this
particular website where the
documentation is available so this is a
simple script
which i have tried to write it in this
id so let's keep both this windows open
and let's go back to our presentation to
see the first feature of this selenium
id the first feature what it says
is improved locator functionality what
are locators
so these are nothing but the techniques
used for locating your web elements on
your website now for example in our
example here now the type here the type
which says name equal to q so name equal
to q
is a locator now this is a locator of
what initially if you saw
i went to google.com and this is the
search button which i used
right the search text and then i said
enter so this is nothing but your
web element for which the locator is
name equal to q now what happens in id
is when you record it it has taken the
attribute name and it has recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute
however it also has a feature wherein
it also records its multiple locators
available for that particular web
element for example it also has a css
locator it has an expat locator now how
does it help here
say for example tomorrow this particular
attribute
name right for the search box if it
changes then what id does
is when you execute this test script it
falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if
none of this locators work only then the
test case is going to go and fail
not otherwise so how does this help this
helps to make the test cases more robust
otherwise having just one locator there
is high possibility the test case might
break or become pretty brittle
as in when the web elements change their
attributes so this is what the locating
techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the
uh functionality in the new id now
what's the next one parallel execution
is possible with this new id
so the first id the traditional one the
parallel execution was not possible
however this is a new feature which has
been added so we will be looking in
detail how to work with this parallel
execution
later in this video next is you can add
control statements in your scripts now
what are these control statements like
if else
while loops for each loops and even the
switch case the earlier ide
also had this provision but you had to
install a plugin
to enable the use of this control
statements and now this new id it is
available
out of box automatically waits for page
to load
in any automation synchronization
between your
application under test and your
automation scripts is very important
your script should not run faster than
your application otherwise your scripts
are going to start failing so it is
necessary to have enter flow
times on the operations of your web
elements and also
enough load times on your page now this
low time
ensures that all the elements of your
web pages
and the page itself is loaded completely
before even a single
line of script is run this new ide takes
care of providing that enough
uh wait time and also you have a global
set speed option which you can
use to control your execution of your
scripts so that is something which i
will show you now
so if i go back to this so can you see
this clock icon here so it says test
execution speed so what you can do is
right now it is set to the fastest so i
can actually
control the execution speed here so
right now i've just
kept it a little slower so let's see how
our test scripts run so you will be able
to see a remarkable difference
when i slow down the complete speed of
this so now do you see how slow
it is initially when i ran it you are
unable to see what i
entered in the search field of the
google right so now it's clearly taking
time on each of the
steps which we have mentioned there so
now it is executed successfully
so next it supports embedded code you
can run a
simple java script from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as
execute now let's see how do we do that
so let's take the same example here
now after clicking this okay so this is
our id
so what i will do is i'll first execute
this test case
and then in the end where i will show
you how do we add a single javascript
and do some function
so let me get the speed back to a little
normal because we do not want to waste
too much time
so i'll just play the script once so now
we are in the selenium documentation now
if you look at this page this is a
pretty long one so now i'm going to
write a simple javascript
wherein i scroll down towards the end of
this page that's all i'm going to do now
for me to do that what i can do is in my
script itself
i can just add another line here okay
here i will say add a new command
here i'll say execute script which is my
command and what is the script which i
want to execute
it's a java script which i'm going to
write here i'll say window
dot scroll by and i'm just going to
mention some coordinates here
start from zero and i'll say one five
zero zero okay this is all my code is
and now
i'll simply run this test again let's
see what happens
so it's going to the documentation now
it's clicked on the link
okay let's move down do you see this
initially it was right here on the top
of the page
and once the javascript was executed it
brought me somewhere to the middle of
this page
that is how you can insert snippets of
javascript
and it has to be in context with your
currently selected window okay and
that's how you run it
all right let's go back to our ppt okay
what's the next feature
so every ide has a debugger which allows
step execution adding of breakpoints
now apart from just having a break
points or
adding the step execution there is
another feature which it provides called
i will show you that which is called as
pause on exception so let's close this
window
and let's just keep this id window open
here right
so can you you see here pause button it
says pause on exception so what it does
is if you enable this button okay and
when you are running
the script so if at all there happens to
be an exception in your script it stops
the execution at that particular
exception field
and we will see this in detail when we
look at complete debugger
for the id can be integrated in ci since
you can execute scripts from command
line
right we also talked about the parallel
execution and you can also
export the scripts to any of the
programming language you want so since
you can do that
these scripts can be run from command
line and hence they can also be
integrated
with your maven project and through gen
keys you can run it and that's how you
achieve your
ci working principle of selenium id
selenium id works on a very very simple
principle one is the recording it
records user interactions with the
browser
and which forms basically your id script
and using this id script which is a
recorded script you execute the script
and verify and monitor for its stability
and success rate and thirdly what you
can do is you can simply save your
recorded script
for your future runs or regression
testing and these scripts can be saved
either in the form of an id project
itself or you can also
export these test scripts into the form
of a javascript or your ruby scripts or
even the web driver scripts
now let's look at the components of this
id interface itself
the first one is the menu bar so let's
go back to our id window
so here in the menu bar what you can see
is is a
project name so either you can edit the
project name here
or you can simply create a new project
open an existing project
and save the current project so these
are all the options available
and since we have already created a
project here i will not be showing how
to create a new project
so that we can do it little later now
next one is the toolbar so this is the
toolbar
what we have here for the id now there
are multiple components in the toolbar
so let's see one by one so it says run
all test
now if you have multiple test cases
written okay so this is an
option where all the tests can be run
one after the other
this is to run your current test which
the focus is on so currently our focus
is on search test so if i click on this
button it is going to execute the
search test for you ide has this
debugger option
where you can do a step execution right
you can do step by step execution using
this option we'll see how to do that
for example let's say we start from here
okay and i click on this
so what it does is basically it has just
executed the
first step for me so let's keep this
side by side so that we can
observe the complete execution now if i
go and press on this again
step over current command so that is the
next command it is going to execute
now it says type into this all right so
now you can see the selenium hq
documentation
okay then again i say step send keys
which it basically said enter
and then it is going to click on that
documentation which it did
and now we have a script written which
scrolls down
on this particular page so let's execute
that and that is what it is so this is
how the step execution happens
so let's close this window and let's
come back to our
id window then we have buttons here
where
you can say record or you can stop
recording okay then you can pause the
execution
and then there are other options
available for disabling breakpoints so
basically you can add breakpoints any
various so for example if i want to add
a breakpoint on the click here so what i
have to just do is i have to just click
here so this adds a break point and if
you want to remove all the spray point
you just say
disable those break points so when you
run the script even though you have a
break point available here
for that particular run your breakpoint
will be disabled and your execution will
not stop at this point and
let's enable them for now and what we
will do is we'll just run the script
until there
so now it has stopped here at this click
now from here
either you can execute the rest of the
test case by just clicking on this run
button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we'll do is we'll just stop
the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red
which means that this particular line
was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component
let's come back here so we saw the menu
bar here we saw the toolbar we saw start
and stop of recording
address bar now what is this address bar
so this address bar is where you
actually write your url from where you
want to start your recording and as in
when you start writing more
and more test cases it keeps a complete
history of all the
websites which you are working on next
then we have a test script editor box
which is this so let me just minimize
this little bit
okay this is nothing but your test
script editor box and this is where all
your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this
okay can you see a command now command
is nothing but the actual
operation or the action performed on
your web element so there are multiple
actions
you can perform like in this case we
have something called as open
we have got type we have got send keys
and we have got click so these are all
the
selenium commands which are available
and then we have something called as
target now this
target is nothing but the web element on
which you want to perform the
action and now this target as i said
earlier also it is identified by
multiple locating techniques
and if you click on any of this like we
looked at the
name here now similarly the website
which we are clicking on if you look at
it there are multiple
locating techniques which are available
here so the one right now which is
being used is the css identifier you can
also have
xpath here which is a relative x bar so
these are all the locating techniques
and this is where it which is applied on
the
target value so value is an optional
field so you can send any value to your
web element for example
in this case where we are sending the
value which is our text which is
selenium hq dot documentation so this is
the value which i want to send it to
as a search text to my google.com and
then comment or the description
so here you can mention any description
about that particular
line which you have recorded for example
i can say here
sending search text to the google
search input box and this gets recorded
here against your uh
instruction now let's look at the test
case pane now test case pane that is
here
so if you look here now it contains all
the test cases which you have recorded
now there are multiple things here
one is your tests so i can always go
ahead and create another
say uh test case two okay i can add few
more test case here
test case three so all these test cases
are here
now i can also have a test suite now
there is already test suite which i have
created which is called the google suite
and now
if i want to add test cases under this
what i can do is i can just say add
tests
and now i can add any of this test which
i just created
under this test suite so say i have
selected the first three and i've added
it
so we have test suite we have tests here
and then executing so
executing is basically it shows that
particular test case which is currently
in the execution mode so whichever test
case we run you will see
all the test cases listed here which
have been executed at that point of time
that is your test case pane and then we
have test log and reference this is a
very important window which you need to
be aware of
now here this is a running lock so as in
when you are going to run your test
cases
the every instruction the every test
step as and when it runs it is going to
log here
whether it is passed whether it has
failed whether the command was executed
properly or not and this is how it
records it's a running law also there is
something called as reference tag now
for example just go ahead and
uh let's select one of this command
which you have written here so which is
send case now this reference it will
show you
the complete description of the command
and how to use that command so say for
click
it says references click locator clicks
on the target element it gives you a
complete detail of what exactly the
command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon dot in so let's go back to our id
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so
i'll click on the create new project are
you sure you would like to without
saving
it yes proceed further and let's give
the name as
amazon project now in this new project
what i will do is i will say i'll add a
test
and my test name is search iphone now
basically what is the use case which i'm
going to automate
so i will launch amazon.com and i will
search for iphones and once i get the
iphones let's verify the title of that
particular page
now just the simple steps we'll go ahead
and do that so for that first what i
need to do is i need to enter the url
now this url needs to be a fully formed
url so for that what i will do i'll
first launch
dot in on any browser i'll just copy
this url and i can close this browser
window and in this url
address space i would say amazon.a and
i'll say enter
and now i would click on this recording
button which says start recording so
once i do this what it does is it
launches the web page with amazon.com
and from there i can start recording my
script so let's do that
and say record it so let me just
keep this window side by side so that
you can see what is happening on the
id window here now here what i will do
is i'll click on the search
and i'll say iphone and i will click on
the search button and here
i will also click on this bestseller
once i'm in this window
i'll say right click now when your
selenium id is in the recording mode you
will get this
option here which says selenium id and
there are a lot of options here which
you can select now for this particular
moment what i want to do is i want to
assert the title so i'll just put an
assertion point here for assert title
and then i will close my browser window
now let's see
what are all the commands which it has
recorded
let's go one by one right so it is done
it is opening
the amazon dot in it is setting the
window size fine it
clicked on the to search window button
and then iphone is what you are
searching
and then it said submit it it's
basically clicking on that button and
then we said we also want to open the
best seller link and here is our asset
title right so it's a very simple test
so let's go ahead and execute this now
since i also have a close command here
this script is going to execute so fast
that you will not be able to make out
all the steps what we have written so
for that what i will do i will comment
out the slide now how do you comment out
any command here just select the command
and can you see your enable and disable
command just click on it so now your
command is disabled
also what i will do is i will reduce the
execution speed so that you should be
able to see exactly what is happening so
let's go ahead and execute this test
first
so i'll say run current test okay i have
not stopped the recording so that is the
first thing after closing the window i
also need to click on the stop recording
now your script is ready to be executed
so let's go and run the current script
again i'll just bring this side by side
so that you can see
each of this commands being executed
here okay it has searched for the iphone
it's clicked on the best sellers and it
has done the title assertion now if you
look at the log here
as i said see every step as in when it
was executed it has been logged here can
you see here
and it puts an ok and it color coded in
green which says that this particular
command was
executed successfully now let's go ahead
now this is what we did
by simply recording all the steps from
the browser now one more thing what we
will do is
say i want to continue recording here
right i have not completed my test case
so what you can still do here is you can
come towards the end of the script and
press on record button again and then
you can continue recording from here now
say for example
after the bestsellers what we have got
say i want to click on
say hot releases hot new releases so i
do that okay it says it has recorded the
click
and then i want to stop the recording
just the another step is what i wanted
to add now it has stopped the recording
so can you see this new line which is
got added so that means you really need
not restart recording all the steps
again
if you want to add something in the
middle of your script you can always go
towards the end of the script or
anywhere in between
and you can add more commands there or
you can record anywhere in between the
script
and that is how this does so let's go
ahead and again execute this then i will
show you another feature of this
okay it's done the title assertion now
and it is also clicked on hot new
releases done now let's say for example
i need to add another command here
now instead of going ahead and using
this recording
what i will do is i'll manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this amazon website
and say you want to click on this card
so let me add a command manually here
so what is my command my command is
click and then what is that i want to
click i need to identify that web
element for that
i can use this here which says select
the target in the page so i click on
that
and i simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all i need to do so
my command is written there so i'll just
simply go ahead and execute this
again let's see what happens so let me
close this window here okay let's
run this test cases bring this window to
the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iphone has been searched
the best seller has been clicked assert
title
so it says your shopping cart is empty
so that means it is successfully able to
click on the
cart so now with using id there are
multiple things you can do you can
simply record your script
while you are running your test case you
can add a command all by yourself
you can stop recording anywhere and
again restart from the same point
now we have our complete test script
ready now let's go ahead and save this
so how do you save this
simply go here and save your complete
project so
all the project from the id are saved as
dot side file so let's name this as
amazon project and i will save it
so if i show you in my finder how it
looks like this is a project we created
so it always stores with the file
extension dot
sid right that is selenium id now also i
said you can export test cases into
multiple format
so search iphone is my test case so what
i can do is i can just say right click
and
i can say export now right now you can
see only three options
it says java junit javascripts and
python however
the older ide had multiple options of
export which had even the web driver
scripts
and also the javascripts this is still
in works and they would be adding more
support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is java junit javascript and the
python so let's go ahead and export this
into java j
unit so it's going to simply save it as
dot java
file let me go here in the id test i
will save this file so if you go back to
my finder
you can find our search iphone test dot
java you can open the java file you can
you can see here it's a simple junit
test it is exported into so
if you have an eclipse ide you can use
this test and
execute it from your eclipse side
selenium commands
selenium commands can be broadly
classified into three
action commands accessors and assertions
what are action commands
action commands are the commands which
interact directly with the web elements
on your application so let's look at
what these commands are so if we go back
to our previous example
where we had written a test script for
amazon.n
so if you look at all these things like
open set window size click
type so these are all nothing but called
as action commands and if you go here
you can see let me do one thing so let
me just come to a blank line
and now let's look at the list of
commands so you have a whole list of
commands here listed in the alphabetical
order
like add selection there are multiple
asset commands which is made available
to you
and then there are set of commands where
you say click
or click at a particular location
closing the browser
using a debugger command double click
drag and drop
echo i'll just explain how to use an
echo command so this is
a command which is not or used on your
web element but something which you want
to say display on your console
and then there are if else statements
which are used as commands here then you
have something called as
execute script for you to execute any
say javascript or any different script
which you want to execute from your test
script here
and then you have few mouse commands
here open which is
what we use for opening a new url pause
and so on so there are multiple commands
which you can
look at and try to use this commands in
your script so these are all called as
the action commands so let's go ahead
and use this echo command and see what
it does
so now in the same script what i will do
is towards the end of the script i'll
just add this command i'll say echo
and say i want to just display a message
saying that
this is the end of the script
execution that is all i want to do now
i'll just go ahead and run this
and what we want to observe here is how
this particular message what we have
given here is displayed on the console
in the log
so now if you observe here so go to this
last statement what we have so it says
after clicking on the card it said
echo this is the end of the script so
this is what we displayed and using the
command echo
okay so this is how you can use the echo
another feature here what you
can do here is now say for example i
just added a simple echo statement here
now for me to execute that what i did
was i executed the complete script you
really need not do that always
instead of that what i can do is i can
just come to this particular line i
can just say right click and i can say
play from here
so what it does is from this point it is
going to play the script for me and not
right from the beginning of the script
so i'll show you how now with this
command if you look here
see it started running the script here
it says running search iphone
and then it executed only one command
which says echo this is the end of the
script so this is also possible to do
with the
id accessors accesses are the selenium
commands that
examine the state of an application and
store the results in a variable so these
are those commands which allow the user
to store
say certain values into your user
defined variables and these stored
values can be later on used either to
create
assertions or you can have some
verification points created
so let's see some of the store commands
in action
so i have few store commands here which
i'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or
you can do some assertions with that
similarly store title
so you can to store the title of any of
the web page under test
then store text so store text is
basically used to
capture the text attribute of any web
element on your web page
and store it in a variable use it as an
assertion point
store value so store value again is
used to store the value attribute of any
web element like so you have lot of web
elements on the web page and say
one of the attributes is what you want
to do an assertion on so what you can do
is you can
use the store value command here get the
value attribute
of your web element and store it in a
variable so let's
see all these commands in action so
let's go back to the same example
so we have this amazon test script
example so what i'll do is
say instead of using amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself
so i'll go here i'll say add new test
and i will name this test as accessor
test
and we will use the same amazon site
here i'll say click on
start recording keep this window side by
side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what i need to do is go to this
amazon site which you have launched
right click on this go to the selenium
id and you have multiple
options here so go ahead and select
store title so once i click on that it
is going to ask me the variable name
where i want to store the title of this
page so let's create a variable here
i'll say
var title and i'll say ok done now come
back to your ide
all right so i will stop the execution
here now i have the store title command
i created a variable called var title
and i'm storing the actual title into
this variable so let's also display this
on our console so i'll add a command
here
echo and in target how do i use the
variable now this is the way to use it
i'll say dollar
and in flower braces i will give the
variable name which i have defined
earlier so it is
where i dle title okay so this is all my
scriptures where
i'm storing the title of the webpage and
i'm displaying it in my console or the
lock so now there are some extra
commands which gets added
here now because we are doing the
recording on that so whatever the mouse
movements happen it is going to record
we do not need this so
i will go ahead and delete this
particular command so lets close this
window
and execute this test first so the
script has executed successfully but
let's go
and see whether did we get the title
displayed on the console yes
so it it did open the amazon site it has
set the window size it captured the
title here
in this line and then after assigning it
to the variable
we said echo and that variable name and
it is displayed as the
title of the page so now similarly let's
go ahead
and let's see how do we use the store
text command now for
store text i need an use case here say
for example
what about this cut let's say we want to
display the text
of this particular element now the text
of this element is cut
so now instead of again going and
re-recording all the steps
i will simply manually add this command
so now after displaying the title
okay so let's go ahead here and i will
say
store text and in store text
i need to pick the text from this web
element cart
so what i will do is i'll use this
target select target
and i will select this particular
element which is cut
after this i need to create a variable
where it can be stored so i'll say
where car text now similarly i will also
display it
using echo command echo dollar in the
flower braces
i'll say var car text so let's execute
this and then let's look at the
other command so i'll just say i'll
close this window again run this test
so now look at this log lines so our
last statements was storing the title
and displaying the title
after that we added store text okay so
here is the command it said it is
executed successfully
it was able to retrieve the text from
the element
cart and the text retrieved was cart and
which is what got
displayed with the echo statement on our
console so now let's move to our next
store command which is store value now
as i said
store value for us to use that
particular web element should
have the attribute value so first let's
examine which element we can take and
display the value now on the same
website i have the search button
so i will right click on this and i say
inspect element
now look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type
input it has a class name it is of type
submit and also it has this value
attribute which is
gogo and this is exactly what i want to
retrieve and print
so we will be using the search button
now similarly
same thing what i will do here i'll go
ahead add a command here
as a store value same way i will select
the target as a select target from page
i will click on the search button all
right so here it has taken the target
here
in the value i will mention the variable
name where i want to store the value
so i'll say where button and value and
similarly
i will say echo and i will print the
value of this variable which is
dollar where btn value let's go ahead
and execute this
and say run current test so it has taken
the title
it has printed the value on the line 7.
so it says store value
on this particular element and the value
was stored in the
variable where btn value so that command
was successful
and the value actually which was got
stored and which we retrieved using echo
statement was jio
and that's exactly what we had here if
you want to check again
go here to inspect element the one which
is highlighted so as we said the value
is
go and that's exactly got printed on our
console now
apart from this i also said there is a
simple command which is just store
so let's use that also now after all
this here
i will say store and say we want to just
store a user message
i would say a target as all store
commands demo and this message i will
capture it in a variable say that
string this is just a text and then like
i did it in the other
string and i'll say echo and the
variable name so now if we
close this and one way to do it is
execute the complete test
so which will execute all our store
commands and also the last line
is this the line number nine in the log
which says the store command which we
use to store the text
all store commands demod and that is
also displayed using the x
so all the store commands we have demo
successfully now let's close this window
and go back to our presentation so this
is all about the accessor command now
what do we have after accessor so we
have something called as
assertions now what is an assert so
assertion is nothing but it verifies the
current state of an application
with an expected state so this is
something where you
compare your actual result with the
expected result now assertions are of
three different type
one is assert verify and wait for now
what does
assert does when the assert command is
executed
and if it fails right the test stops
immediately after this statement so if
you are asserting say
a title of a page and if you find that
the title of page is not as expected
as soon as it finds that failure your
rest of the test case test is not going
to run and it's going to
immediately stop the test and also it is
going to flag the test cases fake what
is verify
verify something where the selenium id
it locks that particular assertion as
fail
however it would continue with the rest
of the steps in the test case
and then at the end of it the your
overall test case is flagged as fake
that is what verified us
so verify is called a soft assertion
whereas assert here
is called as hard assertion why it is
called harder session because
as soon as an assert statement fails the
complete test execution stops at that
statement whereas in soft hazard what
happens is
after the failure happens the test
continues with the rest of the
steps and continue it completes its
execution and then flags the test cases
failure
and when is this usually used in cases
like as the same example say if you are
asserting a title
you really do not want the test case
execution to stop
even if there is a failure why because
none of your steps are going to be
dependent on this assertion point and
this is where you will require a
soft hassle wait for wait for something
which
waits for a certain condition to be true
after that it proceeds to your
further steps so if the condition goes
false here for whatever say if you are
waiting for an element to appear on the
webpage
and if that element does not appear the
test fails
however it carries forward and completes
the test by executing the rest of the
steps
and then flags the complete test case as
a failure which will be something
similar to a softer search so let's see
all these things in action
let's go back to our id we will create
another test case here
so i'll say assert test now for this
what's the example we can take
so first for assert title let's do the
assert
title on amazon itself and let's change
the same test case to verify and see how
this test case behave now for this i
will launch the recorder with the same
amazon dot in okay my recorder is
launched
now simply i will go to this website and
i'll say right click
selenium ide and i'll say assert title
then i will stop the recording
now here i will remove this command
which has got added which i don't need
so this is my asset title now we have
already seen assert title passing in
couple of our other examples
now i want to show you failure on myself
so for that what i will do
i will modify this actual type so here
in the last
line i'll just remove this amazon dot so
now ideally this test case is going to
fail first
because the title which it is expecting
and what it is comparing against are not
the same
first let's execute this uh well i also
need to show some
statements after this so what i will do
is uh let's add few more statements here
let me start the recording here again
say after asserting the title
we want to go and click on this
bestseller and then i will
close this now let's execute this stop
the recording and
execute this test now do you see this
assert title
is in red that means it has failed the
validation here so you see here in the
log
it says open the site done set window
size done when it comes to azure title
it says actual value was something
different
and it did not match with what you are
trying to look for assert test ended
with one error now
after this assert please observe that
there are no other statements which got
executed this test stopped
right away after this failure this is
called as hard assert
now let's go ahead and change this
assert title to verify title
so simply what i will do in the command
itself instead of assert i'll say verify
title
and now let's execute this and see what
happens now
let me close this window first and then
i'll say run test
running assert test amazon dot in was
open window size was set
verify title failed because the titles
were different because we have modified
that
however do you see this fourth line
being executed click on link test
bestseller and click on close
now since i it was a very fast execution
and i closed the browser probably was
you were not able to see the
best sellers clicked here that is fine
but in the log we can see here that the
steps 4 and 5 got executed
even after the title verify title step
fit
and if you compare it with the previous
example where assert title failed
the two lines after that the line 4
where we are clicking
on the best seller and closing the
browser are not getting executed so this
is the main difference between the
verify title and the asset title so now
let's look at wait for how do we use
wait for now for wait for i want to look
at
some kind of website where it would load
an element
uh dynamically after a while so for that
i have a website here
let's let's create a new test again
let's go to the tests pane
i will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser let me open
a new window and there is a demo site
which i want to use
so let me search for that and then i
will use that url
so i'll say internet i'm going to use
the
dynamic loading do we have here yes
dynamic loading page
element rendered now see if you look at
this website when i press on the start
button
right after a while this hello world
text is going to appear on this webpage
so in our use case what we will do we
will launch this website we will click
on the start button
and then we will put an assert on this
text using
wait for let's do that so let's go here
let me copy this
this is the one let me say control c and
in my new test
i'll say control v and then i'll say
start recording so it's going to launch
this
let's close the previous windows now in
this i'm just going to
click on start so that is going to get
recorded done and now
while the recording is still on i will
add a command here for wait for so i'll
say wait for
element visible that is exactly what we
are saying right so wait for is used
until for a condition and until that
condition
is true so i am saying here please wait
for
this particular element which i am going
to give it in target until it is visible
now the target is
i'm just going to select the target from
this webpage itself so i'll say select
target
and i'm going to select this particular
text come back here to your id so
wait for the element to be visible what
is the element to be visible
is this hello volta hello world text and
then you need to give a value here now
what is this value
since we are using wait for we need to
mention a timeout so we have to tell
basically to id that okay
wait for say one second two seconds or
three seconds whatever it is required
and that timeout value is needs to be
mentioned here so and this is in
milliseconds so what i will say is i'll
say
so let's fail this test case first so
i'll use a little lesser timer so i'll
say
3000 so that is 3000 milliseconds which
is three seconds
that is it and then we can say so what
we'll do here is we'll add an assert
so i will say assert text now what is
the other text i'm going to do i need to
look for the same element so i'll simply
say select target
this one and what is that i'm going to
assert with i'm going to assert with the
same text so i'll
just copy this text and i'll put it in
the value there's another way of doing
that
which we have done it previously so i
can just go here do a right click go to
selenium id
and i can say assert text which is
basically going to give me the same
command so let me just go
ahead and remove one of them either of
them you can remove okay so let's
stop the recording i will not close this
browser because i want you to see how
the dynamically loaded element
behaves and will go ahead and execute
this so i'll say
stop recording and say execute this test
now it's here
all right so it's waiting okay it just
failed now see this so it says wait for
element visible after that the value we
have mentioned is 3000 that is wait for
three seconds which was not enough
because and it failed with saying that
unable to locate the element within the
timer period
now let's go ahead and change it to a
passing value so i will say 10
000 here which is 10 seconds so let's
close this
and let's again execute this bring this
to the side so that we can see
okay it is waiting on that wait for
element now look at the
problem here what we have done is we
have closed the website
and after that we have added the assert
text so this is a mistake what we have
done
and hence though it is found that
element here for wait for
what did it do it went ahead and closed
the window and after that it's
definitely not going to find the
ascertain right so that's the mistake
what we have done so let's go ahead and
debug this
so what we will do after this wait for
element we want this assert to be put
after that
we don't need this click content because
this was an additional step which got
added
delete it and then close okay fine so
now let's go ahead and rerun this
let's say run current test i'll move
this to a side
okay it's waiting all right done so now
it is able to
do an assert text on this all right so
this is how
you use the wait for key features of
selenium id
let's look at the first feature
reusability of test scripts
so many of the test scripts have test
steps that involves signing into an
application or creating an account
like for example a login screen is a
very
key example in this case where whenever
you are testing your application first
you need to login and then perform any
other test
so now it's going to be a redundant or a
waste of time to recreate the login
steps again and again
for each and every test case so we do
not want to definitely do that
so as we know since a record and replay
tool does not have
enough capability of writing common test
cases or a common functions and
calling those common factions like our
regular selenium web driver has
however what id is done is it has given
us a provision to run one script from
another script so what basically what we
do here is especially for a login we
write one test case
which is going to log into your
application and call this test case in
the other test cases
so let's take a a look at how this works
so for that let's go to our id so in
this id
we'll do one thing let's go ahead and
create a new project
so let's say login project in this
project i will create a new test case
we'll call it as login test let's say
add
now in this login test i need to give a
url now for this purpose
i will be using again a demo site so
first let me
launch a demo site here file new window
and
i will say the demo site
okay this is a simple demo site which
has a login functionality
right so here i will go to the login
screen now this also
allows me to add few users and using the
same users we can
go ahead and do the login now coming
back to our
login page so this is the url which i
need to launch which is going to give us
username and password we will use to
login into this application
so give this url here and say start
recording move this window here for
recording and this here now what is the
first step we want to record we want to
come here click on the username
and i'll say user1 okay and i'll say
password pwd1
and i will click on test login and then
what we will do is we will assert this
text so here i'll say
right click selenium id assert text
that's it and then i will close the
browser okay this is all my test is
now come back to your id let's see if
there are any unnecessary commands which
it has
taken okay click type all done and now
for the time being
i'm going to comment out this close
comment because i want the browser
to be still open so that we can see the
actual test execution properly till the
end of the
script this is the login test case now
simply if i run this let's execute this
let me execute this and show
stop the recording and execute this test
case
so it typed user one it typed pwd which
is my password here
and then clicked on the button and then
definitely it was the wrong password so
it gave me field locking so this is fast
fantastic however
this is with one value i have used it
but this is a function which i want to
use it every time
and also a probable use case i might
have is that i might need to login with
a different user id and password and
apart from that even just to test this
login test page
i would want to test with multiple user
id and password like valid credentials
and invalid credential now for that
purpose what we will do is
we will parameterize this name that is
user id
and the password and how do i
parameterize it simply go here
instead of giving a hard coded value
here what you can do is
just say use any variable name here and
we'll define this variable somewhere
else so i'll say username this is the
variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value
i'll say dollar and i will say password
now i cannot run this program as it is
because there is this variable is not
defined in the login.test
what i will do now is i will create my
actual test case
so i'll say here i'll say invalid
credential
as my test case and i'll say add now
here is where i will assign values for
my variable now which are these
variables i need to use
username and password so i need to
assign some value here
and then call this function login test
so let's do that
in this video previously we also saw how
do we use
user variables and how do we assign
value by using the store command
so i'm going to say store and then my
target is going to be
the actual value so user1
and where is that i'm going to pass this
to my
variable username so let's just check
once if the variable name is username
yes
all right done now i have done the
username now i need to pass the password
so i again i'll say store
the actual password which is pwd1 in my
case and what is the variable i need to
use here
i have to use password because that's
the variable which we have used in
login test here and then after that i
need to use a command
which is called as run now what this run
command does is
run and whatever target you give which
is basically your another test case it
is going to run the test case
now in our case our test is login test
this is all our test case is going to be
okay so what is that we did we do
in this test case we created a variable
username
and password and assigned the actual
username and password
and then we are just calling this login
test and in this login test this
username and password will get passed
which will be user1 and pwd1
and then it will execute this test with
the or with the value which we have
passed to this variable
so now which test case we need to run
the invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test
see running login test called by invalid
credential before that it said
store this value store user1 in the
value username that is your variable
this is this line and then the password
then it says run login test
so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this
clicking on the password field clicking
on the username and then asserting the
text
and that's exactly what is done here
this is how you use it so now let's
write one more test here
for the same login test so let me add
another test
i'll say valid credentials and let's say
add now same thing i will do here i'll
say
command store my target will be now i'll
say user 3
value will be username right okay now
second command will be again storing
this time it is for the password
my password is pwd3 and
the variable name is password and same
thing i'll just call
run and my login test that's it now
similarly let's
run this test and see what happens now
this test is going to fail
why let me close this window i don't
need this why did this test case fail
because my assertion point let's go to
the tests i'll show you my
assertion point in login test is look
for failed login
however we created a test case for valid
credentials right because
our valid credentials were said that the
login was successful
which did not match with what we were
asserting which is fine right so we just
wanted to see whether we can write a
test case with valid credentials and
invalid credentials
and this is how you do that by passing
the variables through your test case to
your
actual test case the next feature is the
debugger in the id like every other id
offers a debugger functionality so does
selenium id
so let's look at what are the different
functions available for us
in the debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ide
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques works
what i'll do is let's go ahead and
create a new test script
so let's go to our id and i will create
a new test case
so i'll say new test case let's use uh
facebook login this time so i'll say
fb login test or we'll just say fb test
so now for this fb test i would go ahead
and use the
facebook login page so i'll just copy
this url paste it here
and then i will minimize this other
firefox window and i will launch the
recorder now so i'll click on start
recording now let's keep this side by
side
and what is that we are going to do here
is let's
do a simple login functionality so i'll
just use some
email id here so i'll say my user at
gmail.com this is just a dummy user id
and password values and i'll say
password as password1 then i'll click on
login button let's stop the recording
here so let's read the script once
whether it has
got everything whatever we need okay it
has launched facebook
it clicked on email id there's a double
clicks here
because i happen to click twice on the
email id field so what i'll do i'll
remove one we don't need it
and then i'm typing the keys which is
myuser.gmail and then i'm clicking on
the password field typing the password
and clicking on the
login button and then once i do that
okay so i'm going to get this pages the
password you have entered is incorrect
so let it be so we will use
the script until here and check out some
of the login options okay so we have
completed writing of the script let me
go ahead and close this window
now first thing what we will do is we'll
just simply execute the script so we
have to just say run
current test so it's going to log in
your facebook it will enter
my user at gmail it will enter the
password it will login
and that's about it so now your script
is executed now let's go into the debug
mode
as we said there are multiple options
for debugging what is the first option
let's see the first option we have is
something called a step execution so
what the step
execution does is from your script you
can
execute all the steps one after the
other
so you can basically control the
execution of each step
and how you do that what you have to do
is just go and click anywhere so let's
start from the beginning let's close
this window
of our previous run and there is an
option here which says step over current
command so when you click on this
what it does is it basically executes
your first line
where your cursor was and it stops
immediately after that
so if you look here it has launched the
facebook page which
says open the url facebook and then
let's go ahead and just do the simple
step execution
again i will click on that it is going
to execute this command where it set the
window size to certain value
again i will do a step execution now
observe what happens here it clicked on
this email field do you see the cursor
there now let's do the next step again
again i will do step over current
command now the current command was it
entered my user at gmail you can see it
on the left side here
now it will be more visible again i will
do a step execution
it is going to click on the password
field now it is going to enter the
password
and now the last step is it's going to
click on the
login button and with this all our
commands are
executed and this is how you do the step
execution and now where is this useful
say if you've got a very long test case
written
and you want at certain point you want
to start doing the step
execution to see where your test is
filled probably one of your web element
you entered is wrong or
probably the text which you are entered
is wrong so for you to debug such cases
you can use this step over current
command functionality so what's our next
command
break points so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's
close this execution and let's come back
to our script
so what i will do is first let's add a
breakpoint how do you add a breakpoint
say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id
so here what i do is i simply go and
click here so once you click here this
is where your breakpoint is added
other way of adding breakpoint is you
can right click on any command and you
can use this toggle breakpoint so
if there is no break point it adds the
breakpoint and
for you to remove it you can simply go
and select the toggle breakpoint again
so now i've added a single breakpoint
now what you need to do is
once you execute this once you say run
test what it will do is it will come
till here till your break point it will
execute all the commands before that
and it stops or pauses your execution at
this point okay let's go ahead and see
how it does so what i'll do is i've
added a break point at the click
on password field and i will say execute
this test do you see here
it says paused in the debugger so by
adding breakpoint
my test has entered the debugging mode
and where has it stopped to
at the point where i added this
breakpoint so just go
back here and see whether the previous
steps have been executed yes my previous
step was adding this my user at
gmail.com
into the email field which it has done
and it has paused here and now from here
i can either run the rest of the tests
if i just click on this run current test
what it will do is it will go ahead and
execute all the steps
or even i can do a step execution from
here so say if i want to do a step
execution
i'll do this let me minimize this window
a little bit so that you can see
and i'm still again doing that step
execution so it added the password and
after this i'll say just
go ahead and complete the test so it is
clicked on your sign in
login button and it is logged in so this
is how you can use the breakpoint so
that is about adding the breakpoint
let's see what's the next
removing the break point so i showed you
so if you want to add a breakpoint you
just click here
or you can do a right click and do
toggle breakpoint if you want to remove
the breakpoint just click again on the
same place
where it has added the breakpoint or you
can always
do this toggle breakpoint so this is the
way of adding and removing the
breakpoints what is the third option
disabling now say for example my test
case is a pretty long one
okay so i might have a multiple
breakpoints so say let's add one
breakpoint here
at the email and then before clicking on
login let's add another breakpoint now
when i execute this
it is going to stop here and then again
if i say continue execution it is going
to come and stop here so let's do that
first and then i'll show you how the
disable works so let's close this window
again
execute this bring this window here can
you see this
it's paused here okay and here now you
should be able to see it now i'll say
just run after this breakpoint do you
see here
it is paused after entering the password
it has not clicked on the login button
it's paused at the click and now i'll
say again complete the test
so your click on the login button is
done and it is
logged in so it's a little bit slow yeah
now you got that
logged in page at some point of time
while i'm debugging my test case
i would want to just disable all the
breakpoints and not remove everything
for that i have an option here which
says disable breakpoint so if this
button is highlighted here that means i
have selected disable breakpoint so what
this does is when i execute this test
it ignores all these break points for
this run it ignores this break points
until i have selected this disable
breakpoint
button okay so let's see this let me
close this again and
i have enabled this disable breakpoint
is what i have selected i'll just simply
go
ahead and run this test case do you see
that it did not stop
at this breakpoint it went ahead and
completed the execution why
because i have temporarily disabled it
once i remove the selection
and run it it is again going to stop at
the breakpoints
so this is how it works so we saw adding
of breakdowns removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint
now for example like the last time we
said we want to add a breakpoint here so
now instead of doing that what i can do
also do is i can just right click on
that particular command and i can say
play to this point only so when i select
this what happens it
acts like a break point and it comes and
pauses at this particular command
where i have set play till this point so
let's try to do that so let me
close this window and then for say
type the password so here okay i'll say
right click play to
this point so it is going to execute all
the steps
until the password and it will stop here
can you see this paused in the debugger
so it again enter the debug mode and now
it is stopped at this point so now there
are multiple options now every time
last time what we did we did a step over
and also we said continue with the rest
of the test now what we will do we'll
just stop the execution so this is also
an option available say if you want to
change something here you do not want to
continue with your execution you can
simply go ahead and stop the execution
so we saw how do we use the play to this
point option now debugger command now
all these things whatever we did now
adding the breakpoints this was done in
the id
there is also a way of adding a debugger
programmatically and how do we do that
let's see now at the same place
say after entering the password so here
i will insert a command
in this command i'll just say debugger
this is all the command is
now what happens when i execute this
test cases at this point wherever it
finds this debugger command
this program enters into a debug mode
and it comes and pauses the script here
let's see this in action so simply i'll
just play the script
let's type the email id let's type the
password okay
it is going little slower here okay and
there there you go now it is paused in
deep
so this debugger did the same job as
what we did earlier with the breakpoints
now let's go ahead and just stop the
execution because
let's not keep logging into facebook
with invalid username and id okay so
this is how you can use the debugger
command so i will stop the execution
here close this window
and then now let's see the next one
let's close this window so we saw the
debug pause on exception
okay this is a very brilliant feature of
this id i'll show you how it works
now let's say let me remove this command
now i
do not want the debugger i'll say delete
this command just click let it be there
now if you look at this what we are
doing is we are
identifying these elements like email
password and then clicking on the login
button
now say for example say this click so
let's run this then i'll show you what
it is and i want it to come and
stop here okay so i will execute this
all right so now it is paused here so
now what i will do is
the click right so this is where i am
clicking is this login button so this
login button is identified by some
identifier which is an id
now there is a possibility that tomorrow
this particular id might change
or any of the locator might change on
this particular website and if that
happens the first point of failure what
you will see is when you click on this
button because
this script will say that this element
is not found
in such cases if you are using pause on
exception that is here
pause an exception what happens is
whenever this script finds an exception
it goes and pauses at that and enters
into a debug book
otherwise what happens whenever you find
an exception your complete test script
will stop executing because there is an
error and your test case fails
instead since we are in a debugging mode
if you choose this option
what happens is if there is an exception
it is going to come
get into the debugger mode and it is
going to pause the execution at that
point
and once it pauses what you can do is
you can go and correct it
and then continue your execution so
let's see that in action so now for
example
the click button so here the id is you
underscore 0 underscore
so say i try to change this let me add
1 here and then if i execute this
this script should fail for me basically
because it is not
going to find this so can you say is
trying to find this id and since this
particular element with this id does not
exist
this whole test case should fail form
now as i said
earlier in this video so if by any
chance if one of the element id
is not found so if that is not found it
always falls back
into the other locator techniques and
that is what it did in this case
it tried to locate the login button
using some other id and that's what it
says
element found with the secondary locator
okay to use it by default update the
test step and to use it as a primary
locator
and that is where the test case pass so
let's try to see if i can
make this test case fail in any way for
that let's remove this
and let's try on the email id so what i
will do is
let me try to comment this out remove
the debugger and
i will add a command here i'll say
insert new command
and in this i will say click and then i
will
use the target as id equal to email now
in this case
i do not have a fallback id because i am
not using id to recognize the element
rather i added my own command and i
added my own
locator here so now let's try with this
and
now instead of this is the right id so
what i will do is i'll just change this
id to something like underscore one so
that
this test case fails for me now let me
close this and let's run this test case
and basically this test case should fail
so if you see here
in the log it's saying trying to find
the element with id
email underscore one so this id has a
default timer
so it will keep trying to find the
element until the timeout value
is completed now there we go so it had
an implicit timeout of 30
000 so that is 30 seconds 30 000
milliseconds which was 30 seconds now
after that this test is filled so this
is the scenario we wanted
what happens here is it simply started
executing the moment it found an
exception it completely stopped so as a
tester what you need to do is you need
to go back
look for this red lines where it has
failed correct it and then rerun the
whole test
now instead of that what this pause and
exception does is
let me click on that so this is what is
selected now what it does is when i
execute this this is going to come and
stop here let's see that so let me close
this
and run this program again so run
current test i'll bring this to the side
now see it's trying to find the id since
the timeout is almost 30 seconds we need
to wait
until it pauses at this so now do you
see this now it is not exited from the
test
it is just at the same step where it is
unable to find this email field
okay and it's saying okay it failed with
an implicit timeout of 30 seconds
but now since i'm in the debugging mode
and how did i get into the debug mode by
selecting this option
pause an exception now what i can do is
i can go ahead
and change this back to the actual one
and then from here
i can just simply do this i can say run
the test now so now see what it did
the moment i changed that and i said run
it passed
and how did it pass because i gave the
right id here and that's
exactly you can do with this debugger
control flow statements
so in the legacy id uh this control flow
statements were available as plugin
so one had to install the plugin for you
to use any of this control flow
statements
however in the new ide these are
available out of box
so let's see what this control
statements are so let's go to my notes
so there are two types of control flow
statements one is conditional branching
and the other one is looping
so in conditional branching we have a
regular if else if nested if
else and end and when we talk about
looping there are multiple loops
available one is the while
end loop so how does the while end loop
work the code between the while and the
end
is executed until the expression is true
and then we have a do repeat
so do repeat where the commands after
the do will get
executed first and then the condition is
checked
and this is evaluated in the if
statement times
end so you can specify a number of
iterations you would like a piece of
code to be executed
using this loop and then there is
another loop which is a for
each loop so this provides the ability
to iterate over collection objects like
say if you have an array object with you
and you want to
say or traverse through the array and
perform certain operations on each of
the array element
so that is possible using the for each
loop so let's go
and write a test script and see how this
work
so what i will do is i will demonstrate
a use case for the if else
and then for the looping i have a few
test scripts which i have already
written which i will show you and i will
walk you through them it's a simple
counter
which we can use where it will be
incrementing the counter using one of
these loops
so we'll just see how the loops are to
be used what is the syntax to be used
and how they execute in the
id so let's go to our id now let's
minimize this
so this was our previous test case so
what i will do is
i will close this project and open
another project so
i have another project here which is
called as control flows
so as i said i have few scripts written
for some of the loops however
for the demo use case we will go ahead
and write a new script
so i'll say add new test and we're going
to be working with a demo site called
calorie
calculator so let me name the test case
itself as
calorie calculator test so let's look at
what is our
use case now in this use case this is my
use case i am saying
go to this calorie counter website okay
so let's see what that website is
i have this website open here so this is
a calorie calculator website
in this website we are saying if the
gender is
male then click on the mail radio button
so you have multiple fields here where
you are accepting the age of a person
the gender of a person the height the
weight
and then the activity level of the
person and when when you click on
calculate this is going to
give you the number of calories so for
our purpose for our demo use case what
we will do is we will store the gender
to be selected in a variable say for
example i want a gender female to be
selected
and then i'm going to write an if
condition here that if the gender is
male
right so if the gender is male then
click on the male radio button
here and then i am saying click active
from the activity drop down so there is
a drop down called activity here
in this i am going to go and select
active as daily exercise or intense
exercises three to four times a week
this is what i am going to be selecting
and if the gender is female so if the
value passed from
the gender is female then what is that i
want to do i want to click on this radio
button female
and select very active intense exercise
from this activity dropped up a very
simple use case so this is what we are
going to write in our test script
so let's minimize this window or we can
just close this window for now we don't
need this
and here so how do we start this test
case i need to
enter the url so for me to enter the url
let me go to that copy this url control
c
minimize this and control v done so now
here
i will start my recording by clicking on
the start recording button so now this
url is open now the first thing what i
need to do is
in my test script i need to write a open
command so i'll say open
and my target is what this url done the
next command is
as per our use case i want to store the
gender to be selected in a variable so
we will use the store command
and when we use the store command we
need to specify
the target so let's say the target is
f and where is that i want to store i'll
create a var
gender that's my variable so i have
stored this now what is the next thing i
want to do
so once i have stored this first is i
need to put an if statement
because my use case is if the gender is
male and if the gender is female now
since
by default the male is already selected
here so let's put an
if condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what i am going to do so here
i will say if in the command once i say
if in the target
you need to specify the condition now
condition
is i want to check for dollar that's my
variable
var gender i want to check if this is
equal to
f and how is that i can check i need to
use 3 equal to here
in double quotes i'm going to mention f
now this is what i have stored in the
variable bar gender this is what i am
going to check so
if this is the condition in the next
line now all the next lines whatever i
am going to mention are the ones which
will be executed if this condition is
true now in the next line what i want
is i want to select this radio button
correct so now what i will do
instead of writing all the commands
manually i will now use a recorder to do
that since i'm already in the recording
mode
i'll just go to the url or the website
here and i'll go click on this female so
on the right if you see these
steps are getting recorded and then our
use case also said that from the
activity drop down we want to select
very active so now if you look here all
our steps have been
recorded so i clicked on the female
radio button and then
we selected the id activity here which
is our activity drop down
and then we clicked on the desired value
which is very active and then
you end the if statement here so but we
also want to add an else statement
so instead of saying end here i will say
else
so that means if the gender selected is
male
okay what is that we want to do i want
to go and select
in the activity field as active because
the mail is already selected
so i'm not going to select it again and
then i will end the if loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my script is so let's stop the recording
here there are some
mouse move mouse up which i really do
not need so what i will do is i'll just
delete this
so this is the simple statement what i
need in the else where i'm saying
select so select is something a command
which is used
to select a web element which is your
drop down so you select the drop down
here
and once the drop down is clicked and
then you go ahead and click on
this particular target is nothing but
your active daily exercises or intense
this value from the drop down is what
i'm selecting and same
same thing what we did in the if
statement so let's remove these also
we don't mouse move at
and mouse up at so all these statements
we don't need so same thing if i'm
saying
the if statement says if the gender is f
that is female
click on the radio button then go to the
select
activity select the activity by clicking
on
very active and then end the loop so
this is all our scriptures
now let's go ahead and execute this and
see whether it works so let's
minimize this window and i will simply
say
execute the current test let's slow down
the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now i'll say
run the current test so the calorie
calculator is open
so we are passing the value f for the
gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the log
so if the gender is f which is female
yes
it found the condition to be true and
then it clicked on this radio button
it went to the select field which is
your activity drop down
it selected the very active option from
here and then
it ended now in the same program what i
will do
instead of f let's pass the value m mail
and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again
and execute the test script again so now
according to the script
we are not re-selecting the radio button
because this is already
selected by default and in this desk
script if you see now
all the green colored one if you see
okay the open command
ran successfully store commander and
successfully it came to the if condition
it checked if the gender was f or m it
found that this condition is not true so
can you see here
all these other statements in the if are
in black color that means these were not
executed
instead it came to the else part and
then it executed all the commands in the
else part so this is
how you use a if condition in your
selenium id so let's close this
now as i said there are other looping
statements what we have like
while end loop or do repeat and time set
so i have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the
while loop first so what happens in this
while loop let's see in this while loop
what i am basically doing is i have
created a counter
and i am counting it from 1 to 5 and
then displaying the value of the counter
and i am using a while loop for that
so here it says first i am setting a
counter value to 1 and
then i am saying while the counter value
is less than 5
this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that
those get executed until the condition
is true so
this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes 5 so once it sees that
counter is 5
it is going to exit the loop and just
print the value of the counter it's as
simple as while loop so just
pay attention to the syntax the way it
has been used here so this
execute script is what a simplest
statement what i have used this could be
anything
it could be any of your web elements you
are performing certain operations
say there is a calculator which you are
using say a calculator under test so if
you want to key in certain numbers until
say the sum of the numbers is 30 or
something an example like that could
be a valid use case for your while loop
so you could use that so let's execute
this
and see how the counter works so if i
execute this command so now
take a look at the log here this is
running while test
so first statement where it assigned the
counter value and then it got into the
while loop
and it executed the volume until the
counter
was assigned the value 5 and once the
counter became 5
the while loop got exited and we are
printing the counter value
so this is how a while loop is used now
similarly the same function
of using a counter i have tried to use a
do loop here so let's look at it now in
the do loop what happens is
the first the script is executed because
it's the first command after the
do statement so whatever is between the
do and
repeat if is executed and then the
condition is checked here so here what
i'm doing is i'm just first assigning a
counter with value 0
and i'm incrementing the counter every
time by 10
and then i have a condition that once
the counter becomes 50
please exit the loop that's all i'm
doing here and another statement what i
have written here is
every time the counter gets incremented
i am printing the value of the counter
so let us execute this
can you see that the way it is executing
it alright now let's see the lock
running do loop test okay the counter
has been initialized to zero
and then it executes the script and this
script is doing what it is just
incrementing the counter by 10 the
counter becomes 10
and then 20 30 40 and 50. so as soon as
it becomes 50 it's going to exit the
loop
and print the value of the counter so
one thing to notice is
there is no web element or website
testing which i am doing from the script
however one thing what the id needs is
it needs a starting point so whenever
you create a new test kit
it asks you to at least give it a
url from where it can start though it is
not going to launch that url it is going
to launch
your browser definitely before even it
executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
ide so we saw do loop we saw the while
loop there is also
something called as time slope so which
is what i have said
here times and end so this is something
you can specify
a number of iterations you would like to
perform a set of commands
so now in this example what am i doing
i'm simply incrementing
a counter by one right and i'm saying
just
increment that is this is the only
command which i want to execute
but i wanted to execute two types that's
all so there is no other conditions here
it is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which i want
to execute it twice
and the number of times which i want to
execute is what i mentioned here in the
target
so first initially i am assigning a
counter with value 100 and then i am
saying
increment this counter by one two times
and then print the value of the counter
so let's execute this and then change
the number of times so if i say run test
here
so can you see this the number of times
it got titrated and
now the value is 102 why because initial
value was 100 in the loop which is the
time slope i am saying the iterations is
two
two times execute the command which
increments the counter by one so that is
why your counter value becomes 102. now
say i
increase this to say 10 so that we get a
feel of
how the loop executes here and same
thing i will
execute it now see it you can visually
see the number of times the loop is
getting executed all right and in the
log
you can see the values also here okay
can you see here so this loop executed
10 times and hence the counter value
because 110 so these are a simple ways
of using these loops in the id so you
can implement this loops for any kind of
functionality you may want to perform on
your web elements
or any logic which you want to build for
your test cases
selenium side runner selenium side
runner is a command line runner tool
which allows the user to run your
selenium id test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases parallelly and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side runner there are
certain
uh installations which we need to do and
some of the installation prereqs are one
is you need a node.js server and what is
this node.js server
node.js server is a powerful javascript
based platform
and this is the platform which is
intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications
and it's an open source and it is
available free of cost to everyone to
use
it so we will need to go ahead and
install a node.js server for this so now
let's look at
all the installation steps which are
involved in installing the side runner
and running it okay so let's
go to my notes so the seleniumhq.org has
a complete documentation on how to
install this command line runner how to
use it and what are the different ways
we can use this
runner i'll just show you where it is
and you can
use this as a reference for any of the
tests which you are creating and
using the side runner to run it so let
me
open a new window here let's go to this
website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs
installing the browser drivers and
how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the side runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers
it also gives you complete details on
how to do that and also
using the parameters changing your base
url so this is a complete guide which
you can refer to
when you are working with the site
runner okay so let us go back to our
installation so coming back to our
installation here so the first
prereq what we need for the selenium
side runner to run is your node.js
so if you go to this website nodejs.org
let me open the same browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is
available as an installable for all the
platforms like do you have a windows
installer you have mac os installer you
have linux
installers also so if you're working
with the windows machine there are two
options for you either you can go ahead
and download the msi installer or you
can just download the zip and unzip it
into any folder
on your system okay and since i'm using
mac machine what i have done is i have
downloaded this version pkg version and
have installed it on my machine
okay so once you download say if you're
working on the windows machine so say
64-bit is what you require and you click
here and download the zip package
i'll show you how the folder structure
looks like so this is where i have
downloaded the node.js
installable now if you look at the
windows one so this is what happens when
you download the zip file and unzip it
this is the folder structure it creates
and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install
all the packages which are required on
this node.js server and i'll explain to
you what those packages are okay so once
you do this installation you need to go
and check if your
installation is gone properly or not so
for that what you do is
go to your terminal window or in your
case if you're using a windows machine
just open a command prompt right
and then you have to just give this
command here you say npm
minus v which is basically saying what
is the version of the
node.js which you have installed which
is 6.9 okay now what is this
npn npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node
and this is used to install all your
other packages or
what it is called as modules on your
system okay so now
with this we know that our npm has been
installed properly so let's move to the
next step of installation so now we have
our node.js installed
now next thing is to install the
selenium side runner now the selenium
side runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this library
using the
npn so let me go back to my terminal
again so i'll just show you the command
what it is what we use
for installing this package or the
library and since i've already installed
on my machine i will not be
doing the installation here so what you
need to do so if you are a
windows user you can directly give the
command as npn
install minus g selenium site
runner okay so this is the command which
you need to get however if you are a mac
user or a unix user
since you need to use a root user here
what you need to do is
just say sudo once you press enter here
it will go ahead and install this
complete library on your system now
since i've already installed i'm not
going to do that okay so i'll just exit
from this now once the installation is
done
how do you check whether your
installation has gone correctly or not
you have to just simply give a command
like selenium side runner minus
version okay and now this will give you
the version number
if the installation has been successful
so right now the version installed which
is the latest version is 3.11
okay so so far we have done the
installation of the node.js server we
have done the installation of the
selenium now
while you also you do this installation
you need to know that
where is the selenium ide side runner
has been installed right as
i said it's a library or what you
popularly call as module
in your npm it's for you to check
whether where it has got installed you
simply need to go to the directory i'll
say ls minus
user local library so if you see here
you'll see something called as node
modules
so whatever packages you're going to
install using npm would get
installed in this directory the node
modules directory so let's go ahead and
see whether i have my selenium side
runner there or not so i'll just
use the same ls slash node modules
okay do you see this selenium side
runner is what has got installed and
previously to that when we installed the
node.js server it also
installed this npm right so that is also
available under the same folder so far
so good
so we have our selenium ide installed
now what else is required
so we installed the nodejs we installed
the selenium side runner now we need
this browser drivers
now what are these browser drivers now
what you did using your ide was
let me in ide was we said
right in the id itself i said run the
current test and since i am using
firefox browser here any test case using
the ide
plugin on your firefox you execute is
going to execute on the firefox browser
correct
same way if you are using the selenium
ide on chrome which is an extension on
chrome
and you run the test cases there it is
going to use the chrome browser to run
the test case
however any test cases or any automation
scripts you're going to write
you want your scripts to run on all the
browsers
because you want to do a cross browser
testing right so for that purpose what
we do through command line is
we install this browser drivers right so
say if you want to run your test cases
on edge browser so that means you first
need to
install your edge browse driver on your
systems before you run your test case on
edge
process if you want to do it for chrome
similarly you need to download the
chrome web driver
and install it for firefox the same and
once you install that
then you should be able to run it on any
browser now where are these chrome
browsers available
so if you go to the seleniumhq.org let
me show you that
okay in the selenium hq website if you
go to this download tab
and if you go down here you will see
something called as third-party drivers
bindings and plugins
and here you have a list of all the
browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say i want to run
all my tests on chrome browser right so
what i do is i click here
okay in the download section go to the
latest chrome driver available
click on that and then depending on
which os you're working on if you're
working on mac just download this if
you're working on
windows you download this and once you
download the driver what you need to do
is
you keep that drivers like for example
uh can you see this driver file so this
is my driver file this is my executable
driver file so what i did was i just
downloaded this file for mac
and i copied it to the location where my
tests are present
okay now so once i have this available
what i need to do is
i need to install this driver using
again the npm command
and to install this driver what you need
to do is
you need to be in the same directory
where your driver file is present okay
in the same directory you just issue
this command you say npm
install minus g and your chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your chrome driver got it very simple
so similarly if you're working with
different browsers say if you also want
to
run your test cases with edge or
internet explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers
from this location so from here
like you have edge browser here opera
browser you have a mozilla firefox
browser so any
of the browser which you want to work
with you have to just download your
driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using npn command okay so
i will not be executing this command
again because i've already installed it
so once your drivers are installed
what's the next step we are ready to
execute our test cases okay so these are
all the installation steps which are
required to get your
command line runner which is called a
selenium side runner ready
for you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example
in this video where we wrote some of the
test cases for testing our control flows
okay so these are all the test cases now
if you observe here
i have not created any test suite here
we just had a default suite which was
created when we created the project
and we just went ahead and created all
the tests here for the side runner to
run
we need to have a test suite there so if
i just try to run the test switch let's
try to run this
what is the name of this project control
flows so i will show you what happens if
there is no test suite defined for this
so let me clear the screen
and which is our project here this one
okay so what i will do is let me simply
go ahead and execute this project so to
execute any test
this is the command which you use you
simply call selenium side runner
and the project name okay and also once
you have installed the selenium
side runner you can also check the
version of it okay so let's execute this
selenium side runner and the project
name project name is
this done so now if i press enter
now see what happens okay it's saying
running the default suite
carries here it looks for a test suite
to start its execution
okay so it picked up the default suite
which is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine
however it's a test suite failed to run
why because your test suite must contain
at least one test
and all our tests are residing outside
the test suite
we have none in the default test way
correct so what we will do
let's go ahead and create this test
suite instead of default what i will do
is i'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we will say control flow test
test suite okay done so i have renamed
it now let's go ahead and add all those
test cases which we have created to this
so i'll just simply say add test
and select all these tests so we have
around four tests here so i'll just
select all that
done so i'll save this project
i'll go to my folder id tests and
the same file name i'll just say replace
now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again
now let's see what happens okay so there
are
multiple test cases here so let's see
all these test cases will be run one
after the other sequential
so we have that calorie counter test
case and then we have
the loop test cases all right so it is
done so now let's understand the flow of
this test case
okay so this is where we started running
our test suite
so it finished first test case it
finished the second test case it
finished the third test case
and then the fourth test case so all the
four test cases it has completed
and it says all the four passed total
four and it also shows you the total
time taken for
the complete test suite to run and for
every test case what is the amount of
time required to execute that
so this is all the information which is
available here if at all there is a
failure in any of the test case that
would get
reflected here it would say for past one
phase
and total four executed okay so this is
the kind of report what you will get to
see
good so far okay so let's go back to our
notes and see whether we have done
everything so the other way of running
is say you have multiple browser drivers
installed
and you want to run this on a particular
browser so during that time what you can
do is you can use this command you can
say
selenium side runner minus c minus c is
nothing but setting the capabilities
capabilities for what for the browser
and then you give a browser name here
so you can say chrome or you can say
firefox whatever the browser of your
choice
and then give your project name so with
this what happens is if your browser is
installed
now we have to install the browser using
this command correct so if your browser
is installed
it will execute this particular test
suite
on the browser which you have mentioned
here right and that is how you use
the selenium side runner to run your
test cases on multiple process
now simply what you can do is you can
create a shell script or a batch script
you can add this
line into a bad script for the multiple
browsers and you can execute this
so that way all your test cases would
executed on all the process
so that that way you can achieve your
cross browser testing so other thing if
you remember
i also said that command line runner
like if you go back to our presentation
it says we can run it for parallel
testing now let's see how do we achieve
this parallel testing now to achieve
this parallel testing
there are certain steps which you need
to do in the id
so let's go back to our test suite so we
have this test suite so if you go here
and go to the settings
can you see this run in parallel so you
need to check
this check box to run all these test
cases in parallel so right now what
happened when we executed it
all the test cases ran sequentially one
after the other correct
so for every test case there was a
chrome browser launched and the chrome
browser was closed before the next test
was launched
now let's try to do this i i'm going to
check this check box where it says run
in parallel
and i'll say submit i'll save this
project again now
same thing i'll overwrite this project
save done
replace now let's go to our terminal
window
and run this test cases again so for
that what i will do i'll call the same
command again
however now please observe the number of
chrome browser windows it's going to
open okay i'll show you that
so it has started running the test suite
okay can you see this
three chrome browser windows open at the
same time
okay and one by one they are going to
get closed out okay
so there was also the fourth one open
but since the test case was so small
that it was too quick for us to see here
now look at the complete execution here
so what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel
okay and it ran all the test cases
parallely
you will see a big difference and since
these are very small testers you might
not be able to see a big difference in
the
execution time however if you have got a
bigger or bigger test cases which you
are running you will see a remarkable
difference in the time taken by the
suite to run the test cases still here
you can see okay it's almost 11 seconds
it took
whereas in the previous example it took
13 seconds as i said
the difference is very small because our
test cases are very very minor test
cases
right if you have a bigger test cases
where it launches the browser
launches your application under test
then you are doing multiple operations
you will be able to see a remarkable
difference when you run the test
sequentially and when you run it
parallel
so this is how you work with the ide and
this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side runner now
let's look at some of the limitations
of the selenium id the first limitation
is you cannot
export your id scripts to web driver
scripts the support is yet to be added
right
so earlier in this video i showed you
there are ways to export the scripts to
junit and python
however the previous ide did have this
capability of exporting your scripts to
web driver scripts
and that support is yet to be added to
the new id
data driven testing like using excel
files or reading data from the csv
files and passing it to your scripts so
this capability is not yet
available in the id so you cannot do
data driven testing
database testing is also not possible so
you cannot
actually connect your database read the
test data from your database or even you
cannot perform any kind of database
testing
reporting facility so it does not have a
good reporting we saw when we use the
command line runner or through the id
when we run the test there is a very
minimal reporting capabilities what we
could see so it does not really
have a capabilities of reporting like
your test ng or the report engine
what exactly is the selenium web driver
and how we can go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium web
driver so here a
selenium web driver is one of the most
important component of the selenium test
suit
when we talk about the selenium uh tools
suit over here
like we talked about okay i want to
create a whole together regression test
suit
so selenium web driver is very important
component for that
and when we talk about the selenium web
driver it allows the cross browser
compatibility
which means like you want to test your
applications you can have a test suit
there one for the chrome browser
one for the firefox one for the internet
explorer you can then say like okay i
want to test and validate my application
across all these three browsers and in
future if safari browser comes in
all you have to do is like you have to
just run the same script
with the web driver of the safari so
this web driver is not only static for
one browser
it's actually approachable for across
multiple browsers there so that enhances
the compatibility there that yes this
set test suit
even if you're writing the test suits in
case of selenium
it's not limited to one browser so it's
kind of a cross
browser here so these are small small
benefits although we're talking about
the selenium webdriver here
but if you closely see these all points
are actually defining
why exactly the selenium is best
when we talk about the weber automations
or the web testing automation here
right and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages
like uh programming languages yes it's
there it's even
supporting with different browsers and
then of course it's
supporting different operating systems
also because
you can pretty much run these test cases
uh onto linux
macs or windows whatever the platform
you feel like you want to use
you can pretty much use it so you don't
have to worry about like where exactly
this web driver
is getting deployed and from where you
are trying to refer it
so that kind of compatibility is also
something
which is available here so you don't
have to think about the
uh specific different uh versions or the
different
operating systems as such over here and
then let's talk about
further on this one so it also provides
the compatibility across
different programming languages so you
can see like what are the different
benefits you got
you got benefits like you know it's it's
supporting different programming
languages it's supporting different
browsers
and ultimately at last it's supporting
the different uh particular
uh operating systems or the platforms
here so these are small small things
like uh different uh benefits which we
get with the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so
it doesn't matter that if you're working
with java or if you're working with
dotnet
this is going to work for across a
different different platforms like
different uh
environments you can actually deploy so
these benefits are something which can
definitely help you to see like how the
overall
benefits can be achieved over here and
uh
definitely the chrome browsers are the
safari
the firefox the oprah different uh
platforms you will be able to see like
how the execution needs to be done and
how the setup used to be performed here
so that's where the
complete uh implementations uh needs to
be performed here
right and uh these web driver provides a
faster execution of the test scripts
because that's uh the kind of uh
automation which we are looking forward
that we
are not trying to see like how the
systems can be implemented so when we
are trying to talk about the automation
here
so these web drivers basically help us
to go for the faster execution also
so it's not only about uh that we are
trying to
see the setup like we are trying to go
for the configurations here
it's also like the performance and the
efficiency which we're getting with this
one is quite beneficial
so you can get an easy and a faster
execution of the test cases
so it's it's having a lot of benefits if
we talk about
in these features only itself you can
see like there are a lot of benefits
which we got
over here so it's fast it's efficient
and on top of that
it's not depending on any kind of
environment
it's quite generic like you know it's
it's something which you can use for
windows you can use it for linux
you want to use it for dotnet you want
to use it for java it's kind of uh
generic for a lot of technologies
platforms and programming
languages right now why exactly we
require the
selenium web driver like what is the
purpose of using this one so let's
explore on that part here
so selenium fib driver provides a user
friendly interface that could uh
you know it can be easily understood by
a particular person like when we uh
when you're using this selenium web
driver so this is something which
you can easily understood like it's
pretty easy for you to understand that
and it's not that much complex for you
to understand that okay you
are going to take a lot of time to
consume you're going to take a lot of
time to
uh you know understand that so that's
not a kind of
interface which we are getting when we
talk of the uh selenium web driver here
right and uh the web driver uh is
something which is
having uh much more uh features as
compared to the
uh selenium rc and selenium ide there so
when we talk about the
selenium web driver so this is something
which is having
uh much more features as compared to the
other components like you know these the
other components is also
about the selenium only but yes the when
we talk about selenium uh
web driver so it's having much more
features
as compared to the selenium rc and the
selenium id
here so you don't have to worry about
the features like all together selenium
uh
driver is something which is quite
efficient and better as compared to the
other components so
that's another benefit which we get with
the selenium here
so selenium uh we have got some other
components like a selenium
remote control here so uh rc is
something which enables the
uh the creation of uh you know automated
web applications like uh in in case of
programming languages such as java
c sharp uh node.js different different
programming languages are there so we
can pretty much
uh use the remote control uh selenium
remote control over here
which will enable the uh the creation of
the automated
web applications there so that's the
purpose of using the
selenium remote control here it's uh
it's not something which is being used
nowadays
because most of the functionalities have
nowadays moved on to the uh
selenium driver here so that's some
migration which has happened over there
and that's the reason why we are not
going to use
much of the selenium remote control over
here so that's not being used as such
as compared to the other components but
yes the selenium
webdriver is something which is quite
popular and uh because of its features
and the efficiency we are going to use
uh the particular uh
browse the uh web driver as compared to
the any other component as such here
right now selenium ide um needs
not additional any kind of setup is
required like uh you know apart from
installation of the browser because uh
in that case everything will be
integrated in that like because we are
using we are integrating the complete uh
selenium ide over here
so all you need to do is like you need
to do the installation of chrome browser
that's also because you want to go for
the
uh specific chrome driver which you
require for the execution of the test
cases so for that only you are basically
trying to install the chrome browser but
other than that there is no other
component which you actually require
when we talk about the
selenium ide here
so the ide makes the life
easy because it helps us to go ahead
with the debugging mode here like a kind
of a debugging environment you will be
able to do that
so even if there is any kind of issue
any any kind of problem which comes up
so it will be very easy for you to debug
those things and go ahead with that part
so uh tracking the exceptions managing
the exception so all those things can be
easily handled with the help of the
selenium ide here so selenium ide is
something which is kind of a bigger
package which is
uh further comprising of different
different components like it's something
which
is giving us a variety of things here
right
now how exactly the selenium fib driver
is
at all different from the selenium rc
and ide because those are also the
solution which is available there from
this lane now unlike the selenium ide
selenium web driver can actually work
with different browsers so that's
something which we have already focused
on that it's having the compatibility
across multiple
uh browsers there that's the first
benefit which we get over here in this
one
now also the web drivers is something
which does not require
any user to start the server or anything
like that there so just in case of
a selenium rc you have to start some
server because
you're ultimately connecting to that
server and that's how the communication
is happening
but that kind of stuff is not there in
the selenium web driver here
also this linear web driver is an api
and it's not a gui based plugin so
uh it's it's something which can easily
handle like
uh it's having the um quite uh efficient
uh
connectivity or you can say like the uh
integration is also good there because
we most of the applications nowadays are
working on the api
format which is pretty generic so we
there is no gui based
interface which we have to explore which
we need to integrate here so it's all
like
the api is called which we need to do in
order to use uh make use of the
selenium web driver here now in selenium
webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium rc and
selenium id so which is not a kind of
object oriented in nature but selenium
webdriver is something which is
quite object-oriented here also uh
web driver the selenium web driver is
actually uh supports
multiple listeners right
so uh which is available there as
compared to selenium rc and
selenium id here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there
also it also supports the testing of the
ios and android which is not being
supported in the
and ide there because most of the
applications
uh nowadays also have the counterpart
android or the ios applications
so if you don't have the interface or
integration with those platforms
then it's a incomplete way of testing
here so not only the web applications
but even the mobile applications also
now getting integrated with the help of
the
selenium web driver here so these kind
of features which is not
exactly available in the rc or the id
over here but
definitely it's it's going to be
available there in case of selenium web
driver
so what exactly is the overall need of
the web driver like the selenium web
driver here
so uh let's talk about that that uh how
exactly we can use it for the software
automation here so there are a couple of
benefits which is available there so
let's focus on that one by one
the very first one is the open source
now it's something which is available or
which is
uh available as an open source over here
which means like
uh it's something which you can use
without any license without any cost
uh just like that you can go to the
selenium.dev website and you can start
downloading the
uh selenium related uh uh deals or
selenium related components
second is support it's having the
support for different kind of
programming languages
not only for the java based applications
it's actually supporting like different
different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool
and then can serve eyes or that can
support multiple programming
languages here several operating system
support yes it's not only related to the
windows or linux platform here so it's
actually supported across
windows linux macos a different
operating systems are actually supported
here so different
operating systems is supported by this
uh particular selenium here
uh multiple frameworks are there so
that's a multiple framework support
which is available in this one
uh user friendly it's quite user
friendly there and the developers were
more comfortable with the java
programming languages
so they get uh quite uh comfortable and
integrated with the
selenium because it's also using the
same java syntax over here in this one
it's cross device testing uh definitely
both mobile desktops
are different platforms different
operating systems mac os
uh ios android different uh platforms
are actually supported
by this uh particular selenium here so
selenium webdriver is something which is
having like
cross device testing here community
support is there
it's kind of open source yes but uh it's
having a very good community like a lot
of people are actually there
who can contribute to this selenium you
can get the information from there and
it's kind of a
huge efforts like a kind of a huge
community efforts which you can
uh see over here in this case also a
compatibility testing so it's having a
very good compatibility here so
uh when you're working with this uh
selenium so it's
uh compatible with pretty much any
programming languages
any platform any operating system so
that kind of
of benefits you get with the help of
this selenium web driver here
and uh unlike uh selenium rc
you don't have to start any kind of
server component here uh which you need
to connect so it's like uh
on demand like when you're running the
scripts a kind of a local chrome browser
will be
uh initialized and your test cases will
be executed and uh
performed and that that's how the whole
executions will be performed there
so there is no involved like you have to
go somewhere start some server
start somewhere remote server there and
then the communication or the execution
of the test cases will be initialized so
it's not like that kind of communication
here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver
uh architecture here now in this one
there are some different uh components
which is available there in this
architecture components the very first
one is the selenium language bindings
here
now these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like java
ruby python c sharp javascript these are
the different
programming languages bindings which is
available there then with the help of
json wire protocol these are going to be
connected to the different drivers
now browser drivers is the one where
exactly the request will be sent out
so the selenium web driver is actually
going to connect or send the request to
these drivers
so um depending on the platform also and
depending on the different uh
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for chrome
driver you want to go for firefox you
want to go for opera you want to go for
safari
these are the different browsers which
is available there earlier the
uh internet explorer was also there but
now in the latest version say it
each browser or h driver is something
which is available there
and uh these are going to be connected
through the actual uh
particular browsers like the chrome
firefox and all so
it will be sending the request over the
http
uh http uh that request will be sent out
to the real drivers so the browser
drivers and then the real drivers will
be there
so the web driver is going to connect to
the chrome driver
and then in fact from there the chrome
driver is going to
initialize the chrome browser and then
the whole request will be processed the
websites will be open the clicking the
access everything will be done after
that on that case
so these are the different uh steps
which is involved
when we are basically going for uh from
one step to another like where the
communications
or will be performed over here in this
case
right so uh again uh it's not dependent
on any programming languages
it's not dependent on any kind of uh
browser or any kind of components here
so right from the uh language bindings
it will go to the json wire protocol
from there it will be sent out to the
browser drivers
various browser drivers whatever the
browser drivers you want to use
you can use that and then those drivers
are actually going to connect with the
real drivers or with the
real uh browsers over here so that the
communications or the
uh exact end result you should be able
to see
so for instance if you run a particular
chrome browser
uh chrome driver there so you will be
able to see like a chrome browser
getting initialized and the website is
getting accessible so all that activity
will be
happened or will be performed over there
so these are the parts of the
sequence these are kind of architecture
components like one to another these
will be
processed or these will be executed here
right
so uh these programming language these
selenium programming languages again
it's actually a kind of a generic one
so these are the client libraries which
is available there depending on this one
for example for java i can download some
binaries
i can download some jar files so that
will be referenced or utilized into my
source code
for ruby it's maybe like different uh
third-party libraries or shared
libraries which will be available there
for python it will be available in the
form of modules uh csharp javascript so
each and every programming languages
is actually having its own uh
libraries now these libraries are
actually required
so that we can get the whole interface
of the selenium
it's okay like i am writing some test
cases i'm writing the complete test suit
and i'm using it
but unless and until i import my
selenium libraries
it will not work for me i will not be
able to work on that part because
i will not be able to get those features
as such in order to get those features i
need to download these
bindings or these kind of language
bindings there
corresponding to my programming language
and these are easily available on the
selenium website so if you go to the
selenium website whatever the
programming languages you want to follow
you can download these findings
these windings will be nothing but the
archives where you will be having some
kind of
executables depending on that
programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these
bindings in order to interact in order
to initialize the selenium
so then we will be going to the json
wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers
now uh programically using these with
the help of these uh
client libraries we're going to send the
request to the web drivers
it also helps to enable the transfer of
data between a server and client
because of course uh you have to uh get
your end result process right so that's
where you need to
go for the execution so what you're
going to do is like you're going to see
like okay i'm going to run
or i'm going to execute this json wire
protocol over here
and it's going to connect between my
client libraries and the web drivers
here
so that's the communications and the
connectivity which we want to establish
or we want to provide here
now these are selenium browser drivers
are actually
specific browsers now because the json
wire is going to connect
to the specific browsers
the drivers here so that the
communication can be happen
now these drivers are actually used
uh as in drivers in order to interact
with the exact browser because these are
not the
exact browser now if you want to
interact with the chrome
then you definitely have to use the
chrome driver if you want to use for the
fireworks then you have to use the
firefox driver
so depending on the programming language
you have to define
like which driver you really need to
process or you need to really go ahead
with that part so
that's where the selenium browser
drivers really comes into the picture
and then uh the exact browsers will be
there now once the
executions will be done at last you will
be able to see like all these browsers
getting open
if you're going to use the chrome
browser then chrome browser will be
initialized
if you're using the firefox then the
firefox browser will be initialized
so whatever the browser or driver
specific driver you will utilize
so according to that you will see a
particular browser
being invoked over here so that's how
the communication happens and it's kind
of a sequence here like step by step
here
so each and every stage is very
important because that's how the uh
communication will happen over here and
you will get the end result or the
desired output
if you uh have any kind of uh failing
component over here
so that's where the whole uh
connectivity will be breakdown and you
will not be able to get
any kind of values x expected so
this is something which we really need
to consider or we need to go ahead with
that part here
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more so what are the different
drawbacks which we got with the help of
the selenium web driver here so when we
talk about the
selenium web drivers so what are the
different drawbacks which we are getting
over here
so that we can understand like how
exactly we can
talk about that part here now the
drawbacks of a selenium webdriver is
something which we
uh you know use because this is kind of
uh
main component you can say like you know
using which you can actually do the
complete validation
but the problem is that it's not
something which you can use
for the desktop application so for the
desktop application this does not works
so this web driver is something which is
uh supported for the web applications
only
it's not something which we can use for
the desktop applications as such
so that's a kind of a limitation which
we get with the help of the
selenium web driver here so it's only
there for the websites for the web
portals
secondly uh the uh it requires the
expertise of the
teams uh you know in order to manage
these scripts because
these are the programming languages of
course there although it's a test suit
but uh
it requires a programming language
efforts as such in order to
go ahead with that in order to manage
these things so
it requires a kind of expert team uh who
can actually handle these
scripts or who can work on these
requirements so uh
that's a kind of a overhead because if
it's not like very easy to manage these
like uh pretty much a person who is an
expert in these things can only handle
these kind of requirements so
it's kind of a limitation where we will
be only depending on an expert
to manage these scripts as such right
now um it's not having any kind of uh
reporting builder reporting capability
over here so
it's not available in this one so test
reports which is getting generated here
is uh with the help of the junit and
test ng
so there is no default uh reporting
mechanism which is available over here
in this one so we
only have the mechanism of the j unit
like we can extend
our uh test scripts in selenium by
integrating with jh unit and the test
ng here so that we will be able to get a
proper reporting
so for the uh reporting purposes we
actually use the components like this
junit and the test ng over here to
go ahead with that so these are the ways
in which we can actually go for the
integration where we can integrate the
selenium
and the other frameworks like junit and
the test ng
kind of components here and that's the
whole basis because
alone the selenium webdriver is
something which can
execute the scripts process the request
but it's not going to
handle any kind of uh reporting
mechanism so reporting
mechanism is something which you can
only get with the help of the
junit or the test ng here because these
are the
additional packages which you need to
integrate so it's it's a kind of a
custom solution which we need to design
uh you know where we don't have only the
web driver
available over here like the core
components but also we have like other
components available over there which
will be of course having the other
components like test ng and the j unit
here so that's also something which you
can integrate
all together with this one right also uh
it's very difficult to manage there is a
lot of management
or the maintenance activity which we get
over here
also it's very difficult to scale this
up also depending on the load or
depending on the requirement
it's very difficult to scale it up also
if you are using for some infrastructure
some
kind of a load there so having it
increased to a different level it's kind
of a difficult task here
also maintenance activity is quite huge
so if you want to have a proper
maintenance
or management you have to get a couple
of uh
you know experts in that case so that
they can easily manage those things
so these are the different requirements
which is available there where we can
see like how exactly the
we can you know manage all these things
now
it also uh you know allows the across
browser uh compatibility testing here so
uh it's something which can easily
handle like different
requests across the browsers so um image
testing is not available so
uh you don't have to uh you know use the
selenium alone like selenium alone is
not compatible for testing the images
here
so if you really want to test the images
so you have to
uh integrate securely uh in with your
selenium so that you can have a complete
package
so again uh selenium in some cases it's
not sufficient for
like most or a variety of things there
so in some cases you have to actually
go for another tool integrations so that
you can have the complete details you
can have the complete component here
so that's where the uh real mechanism
comes in like yes
uh you don't have the uh exact single
tool available for taking care of
all these things but yes you can have
all these things
integrated uh with the other tools other
components there and from there you will
be able to get a complete uh values
and the complete uh implementation here
right so these are the uh you know
different uh
drawbacks which we get once we start
using the
a web driver here so let's go ahead
with the uh particular demo over here to
understand like how
exactly the selenium web driver can be
utilized can be used
so that we will be able to run some test
scripts here so
we are going to run or prepare a test
suit here so that we can get it executed
with the help of selenium
so that's what we are trying to do here
so for this one we require some couple
of components to be there
like the jdk eclipse and all so let's
talk about that component so let's go
ahead with the
implementation so let's begin with the
uh
configurations of the swift driver here
now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the
java here now let's uh go ahead with
this url so now this one
is something where we have to see like
how uh we can go for the installation of
the
jdk here now here we need to go for the
jdk installation that's the version
which we want to install
now it a variety of versions are
available there like which version you
want to
install you can go with that uh jdk 11
8 it is the most stable version so you
can go ahead with the jdk 8 here
so you can download here different
platforms it's available like windows
platform
uh whatever the platform is there all
you need to do is like you need to just
download this exe file
now once the exe file is downloaded so
what happens like you will be able to do
the installation
now i have done the installation of this
jdk here so
if i have to open my uh command prompt
here
i would be easily able to see that i'm
using a jdk version
of 1.8.0 over here in this one
so that's a version which i'm using but
again of course
if you're using some different version
of cdk that will also work here
the only thing is that you need to see
that you need to go for a compatible
browser
a compatible java and the compatible
eclipse
tool here so that's what you require now
what i'm going to do is like i'm going
to install
or download the eclipse browser also now
let's download the eclipse here now
we got an official website of eclipse
here from where we can download the
exact clips
different platform you can do it like
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here
so uh here the uh download will work
just like that you can do the download
here even if you want to go for a
different
offerings like you want to go for
different platform uh
you feel like uh you want to decide that
which package actually you need to do
because uh in the eclipse also you got
like different things
um ide eclipse ide for the java
developers
for uh the c plus c plus plus so
different uh different uh operating
system and different uh packages are
also available there
so it's basically up to you like which
exactly environment you want to follow
so i want to download this 64 bit over
here in this one so let's download this
here
now uh let's again download this this is
kind of an exe file which is available
here so let's download it again
now um it will be working on like a it's
kind of a download
which is getting started over here it's
close to 102 mb which is available there
this is the executable
which is going to help us to do the
installation of eclipse
now this is the uh latest version uh
2020 version
is what it is getting installed over
here um
and uh it's completely there i have
already got the jdk installed because of
the fact that
using this jdk the eclipse will be open
if you don't have the jdk installed the
java runtime then the eclipse will not
be installed for you
so in order to get the eclipse installed
and executable perfectly
fine you need the jdk installed to be
done here
so we got like one more minute here to
complete the download and this is just
102 mb
package or installer which is available
there and once this is installed we will
be able to get
ahead with this installation of the
eclipse here
so once the eclipse is installed all you
can do is like you can go ahead with the
uh particular configurations you can
create some couple of cro uh
projects in case of eclipse um then
we'll also see like how we can download
the
uh programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download
so these are the different components
which you're going to explore while
working on this one
so uh let's wait for this uh download of
this
executable to be performed here so that
we will be able to proceed further with
this one so
let's wait for that so it's hardly
taking one minute more to complete it
so selenium and eclipse both are the
open source one you're getting a donate
to a class community page there because
that's the donation which they want
but again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here
so you don't have to pay any cost as
such over here in this case so there is
no cost associated with this one
so just 10 seconds more and uh then we
can pursue with the installation of the
eclipse here
and here we go so the installer is
almost done here so i can
pretty much go ahead and open the file
so
this will help me to do the installation
of the eclipse here
so the eclipse installer is what it's
getting started
initialized over here in this one uh now
the java runtime is already available
with me
we require the uh specific uh
jdk installed the java command line is
working we can download the eclipse here
and uh then we can go for the uh
specific executions like we can go and
uh download the uh browser drivers here
now the thing is that if you really want
to go for the chrome browser or firefox
or any kind of those things
in case of your particular system in
case of your windows machine over here
you don't have to necessarily go for any
kind of
uh a kind of a driver as such here
because of the fact
we got a links over here like uh this
mozzarella for the firefox
uh this one is there for the particular
selenium this one is there for the
chrome
now chrome is something which we have
already got here like we have already
got the
chrome browser installed but
let's see like uh we can download this
driver also like uh depending on that we
can go ahead with that part
and then we can also download the java
client uh libraries over there from the
bindings over there from the uh specific
selenium.dev website over there and
we can download and we can integrate it
so let's do it one by one so first of
all let's see like you know once the
installation of the eclipse is done
and then we'll be able to go ahead with
the third component or the third
request which is the a web driver or a
particular chrome browser
a driver over here so this installer is
going to give us the same thing here so
i'm going for the
uh specific java developer here so let's
go for the uh
installation here now this is going to
uh install
uh the java 8 right uh this runtime over
here
so if you feel like you want to use the
jdk 11 because that's something which is
available there
now if you're using an existing ones
like uh you're already using uh
an existing ones over here the jdk and
also
that's where the installation is going
on like uh it's it's going in with that
part here
but we already got some system related
uh jdks which is installed but uh you
feel like you want to go ahead with this
one
um like you're not doing this separate
installation of the jdk or jre so there
you can actually use this once here so
let's select this one like i pretty much
want to use like
any one of these uh jvms over here like
which i feel like i can configure or i
can utilize so that's pretty much
we can do here so it's like uh we can
use these variables like
we can go for these jvms or if you feel
like you can go for an external jvm also
there so it all depends on you like how
the
uh installation you want to perform here
right and this is the location let's uh
go for the
desktop location there and or you can go
for the default location also over here
in this one
so let's go for the installation now
just accept it
and uh the installation will be
proceeded over here so
uh even if you have not done a separate
jtag installation so this will basically
have
a jdk installed i have selected the java
11 over here
uh but you can go for the 15 also in
this case in this scenario so the whole
installation of the eclipse is what it's
happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component there which is like
uh dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components
and chrome browser again it's already
something which is installed there but
we'll see like how we can download the
chrome driver
how we can configure and we can utilize
that so that's what we're going to
follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something uh which we are trying
to do
like uh it's this installer is pretty
much downloading some couple of
components
as such uh like this j uh j
jre is something which is getting
installed or downloaded from the
uh eclipse website and uh that's where
the uh
you know all the components is getting
installed so one by one
all the components will be downloaded
from the eclipse website here
and it's a complete package which means
like you don't have to necessarily go
for a separate installation there is
another installer which is available for
eclipse where you just have to unzip up
for
a zip file and you can pretty much use
it but in this case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside that so that's
an another component which is being
available here
so the installation is still going on
there so
uh it depends because all these things
are getting cached
up from the internet so it also depends
on like how much size of file is getting
downloaded here
so let's uh you know let's wait for the
installations to be complete
and then we'll proceed further so now
the installation is done so we can
launch our eclipse here so that's what
we are trying to launch here
now apart from eclipse what happens like
we require some other components also
like uh we require this lyrium web
driver also there
so for that we have to download the uh
java related client bindings
so for that uh chrome browser first of
all it's already installed so we don't
have to
do any kind of installation there uh yes
i can go ahead
with the exe file like of the chrome
browser driver
that i'm going to use it so i'm going to
open the uh specific downloads here now
in this segment what happens like
selenium.dev is the website which is
available there now here we can go for
the downloads
now related to your programming language
whatever the programming language you
are trying to use so you can download
the language binding for that
now language binding is something which
is utilized so using which you will be
able to see like how
uh you can establish the connectivity
it's just a kind of a libraries where
you can do the connectivity and you can
see that execution
so what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to download this bindings here
so let's download this one now it's
again available as a zip file which is
available there so
uh depending on the version you can go
for the beta download version also
now i'm going for the stable version
which we want to utilize we want to
refer it
so it's going to download zip file so
this zip file will have all the
jar files and all the required libraries
there
and when i'm going to create a project
into my eclipse at that moment of time
i would be requiring all these
components like all these
various uh libraries i should be added
up into my
uh project as such in case of the
eclipse so that's what i need to do here
so let's go to the eclipse here so here
we're going to expand this
like a package explorer and here we're
going to
go to file new and java project
so i'm going to create a java project
over here so um
in which we will be getting some couple
of class files in which we will be
having the
uh selenium related test cases like how
we want to process or how we want to
execute that part
so i'm going to proceed with that part
so let's put the
uh project name here so i'm going to say
like selenium
just a project name i want to put uh
then the jdk
now if you want to go for a specific jdk
like another
version so you can go with that but
right now i'm using like jdk 1.8 which
is pretty much configured so i can use
that
uh you feel like you want to use uh the
specific jre
of gre which is available as part of jdk
1.8 that also you can use or if you want
to use like a jdk so that also something
which you can utilize over here in this
one
so there are different things like you
can configure the gres also
so if you have some custom path which uh
where you have the java available or the
jdk or jre is available there
so that also you can easily refer it so
you can simply say that
yes uh this so and so location i want to
refer i want to see my
source code so that's where you can do
the you can go for the execution
now once you're providing these values
like the install gres which you want to
provide which you want to process here
next thing what you need to perform is
like you need to go ahead with that
execution so i'm completely okay with
the jdk whatever the environment i want
to
process i can easily do that and i'm
completely okay with that
right so let's go with that part and
then click on
next and uh this is the source directory
which is available there right and
if you want to add any additional
libraries so uh here exactly you can add
your
selenium related libraries using which
you will be able to see your source code
working fine but i'm not going to do
that activity here
so i'm going to do that later on so that
we can get our complete things in a
sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the gi related libraries and the source
folder here
so right now it's completely empty
project there is nothing available as
such here
and what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to create a class file over here
to see with the specific source code of
the selenium to
how the web driver is getting loaded up
and processed so
that stuff we are going to talk about
here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this
selenium programming language bindings
here so let me extract it
uh you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also
or if you wish you can keep it aside in
some specific folder because
it's just going to be referenced with
every project so it's just
kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of a
package or this kind of share library
you can easily utilize and you can
implement it
so we are just trying to extract it now
once extraction is done so you will be
able to see like some couple of files
and folders
uh now this is having a particular two
executable files like client embed
combined
this is kind of connecting uh acting
like a selenium client and which is
using to connect and
uh process all the requirements and we
also have a sources file which is
available there
for this one but again it's something
which depends on the requirement
so you don't have to put the sources uh
jar file also over here because that's
not required
so you can pretty much uh use this
executable jar file because in this one
you will not have any kind of source
then of course uh your selenium related
jar file is
further on depending on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are also
uh something which you should be putting
up into your uh
specific uh shared library so that
your selenium-related jar files should
not started failing so
uh we'll we'll try that scenario also so
that we can get the complete output and
complete in chance here
so let's see now uh we'll go to this uh
we'll import this particular file over
there
and uh for that we have to write a class
file so let's see like how we can do
that
so we have already got the selenium web
driver so uh the eclipse is what we have
followed so we have created a new
java project now we want to create a new
class file
the build path configurations we will be
taking care of that
later on but right now we are going to
see like how we can proceed further with
that
so i i'm going with this uh specific
component here right so uh whatever the
browser or whatever the
a driver you want to follow you can do
that so firefox if you want to use you
want to use our chrome
browser it all depends on you like it
all depends on the
way like how you want to configure it so
uh let's see
let's uh import this uh particular
component here now if the
uh specific uh firefox browser is
installed that's great if it's not
installed so you can just go
back here so here you will be able to
see like this browsers
like these specific components which is
available here
so this is the driver which is available
so for the windows 64-bit you can again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want uh
like if you want to use for the chrome
browser you can go for that if you want
to go for the firefox
edge whatever the driver you feel like
you want to go you can do
go with that part here so let's uh open
this one here
and extract this one also so that we
should be able to refer it over here
into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there
now all we need to do is like we need to
just open our eclipse there so
in our eclipse uh we should be using or
we should be referring to this one here
so this is a kind of a path which is
available
similarly we will also be giving a path
over there so that
we can refer to that specific uh driver
that
driver over here so let me open that and
uh
let's see so i'm going to create a class
file here you can create a package
uh called calm and uh
in that package you can further on
create a class file
like
selenium test uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name
so uh you feel like you want to give
some different name you can
go for uh you know any kind of class
name over here but this is something
which
is something we are going to see like
how the execution
needs to be performed and needs to be
done here so
there are different uh you know names
like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also
now if you see closely here let me save
the file here
now in this one you're getting some
errors uh related to this one like
you're getting the uh error codes
related to the imports here like how
the uh specific execution should be done
here right
now the thing is that uh this is
something which is uh really causing the
problems uh like how the import or the
execution should be done
right also uh the thing is that uh
we require these imports to be available
there right so uh that's definitely we
are requiring over here
and uh that's that's something which we
uh require
uh we want to process as such also so
right now let's uh have an uh particular
declaration of the
uh package also there because it's
something which is there in the comp
package so let's have the
package com also here so it's there in
the comp package
uh but again those errors are not
related to that so these are like
related to the configurations which we
are trying to put
and uh during the copy paste there might
be a conversion of the code so
that i have taken care great so uh let's
see
now what i have to really do is like we
have to see like how we can proceed
further on the uh for the most
executions and
we need to get this driver like we need
to get this one so i'll right click on
my project here
and go to the build path and click on
configure build path
so first i'm going to uh add my binding
jar file there the java binding the jar
file which i downloaded
just now this client combined one here
so only this jar file we are trying to
add up over here
and with that most of the uh related
errors
related to that uh imports will be
resolved now i'm not sure that how it's
going to work
how it's going to uh you know function
whether it's going to success or failure
that's a different story
but yes all you have done is like i
right clicked on my project
went to the build path went to the
configure build path here
and went for the add external charge so
these are the external charge which you
have to do
we have to put up over here so only the
combined client combined jar file is
what i have put up over here in this one
in the reference libraries you will
immediately be able to know that
part of the jar file here now this is
the directory where you will be having
the exe file available for that driver
for the firefox
so let's get the path for our component
also so we got the path so let me paste
it over here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the
folder where we got our driver available
here and let's try to resolve it let's
try to run it over here
great so now i'm going to right click
here
just say run as and java application
now in this one i got an error saying
that some com
google common collect immutable map some
class file
is not available there this is of the
fact that i did not imported those
uh dependent jar files also which we got
downloaded
from the uh java binding file here so
that zip file was also having some of
the jar files there in the library
folders
so in this one also you will be able to
see like some executions of the jar
files is required over here
as an inputs as a standard imports so
let's import this one and
this is the reason why we got the error
at the first place because we are not
importing those ones
those jar files which is being required
by our client
combined jar file also so these are the
dependent jar files which we are trying
to import here
so ultimately at last you will be able
to have your referenced
libraries available here with all these
jar files component available here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require
is the browser now i have the chrome
browser but unfortunately i don't have
the firefox browser so let's go ahead
and download the firefox browser so for
that
let's open the browser so i'm going to
download a
firefox browser over here into my system
so uh the official website is something
which is quite good so we can go for the
download firefox here
now uh why because i require now i'm
using the firefox here if i am
using the chrome browser i will not be
having or facing any kind of issues as
such but since
i'm using the firefox uh driver so i
require firefox browser so
uh the uh dependency of the uh browser
is there when we want to go ahead
because
uh pretty much my core base is going to
connect or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver ultimately internally
or require a browser show that it can
perform these occasions it can do that
execution
so these drivers are going to just uh
communicate
between the your source code and the uh
actual browser here
so uh after the driver you also required
the browser to be installed like
the chrome browser to be available here
so that you can pretty much use it and
you can perform the configuration
so let's see uh we are getting the
browser over here in this one
and we got the browser installed
perfectly fine over here
so we should be able to see the browser
uh because in this one we are basically
trying to open the browser and
getting our website called
www.google.com here
and then we are having a particularly
one and then ultimately the driver is
getting cured here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as
java application so you will be able to
see the browsing here so okay it's
connecting
the uh browser the firefox exe file is
getting executed
a browser is getting executed and it
will be maximized automatically
you can see here like it's you know
getting maximized automatically here
and uh we just have to wait for a couple
of seconds more
and uh here we go we got the a browser
closed automatically also because there
was a slip of
a couple of seconds over here and you
got the failure like you got the
complete
uh component or it cuts the driver close
there driver close means that definitely
the browser will also be closed here
and you can see here that the uh
specific uh
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here
it's actually showing us like how the
executions and the
setup needs to be performed or needs to
be done here
so this is the way that how
the bro the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case
you got the browser execution and
everything will be work perfectly fine
so again i'm right clicking over here
just click on run as java application
the same browser will be open again it
will be automatically refreshed
you will see that progress like this and
after a couple of seconds
uh the thread will be on sleep but yes
after that it will be closed
automatically over here
so like that you can program how to open
your website
how to proceed further from there you
want to click on some buttons you want
to
do some processing that's all up to you
like how you program
how you code it over here so this
completely helps you to see like
how exactly you can go ahead with the
complete program
and this program will help you to uh
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases
so this is what we have in this demo
where we saw like how we can configure
the different drivers
the web driver the browser driver and
ultimately the browser and the selenium
web driver here
so you're using this linear web driver
over here which is going to invoke the
browser driver and this browser driver
is going to invoke the browser
as such over here in this case so that's
it for this demo
let's move on to main content so that
was the demo in which
we executed a very simple program in
order to execute the
selenium web driver which is going to
further invoke the
browser driver the firefox driver and
then it was invoking the
uh specific implementations there right
so this is what we did and if we
summarize this demo so in this one we
downloaded uh the selenium web driver we
installed it we configured it
we integrated the eclipse with the
selenium web driver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be
booked and the previous cases yes the
browser was invoking our www.google.com
website there
and we were getting the response
accordingly and that was the executions
mechanism like that's the whole basis
that how the selenium test cases used to
work and used to be integrated over
there so this is the complete way that
how
exactly we did this demo here first of
all
you should have java eight in your
system to run
selenium three point zero three plus
average so you should have java eight if
you want to run selenium 3 plus okay
you can verify whether you have java
version 8 plus or not by going to
command prompt say java
hyphen version and then see if you have
the latest version of java or not
if you don't have download it from the
link provided right here
and install that in your system and
configure it second selenium 3.3.1 is
mentioned right here but
now the latest version is 3.5.3 you can
simply
download the latest version whatever you
get from the selenium
website okay uh here it is talking about
test ng so we'll be talking about test
ng at the later point
when we will be talking about unit
testing framework so as of now you don't
need to download it
no need okay you don't need to download
it
just set up selenium and java in your
system and make it ready
because from now onwards we'll be
writing the script of solarium
now let's talk about the project setup
steps
so first create a new java project and
give a name
second create a new source folder and
provide this
uh situation this source folder is
automatically created you don't need to
worry about
it right click on test source folder
create a new package and provide
a situational name this is scripts so
here we'll be going
create a new package we have already we
already have a package that is called as
selenium examples
so we will use it right click on test
source folder create a new folder and
name it as resources
right click on the project create a new
folder and name it slip
so why they are calling it as resources
and why they are calling it as lift
let me tell you that so they are asking
us to create two new folders in the
project
so by saying new folder
give it a name resources in this
resources we will be going to keep
all our drivers that is chrome driver
firefox driver all those drivers there
is also to go
it is also asking me to create
vent it is also asking me to create one
more folder
that is called as lib okay
so in this lab we will be going to store
all
our selenium libraries
okay so earlier how we set up so there
are two ways to set up
one is you are going to the project go
to properties
java build path add external jars and
you select the libraries which you want
to add
okay the second one is you go to lib
you don't go you just create a left
folder you go here
copy the libraries paste it here inside
this
after pasting it doing the right click
do the right click and say
say here's that let's see
i completely not here
why i'm not getting that option you can
try it right now
if you like so download the libraries
create a new folder right in this in
your project
by creating the folder you will get here
liv
and you can paste all your libraries
right into this folder
and then you can select your library do
the right click
and then you will get an option add to
build path
you can then add your libraries directly
to your build path
so how it helps it actually helps you to
manage all your libraries at one project
and it will be configured in your
project
how to add libraries into the lib folder
just copy the library
come here and paste it and done
so here if i go to lib folder copy it
and paste it
and then it will be added or you can do
the right click
go to properties copy this path the
location where this lib folder is
present you can copy it
paste it here and here you can paste
your library
this is also an option after that you
select your libraries do the right click
and there you will get an option add to
build
path okay and then the libraries will be
added to the
build path
we might i would suggest you to try
yourself as well
it will be there in your in your eclipse
if
you won't face any issues like i am
facing
so that's what we do uh it is just that
uh we do create a library here so that
we can maintain all the libraries in one
folder in the same project
instead of you know go and explore
libraries or search for the libraries uh
it's completely there is no difference
you can use
any way you can use any approach just
that
when you do the right click in the
project and go to properties and
uh do add external charge then
it is getting added from some different
location
but here you are creating a folder in
your own
project where you are working so you
don't need to go
here and there to search for the
libraries
that's it yes it goes to the reference
libraries regi
after you add it to the build path it is
you know adding it to the adding files
to the left reference library it is same
no difference do the setup okay
today itself so here you can see they
have created a
a lib folder on top of that they have
created two more folders that is one is
source and one is test
source is what that we actually get
it there is no need to create test
folder if there is a
maven comes if you know built to enable
comes
then you will see automatically all
these architecture will be created
it's by default comes when you work on
living
okay this is how they are saying that
your folder structure will look like
this
then they are asking us to add you know
libraries
so they are asking us to copy the
downloaded psyllium jar into the lip
folder
like i have shown you this one
they are asking us to add the drivers in
the resources folder
so just add the drivers in the resources
folder
asking us to test add the test ng
library
just ignore for the time being will not
be going to do that
and here you can see that guys okay
great obey
i hope you must be getting the build
path option
and add to build path by right clicking
on the project
so there are two ways like i mentioned
one
is you select all the libraries and say
build path add to build path or another
way is
add to external jar files so
you can choose any way it's up to you if
you don't have chrome and ie then
install those browsers as well guys it's
for you as well if you don't have ie and
chrome just download them
as well no surajit you don't require any
github account to get the jaco driver
you just what you need to do is go to
jaco driver version and here you have
windows
zip file click on it and it will
download the zip file for you and that's
it done you don't need to create any
kind of a you know any account and all
that
if you have an older version of firefox
then install the latest version
so that we can work on latest version
and guys make sure that you have chrome
in firefox
because these are the main browser
people uses and
will be working on all these browsers as
well so this is how they are showing us
that you know
it has been added so they have
maintained the resources in a package
but we are maintaining it in a separate
folder and it is always suggested
maintain your drivers in a folder
you can for the time being you can
ignore this
the package okay so let's create this
architecture
of course i have the architecture
correct so we have already created that
and but in resources let's copy the
jaco driver chrome driver and i driver
as well
so let's go to that uh selenium
resources so here i have stored all my
library all my
you know exes and libraries etc so
here i need to add the jaco driver how
to download tracker driver and repeating
it once again just take a look
here for the jekyll driver click on this
version clicked on it you will get this
page
go down you will get a zip file here
click on it and download it
and unzip it download it and unzip that
that's it
second chrome driver click on the latest
version 2.31
let it open you will you will get chrome
driver
click on the zip file it will get
downloaded and then
unzip it and that's it after that ie
driver
so for i driver just move your cursor up
move your cursor up and here you can see
there's a different section completely
internet explorer driver server okay
so click on 64-bit windows
ie when you click on it it will start
downloading the
ie driver server and done so all the
three
drivers are downloaded and now
you can unzip them and after unzipping
you can add them to your resource folder
so jekyll driver copy this paste it in
resource folder
go back let's see chrome drivers this is
my chrome driver
let me go inside copy this again paste
it here control
v going back internet explorer driver
server
open this copy it paste it and done
all the three drivers has been placed in
the folder
you don't need to add them into the
build path okay don't add them
into the build path so you just need to
add the libraries into the build path
not the resources okay okay
all the setup is done no more setup is
required now
in this session we will begin by
learning what xpath is
what is its relevance and in the process
of learning about xpath
we shall see its syntax and different
types of expat locators
we shall learn the types of xpath
different expat functions and lastly
we will see expat access while we learn
all of these
we shall see the syntax often along the
side
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and
click that bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from simply learn
okay so without further ado let's get
started with what is xpath
xpath stands for xml path language it is
a selenium technique
that is used to navigate through the
html structure of a web page
it is a syntax or language that makes
finding elements on a web page possible
using xml path expression there are
other locators in selenium that search
for elements using tax or css class
names
and they are simple to use but then they
are not always sufficient and
effective there are times when you need
to select all dom elements of an html
document
which is when xpath comes to your rescue
the xpath helps in dynamically searching
elements with a webpage giving
sufficient
flexibility to the user it has always
been an essential part of an automation
script development to locate a web
element
and it has always been a challenging
task to find the correct
useful and accurate locator in an
automation test development process
this is when xpath comes to the picture
and provides its various functions to
help
write effective experts in selenium
automation
there may be times when elements can be
hard to find
with general locators like id name class
etc and this is when xpath is used to
locate those elements on the web page
we can use xpath and selenium on both
xml
and html documents
xpath in selenium has a basic format or
syntax
here we can use a syntax that has many
keywords
these double slashes are used to select
nodes in the document from the current
node
that match the selenium no matter where
they are
then tag name is used to give the tag
name as an input
this add the rate symbol is used to
select the attribute
the keyword attribute indicates the
attribute name of the node and lastly
the value refers to the value of the
node next
before we move on to the types of xpath
let's first see the types of expat
locators
as we know by now xpath is used to
locate web elements
based on its xml path here the term
locator refers to an address that
identifies
a web element uniquely within the web
page these locators are html properties
of a web element
which tells the name about the web
element it needs to act on
the first type of xpath locator is the
id
the best and the most popular method to
identify web elements
is by using the id and obviously
each element's id is unique the second
type
is the class name in this case the class
name of the element is used to find the
element
the third type is the link text here the
links text is used to find the element
all the hyperlinks on the webpage can be
identified just by using the linked text
we can determine the link on the webpage
with the help of an anchor tag
the anchor tag is used to create the
hyperlinks on a web page
and the text between the opening and
closing anchor tags constitute the link
text
then comes the xpath locator that uses
the name of the element to find that
particular element
the other type of xpath locator is the
xpath
this is required by the dynamic element
and to traverse between different
elements of the webpage the last type of
xpath locator
is the css path it locates the elements
that have
no class name or id
now let's move further and learn about
the types of xpath
there are basically two types of x path
absolute x path and the second one is
relative x path
if we talk about the absolute x path
then it refers to the direct way of
finding an element
the major drawback of an absolute x-path
is that
if there are any changes in the
element's path then the x-path will fail
the x-path begins with a single forward
slash
which states that we can select the root
node element
the syntax of the absolute x path looks
something like this
you can determine the absolute x path of
any windows file by right clicking on
the file and then clicking properties
in the file properties first look at the
location which is the path
to the file next add a backslash and
then the file name to the end of the
path
these actions will give you the absolute
x path of that file
now next let's see the relative expert
in the case of relative xpath the path
begins from the middle of the html dom
structure here the structure with a
double slash
or double forward slash that states that
the element can be searched anywhere on
the web page
relative xpath enables you to write from
the middle of the html dom structure
without any need to write a long
x path the syntax of the relative xpath
looks like this
a relative path needs to be combined
with another path to access a file
creating a link to an absolute path is
easy since you are pointing to the
file's internet url
if you want to find a specific files
relative expert
certain things must be kept in mind the
file
must exist on the same server as the
html file
the path to the file must be relative to
the directory of html file
this is what sums up the two types of
expats for us the next topic
in this session is the xpath functions
now the question arises what does the
term xpath function
mean there may be times when locating a
particular web element using general
attributes
xpath in selenium provides expat
functions to write efficient x parts
to discover elements uniquely there are
elements
with similar properties like the same
name or the same class name
this is when the simple x path
strategies are not efficient
and then we need the xpath functions
there are
three types of xpath functions the first
type is the xpath
contains the xpath contains in selenium
is a function within the xpath
expression used to search
for the web elements containing a
particular text it can find the element
with partial text it is used if the part
of the value of any attribute changes
dynamically like
login information etc and here we can
see the syntax of xpath
contains function the contains method
accepts two parameters
the attribute of the tag must validate
to locate the web element
the value of an attribute is a partial
value that the attribute
must contain the second type of xpath
function is the xpath text the xpath
text function is a function used to
locate the element on the web page
using the web elements text it helps to
find the exact text element
and it locates the elements within the
set of text nodes
the function proves it worth if the
element contains a text
like a label or etc so
here we can see the syntax of xpath text
on the screen
the text method here returned the text
of web element
when identified by the tag name and
compared with the right side's value
now comes the last type of xpath
function that is the xpath
starts with function the xpath starts
with function
is used to find the element in which the
attribute values start with some
specific character
or a sequence of characters the function
plays a major role
while working with the dynamic web pages
we can also use this method
to find element's worst attribute value
as static
that is not changing the syntax for the
starts with function can be seen on the
screen
this starts with accepts two parameters
the attribute of the tag must validate
to locate the web element
and the attribute value is the partial
value of the attribute
with which the attribute is expected to
start
after the xpath functions let's move on
to our next
and final topic that is the xpath axis
all the xml dom elements are in a
hierarchical structure
and can be either located using absolute
path or
relative paths for this xpath provides a
specific attribute
called xpath access xpath axis and
selenium are methods used to identify
those dynamic elements that are
impossible to find by normal
xpath methods such as id class name
name etc axes are shown in because they
tell about the axis
on which elements lie related to an
element
here an axis shows a relationship to the
current node and helps locate the
relative nodes
concerning the tree's current node so
the x path axis
uses several nodes to find those nodes
in the dom structure
let's have a look on some axis that help
in locating the elements on the web page
the first expat axis is the ancestor the
ancestor axis selects all ancestor
elements
grandparent parent etc of the current
node
then comes the ancestor or self this
axis is used to locate the current node
along with its ancestors
along that comes the attribute axis the
attribute axes are used to specify the
attributes of the current node
then comes the child axis as the name
suggests it selects
all the children elements of that
current node the next axis is the
descendant axis
it is used to locate the children of the
current node to the leaf node
then comes the descendant or self access
that is used to locate the current node
with its descendants after that comes
the following axis
which locates all the nodes that come
after the current node
now comes the parent axis that is used
to locate the parent of the current node
and at the last we have this self-access
the self-access are used to locate
current or the present nodes
there are several other nodes other than
these that we have just seen
there is a preceding axis used to select
all nodes that come before
the current node then a following
sibling node that selects the following
siblings of the context node and
siblings are
at the same level as the current node
there is one axis called the parent that
selects the parent of the current node
let's get started what exactly is a
chrome driver
now when we are working with selenium so
pretty much we
are going to use that tool for the
automatic test cases for the automation
of the test cases is what the
basis of the selenium tool here so if
you got a website
and uh let's suppose you want to log in
you want to
put some credentials you want to do some
transactions so if this kind of flow you
want to test it out
definitely having some back-end test
cases will not help you on that part
because they will not help you to click
on a particular
button put some imports in the input
text so it's it's more on like a dealing
with the more on the gui perspective
so that's where the selenium chrome
driver or the selenium comes into the
picture where it helps you to
drive those test cases where if you are
working on some kind of
gui uh related interface and you want to
test out that application so this kind
of functionality will be
helpful for you and how exactly it goes
on let's talk about the chrome driver
here
now chrome driver is a kind of uh
component which is available in selenium
like you pretty much use chrome driver
only when you feel like
uh it's being utilized and at that
moment of time you are working on
the specific chrome driver and it gives
you a kind of a content here
where you feel like okay i'm going to
use this chrome driver to see like how
the implementation should be done
and how the automation should be
performed over here
so chrome drivers specifically helps you
to launches the uh
launch the google chrome browser if
you're going to use
firefox if you're going to use internet
explorer then they have their own
specific drivers
but this one means like all your test
cases is going to be executed on the
chrome browser
so if your application is compatible
with the chrome browser
then this particular driver makes more
sense for you
so it's kind of a driver like uh
definitely this web driver is going to
have
all the api calls embedded inside that
which is going to help you
to automate your web applications
testing so
whether you want to go for chrome driver
you want to go for firefox you want to
go for internet explorer it totally
depends on the user
and your applications compatibility if
it's compatible with the chrome you can
pretty much use the chrome driver
without any issues
as such here right so why exactly we
need to use a chrome driver here
now when we are using a chrome driver so
it's basically
a kind of main component which is being
utilized by the selenium
by the selenium web driver because
selenium requires
a browser plugin or a browser driver
so that it can send the request so it
can send the request to the chrome and
it can process the request
if the selenium web driver is saying
like i want to hit onto some input box i
want to hit onto the summit box
so those kind of requests will be
processed by the chrome driver
so for that purpose we require the
chrome driver which will
only send the notifications or the
communications which will be sent out to
the chrome browser with the help of the
selenium web driver here
now it's being used to navigate between
web pages so
uh if you want to navigate or if you
want to go from one web page to another
web page so for that also you can use
the chrome browser chrome driver here
so while doing the processing here what
you can do is like you can put the
inputs in the web pages like
let's say like you got a login page so
you can put up a username password
you can have the credentials not only
you can provide the credentials but you
can also click on some button certain
buttons like okay
let's click on the login button so if
you want to test out
how what will happen that if
automatically you're going to
click on the login button so how your
application is going to behave
so if this kind of a validation and this
kind of verification if you feel like
you want to do
then in that case these chrome browser
will be used by the selenium
to interact now the uh selenium
webdriver or the selenium tool can
actually send the request and all these
requests will be processed by the chrome
dropper
so ultimately it's a chrome browser
where you will see the end results like
the website is getting navigated
the browser is getting closed
automatically the browser is getting
started or initialized automatically
here
so all that activity is going to be done
by the chrome driver which will in take
all the specific requests from the
selenium web driver here now let's see
like how we can
set up a chrome driver for this one you
require a chrome like
a chrome browser unique wire whatever
the platform you're using chrome is
pretty much installed there
if you already got a chrome browser
installed all you need to do is like you
need to get a browser
uh exe path over there so that you can
configure that into your
specific uh source code here so as a
chrome driver
in the configurations for that you can
put okay so this so-and-so location we
have the
exe file present there and the source
code can actually use it to
launch the chrome browser and do
whatever the activities
you want to perform on there as such
right so let's see like how we can set
up the chrome browser
uh and the chrome driver over here so
that we can run some couple of selenium
test cases
now for the chrome driver uh
demonstration over here we require four
things one
the cdc installation the jre which can
be installed from the oracle
we already got the jdk installed into
our system and eclipse also installed
into our system so these two
prerequisites already being done
now chrome browser is something which is
also available over here we already got
the chrome browser embedded inside this
machine
so the only thing which is left out is
the selenium here because
pretty much though the uh jdk
eclipse and chrome browser you will
already be having it there onto your
development machines or into your
personal machines
if you're already dealing with the uh
disk with the java programming source
code
so you already have these things
available there but even if you don't
have these things we can easily download
those things
and configure into our machine so that
we can start using that one
right so we have the respective links
over here eclipse is pretty easy to
download just download the zip file
or exe file eclipse will be installed
and you can start using it
and in order to make the eclipse work
first you have to do the installation of
the
uh jdk or uh you know the java which you
want to install
so that that's what you require here
right so let's open the selenium browser
here so i'm going to click on this
button here
so this will help me to open the
selenium website selenium.dev is the
website which is available there
which can help us to see like how we can
go ahead with this uh particular
selenium download here so we are going
to download the selenium here
and then we are going to utilize that uh
selenium over here in this one to
process it
so this is the selenium which we got
this is the website now here if you go
to the downloads like first of all you
got web driver
ide selenium gate these are the
different components which is there
now if you go to the downloads button so
here you will be able to see like all
the downloads which is available there
like
the browser or if you want to see like
the web driver
if you want to install so these are the
different uh programming languages
integrations which is available there
right so you can see like how the
executions uh
even if for the c sharp you have this
one here so you also got the selenium id
which is available there
so all these different components are
available which you can see
which is easy for you to integrate for
the selenium here
right now since we are going to uh use
it for the java so we have got like uh
the
specific version over here three point
one point uh
for 141 141.59 here so this is something
which we can use
and uh you can also go for the beta
version also but i want to download the
uh stable version over here you can go
for the vital download also
right whatever version you feel so let's
go for the download option over here so
this will basically help me to download
a specific file as a file over here now
this zip file is something which is uh
going to have all the required values
and attributes which is available there
so let's see like what exactly is
available in this
file so this is kind of a selenium which
we are downloading and this is what we
are going to use in the eclipse also so
in the eclipse we will be using this
stuff
so that we can utilize it
so let's open this one here
okay now you got this uh specific
library files these are the different
library files which is a
required over here you can say like as
in dependencies
and these are the ones which is
available there these are the
uh executables like you can say like
these will help you to run
any kind of selenium test cases so all
you require to do is like you can just
indicate these ones into your class path
while running your eclipse project you
can add these ones to the build path
there and this will surely work for you
these are the requirements like these
are the predictors which is required in
the eclipse
so that you can proceed further with
this one if these are not there
then it's going to show you the
compilations error so first we'll try to
put up the code base there
and see that what kind of error comes in
and then later on we'll see like how we
can
resolve those errors as such here so
let's go to the eclipse
right now what we really need to do is
like we need to create a new java
project and uh create a new class so
that's what we need to do
and in that case uh we have to configure
the build path but i'm not uh
uh going to uh add the external charge
as of now to put that
class bar there so what i'm going to do
is like i'm going to first
see there that how i can do that
installation so i i'm going to copy this
code here because this is what i'm going
to put up into my
a specific class so whatever the name of
the class you can give so here we are
using in the code base as in
the get started here so the same class
name we can use so that we don't get any
kind of issues
so let me copy this content
also uh provided like uh the driver the
chrome is already installed here so we
don't require so you can see here that
we are giving the path of the chrome
driver in case of linux platform when
you're trying to deploy it like when
you're trying to
put it up right there so in that case
probably you have to do the installation
like you have to download the chrome
driver for the linux platform
but here it's pretty much like you can
simply use it or you can
get it uh done because already the
windows platform we are using it
so we are launching the eclipse here so
uh in this one we will be creating a
quickly a class over here in this one
or kind of a project so that we will be
able to proceed further with that
so we're going to create an empty
project here in this case
so we got the uh specific eclipse open
so we can go for a new java project here
so i can say it like selenium so we can
give any project name here
and uh we can say it like finish so
there will be some
basic structure which is available there
so i'm going to quickly create a
specific
file like a class file here now these
are the jar files which is available
like
white from the jdk but uh we can easily
go to the
build path and we can add the external
jars but we are not going to do that now
we are going to first see like what
error we are going to get
so i am going to create a class here
like a simple class so getting uh
started is a class which i'm going to
create here because that's the one which
is available into my
content of the class file so you can uh
you know if you feel like you don't want
to use the same name like this one so
you want to use some different names so
you can easily do a rename
so that can be easily done there now
here the since
like the imports is something which is
coming up like this is not uh
something which is coming up over here
like it's not getting resolved
because of the fact that uh we are
pretty much using uh
the uh specific open uh the selenium
literally jar files the jr files but
it's not getting that
it's not uh showing that output here so
let's see like
let's open the uh specific downloads
window here so from where we can access
these
jar files and we can refer it so we got
this one so let's extract this
completely uh you can put these uh for
jar files in any other locations if you
feel like you want to refer that so
you can keep put up into the default
location of the
eclipse also if you feel like this is
getting referenced
pretty much frequently and there are a
lot of projects that you are working so
in that case you can have it into a
small
folder or directly import it into the
eclipse itself
so uh here i'm just doing a one-time
activity so let's
uh use this downloads folder itself from
where we can
simply import these jar files here so
these are the jar files which is
available there in the libraries we also
got like an
additional jar file which is available
right so uh we can
go ahead with that part here so these
are the different libraries which is
available and these are again the
libraries
so let's uh you know change the build
path here so we'll go for the build path
here
and uh we'll say like uh we can add the
libraries here now libraries
is something which we want to sorry we
want to edit the
build path here
so here we're going to talk about the
external libraries like you know the
libraries which is available there
which we want to put up into this one so
we can say like add external jars
so now we can go for the downloads
button here and here we can put up this
jar file here now we also got a sources
one a sources jar file which is also
available there but what we have done is
like we have added only
the uh executable ones because sources
ones and executable ones is just the
same
the only thing is that the sources one
will have the source code also we don't
require that as such
then lastly we comes up with the junit
one then of course like uh junit uh
you know is also being referenced here
so for that we don't have to download
the j2.1 because most of the
eclipse browsers are already having the
libraries integrated
so all you need to do is like you need
to click on the add library here
and we already got the junit in this one
so we don't have to really go anywhere
there because
it's a part of the plugin of the eclipse
that it's already integrated there in
case of selenium you went for the add
external jar files and you added the jar
file there but not in this case
in june it will be automatically
referenced because of the fact that we
are using it on over here in this case
right so these are the two references
like junit also we reference it because
we are running some genuine test cases
here so
which is like already a part of the uh
plugins here in the eclipse
yes uh if you put the plugin of the
selenium and you integrate in the same
way
then also you don't have to go for this
third-party references but it's okay
like you can
reference it there and um you know any
project of selenium can work now because
you got the basic
executables required for that so that
that's how it it works on there right
now we also have got like a certain uh
other jar files which is
uh which needs to be added up over there
now those were not uh
something which we added because right
now we just resolve the issues related
to the
selenium but uh these selenium
executables may also have some
other dependencies so for that what you
need to do is like you need to add
and another uh folder like uh you know
another uh
folder over here which is like lib here
so these jar files will also coming up
over here because your code bases may be
available or may be dependent on these
ones
so these are the exact uh you know
because your selenium may be dependent
on these jar files there so that's also
we are going to add up over here
so not only the client combined jar file
but other dependent jar files also is
going to be there into the referenced
libraries here
right now let's find out the executable
path of the chrome browser here so i'm
going to open the
c drive here because in that case we
will be having the chrome browser
installed
so it's a standard location where you
will be able to see your uh particular
chrome application exe file here
so uh pretty much this is the directory
structure which is available there like
in this one uh
it will be installed there so uh you can
get the same
information from the chrome shortcut or
the from
a chrome icon also that where exactly
this exe file is referenced and if any
difference is there so you can do that
now this is a directory like this is the
exe file which is available there
so i'm going to just put that one over
here in this one
right so this is the way uh we are going
to put up the parts here in this ones
like how the
uh path should be referenced should be
executed over here
and uh ultimately uh this is required
because definitely when we are going to
run the test cases uh
this chrome browser will be sent the
notifications to opening www.google.com
here
and it's going to uh wait over there on
that part
and uh it's going to search the specific
keyword over here called chrome driver
so this is what
it's this program this basic program is
going to perform here
so now let's run the chrome browser here
so uh we're not going to run the chrome
browser but ultimately the junit test
cases so you right click over here
and say run as junit test cases and this
will
ultimately help you to launch a chrome
browser now i have not triggered it
manually
uh i have got it like automatically over
here and you can see like the cursor is
going to blink because it's
basically waiting for the selenium to
put up the inputs and all
now if you have the test case executed
like you open this website go to this
website
click on this and click on that so
according to that your browser will
start behaving
without any interaction from the human
there now this is a kind of a
functionality which we will get with the
selenium and this
makes easy for us like if we want to
validate or if we want to go through any
kind of web application waste
testing this is the ultimate way like
how we can go for that verifications
right so this is what we have in this
demo where we can see like how the
uh automatically we can do the chrome
browser we can interact with chrome
browser
right from the selenium over here so
let's go back to the main content
right so that was the way that how we
can configure the chrome driver with the
selenium here so that we can invoke
chrome browsers and when then we can
according to the statements we can start
sending the request
so that's uh pretty much which is there
now the various uh activities which we
did in this case was the jdk
installation
uh eclipse selenium chrome browser now
chrome browser
ide and jdk is pretty easy to download
and you can configure it
and uh that that's the way that how we
can set up the chrome browser the main
important thing is like how to download
the selenium
and refer it into your projects okay so
that you can start using the selenium
over here
now we will come to various annotations
this thing she will be going to talk
about test engine out today
what is destiny let's talk about that
existing
next generation this is the full form of
this ng
what is test engine so first of all
preston g
is a unit listing framework
or i would say java unit basic framework
they're specific to java there are two
most popular
unit testing framework one is geonet and
one is distance these are the two
investing framework for java and if i
talk about jna
j in it it's used
a lot by developers so developer use
this particular framework a lot for the
unit testing purpose and when i talk
about test ng testing g it is
used a lot by testers
why there is a discrimination between
these two frameworks then
okay what happens is uh you know
developers are keep on using unit from
quite a long time and they don't want to
switch to the new one
that's only the thing which i feel is
they are using jlit
however if i talk about this change
testing g is
having more annotations
compared to j unit
it's having more annotations means more
functionalities
let's let me write it here more
functionalities the latest version of
junit
is junit 4. for testing g
it is actually 6.7 is the latest version
of testing gm for your junit as it's the
fourth version
for junit there is a new version coming
up that is called s5 and it may be
possible that that will be more advanced
or more not more advanced but that will
be equivalent to test energy
because i have seen as an introduction
that it is having functionality similar
to distance g
so now then we won't be able to say that
testing g
or sorry j unit is behind test engine
but as of now yes it is
in test ng if i talk about we will be
going through
some annotations these annotations helps
us to make
our test more reusable easily
maintainable okay um if you
uh get stuck at any point of time you
can go to the documentation of this
engine you will find each and everything
clear and very easily defined so test ng
uh documentation is very good so i would
suggest whenever
you get time you can go through with it
but most of the seventy percent of the
testing functionality is what we are
going to take a look
okay because they are very helpful
when we talk about test ng we always
talk about view and notation
question when we talk about annotation
what annotation is can anyone tell me
what annotation is
let me create a package here
so actually testng learning testing is
very interesting thing
we are creating a class and we are
saying
it as login
test cases
we see here
verify with valid
credentials
verify with invalid credentials
verify um
suppose if you have any other test cases
well let's let me just think
if you can tell me one test case of
login one is with valid credential one
is with invalid credentials you can
expand it as much as you want
you but
just verify it with
with no credentials as well correct
or we can say verify with special
characters
sql injection
so there can be multiple methods correct
guys have you observed at any point of
time
whenever you are working on java if you
have written any programs or anything
like that have you observed
there is one annotation comes up there
is one line comes out that is at the
rate
override sometimes at the rate
surprise warnings
anyone of you have have you ever seen
this kind of statement
no one it seems okay
we also get deprecated
okay so
let me come back from that so
whatever you write on top of your method
with enterate sign
and anything post that that will be
considered as an
annotation on top of a method on top of
it to pass
anywhere okay these are called as
annotations
and it can be anything i will say at the
rate test i
so it's not what you will define this is
what you will say any name to it no
these are the annotations which are
being provided by
test ng and every
thing whatever you will be going to
define here
has some functionality attached to it
has some functionality attached to it so
it's not that it is just for the name
purpose it will be going to add up
some functionalities okay
that's the thing but okay
let's find
[Music]
so whenever i am talking about
annotation i am talking about
few things which i am going to add on
top of methods or on top of a class
okay and they actually
place an important role in your
particular class or in your methods
before i tell you about annotations
that what all annotations do we have in
test ng
let me tell you how you are going to
download this test engine
first of all i said junior jr note is a
pre-installed
jam it is pre-installed in eclipse but
test ng is not
if you have to download this then just
go to
help eclipse marketplace
wait for it to boot up
right here they're changing
and defined okay it just will hang
just let it come here test ng
and search for it
so to install it you write uh you go to
help
eclipse marketplace and inside that
you mentioned destiny when you get the
test change you will see here testing g
for eclipse just click on install this
is how
install button will look like click on
that and insert sng and done
testing g will be installed in your
system
okay now let's talk about few
annotations in test ng we are talking
about annotations from quite a long time
now
let's write some annotations
enter it before
suite enter it before
test add the red before class
and the date before method
enter it test
enter it after method
enter it after
class hit the right
after test enter it
after shoot
enter it before group
and the date after group
entered data provider
and and and let's just think if i have
entered it parameter
okay so these are the annotations what
we
have in test ng
so here what it says score of uh web
driver automation framework
without proper design your test may look
like the image below
if you don't think and you know without
any
design you may end up by saying login
test
product test add to cart test checkout
test
check out test payment checkout test
shipment payment test and paymentation
etc
it may be possible that the things which
you are using here might
can be used in product test as well it
might be possible that whatever the
things which you are doing here
can be used in add to part as well
so these are the things which
we are going to use now like this see
this
so with page object you are creating one
object for sign in page
product list one object part one object
shipment one object payment one object
order one object
when you are using the login test when
you are creating select product test it
might be using
sign in page objects as well as product
list object
so it may be possible like i have shown
you just now in the
uh trivago in that we were using
multiple
pages multiple page objects and we were
coming up with the
test case and that's what it is showing
us in a form for diagram
if you want you can go through with that
but this is how we are going to
write our automation framework and
that's what it states consideration
whenever you create page object design
always consider these few things
always create a class
for every web page create a class for
every web page
webpage elements web page elements
are instance variables off page with a
class of type web element
what it's saying that whatever the
elements you will be going to write in
that
are always instance or always instance
variable
we will be going to do that service page
would include
sign in page active cart which becomes a
method
in page object class
so there will be services pages where
you may see sign in page add to cart
page
add to cart query functionality or
methods i will say
and then at the last we have written in
test you create object of
page vectors and call the methods so
let's go
three more slides there are we'll go
through that and we'll see design
pattern test does not have any technical
code to communicate with deal
with the browser so test will not have
any technical code
okay make sure that whatever you are
writing technically
you will be writing in the pages test
called page objects and verifies the
result
test is more readable like i have shown
you it was more readable form test
object do not verify page load
we don't verify whether the page is
loaded or not okay but they communicate
with the browser
these are the syntax is what i have
mentioned here if you see here
they are using weight dot until no
that is again also a method so you can
ignore it again
okay let's just take a look at this
because all these syntaxes is what we
are going to see
after the break but let's take a look
these are the best practices one can
follow to make design
robust and maintainable create one page
object class for each webpage
create one page object class for each
web page okay we'll be doing that
each page object method should either
return the object on that page or should
return the
page object of the next page so we'll
see
it is this is what we call as in the
name of language
linking between the classes linking
between the classes
each page object should self validate
whether the page is
fully loaded before giving control to
the next step
any data used by the page object should
be passed through test and should not be
hard coded
so now will not be hard coding anything
and that's what here it is showing us a
very small example with the page check
bmi calculator
and the test and here again but
let me just create an architecture of
the framework
and then we will see
all the things will be going to execute
this is my test i'll be going to create
few packages inside it
and i'll be going to tell you about each
package everyone has a different way to
define it
and this is how i always define
some people say it as page package but i
call it as
core package the score package in this
four package
i'll be going to initialize all my
elements
in this this is the heart of the package
if something goes wrong in this package
in this
whatever i will define in this package
if something goes wrong in that
nothing will get executed nothing will
be executed
second package this is the package i am
going to call it as pages
pages is here we will be going to create
all our pages
means all are classes for web pages
so all the pages are maintained right
here
another package we'll call it as
test cases here i'm keeping all my test
cases
another package util
here i i'll be keeping all my utilities
under package config
here i'll be keeping all my
configuration files
another package logs
here i'll be generating all my logs
related to my
project
a new folder
let's do one thing instead of creating a
folder let's use utilize this resources
and let's put here
one folder by the name of drivers
so all our firefox chrome ie drivers
will be placed
at this location one more folder
test data excel sheet or whatever trace
data you are using you'll be putting
your test data right at this location
one more folder
screenshots it's at the project level so
all the screenshots will be maintained
in this folder
and this is the architecture of my
framework which will i'll be going to
create let's take up one more
concept that is first principles srp
let's see that what it is
so first principle structures the test
creation and create
value of the test suits not all the
first principle can be followed in ui
testing
use first principle as a long term guy
to maintain
a test suit let's see that what all
those five principles
are fast isolated independent
repeatable self validating
through timely so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so
that's why we always discuss that void
use of thread
pick up uh one more concept that is
first
principles and srb let's see that what
it is so first
principle structures the test creation
and create value
of the test suits not all the first
principle can be followed in ui testing
use first principle as a long term guide
to maintain a
test suit let's see that what all those
five principles
are fast isolated independent
repeatable self validating
through timely so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so
that's why we always discuss that avoid
use
of threat dot e what explicit weight put
implicit weight
else you may be spending a lot of extra
time so better avoid this
isolated independent minimize dependency
between tests
as far as possible so there shouldn't be
dependent
uh you know your test cases should not
be dependent on
each other because if one fails it may
be possible the other one will not run
in that case
okay don't make your test case dependent
on each other
as much as possible and also in your
test case
insert at least verification of course
you will be having that verification
because that's a
requirement repeatable configured test
so that re-running the test
always give consistent result we have to
keep
now our test cases separately
in different different methods so that
if even if we rerun
it won't impact you know the results and
of course it is not
impact and it actually does not apply to
the service here
validating while writing the test you
should automate communication
as automation suits run without human
intervention
don't assume any human intervention
so always whenever you are creating your
framework
your test scripts don't think that you
will be providing some input to it
never ever give any input to your test
cases to your
automation pack make it in such a way
that
it can be freely or it can be run
in your absence as well so what you will
do you will schedule it at 3 a.m in the
night and it will run and will give you
the results
you'll have to make your test in such a
way not that that it
requires your input like verification
here we are saying you should automate
verification you know
so when you are opening up a website you
should verify whether it has actually
opened or not
that is actually opening that particular
url or going to that url
it is going to some other different url
need to verify all these things
thoroughly uh borrow timely this is
applicable to unit test
this test should be true in terms of
coverage
so when i say in the terms of coverage
you know guys
what happens in unit test cases in unit
testing
we write code okay of course in selenium
also we write code
and in code we write some variables we
create some methods
some extra methods some extra line of
code as well
but if we write some extra line of code
that means
if your graph will when the sponsor
program will get executed
execution time will be moved correct if
you are adding some more things
if you are using objects which are not
being used anywhere if you are creating
objects which are not
generally here if you are creating
variables which are not being used
anywhere so of course java
while executing java will take care of
them and will see them
correct we'll go through through those
steps which is
of no use actually in your scripts
so here in terms of coverage what it
means is you should get the code
coverage
that you have written hundred percent of
your you know
you have written your complete code but
actually how much percent is being used
50 percent 60 70 so there
are some code coverage tools which you
can
use and can see that actually
how much code is being used
so when you write your script it may be
possible that the
50 of the script is only useful 50 is
you know
it's completely not is of no use
so when you get the coverage code
coverage report you can see that
which one is of no use and you can
remove those
extra lines that's the benefit of code
coverage
and it is applicable of unit test it is
applicable and selenium as well
running or executing softwares or
applications with the aim of finding out
errors
or bugs in the developed application is
called software testing
selenium and qtp are two software
testing tools
used widely in the current software
industry
let's do a comparison between these two
testing tools
in this video in this session we will be
going through
what is selenium what is qtp then we'll
have a comparison between selenium and
qtp
we'll then try to understand why one
should shift to selenium
and finally how to migrate from qtp to
selenium
so what do you mean by selenium to put
it in simple terms
selenium is an open source testing
program for web-based applications
spread across different platforms and
browsers
selenium is a set of four components
that are usually required at the time of
software testing
they are selenium integrated development
environment or ide this is a web browser
add-on
that creates tests very quickly through
its record and playback functionality
depreciated selenium remote control rc
this is a test tool that allows you to
write automated web application
ui tests in any programming language
against
any http website using any mainstream
javascript enabled browser webdriver
this is used for cross browser testing
and selenium grid this is used for cross
platform testing
so what is qtp qtp is a testing tool
developed by havelet packard it stands
for quick test professional
identifying errors problems or gaps with
respect to the expected results of
any software that is being tested are
the functions of the hpqtp
vbscript is used by qtp for automation
purposes
and it need not be installed separately
as it comes along with the windows os
the latest version of qtp is called uft
and it is a combination of hpqtp and hp
service test
hudson's and jenkins are two open source
continuous integration system
that is supported by uft it also
provides support for mobile testing
ufd mobile support allows to create
agnostic scripts
that is scripts compliant with for all
mobile platforms
this script developed in ios can also be
run
on android let us now have a comparison
between hp qtp and
selenium hpqtp is a famous tool in the
market of web-based testing
but with the dawn of selenium's
popularity and its ability to do more
than qtp
ever could has made it a worthy
competitor
these are quite a few straightforward
differences between qtp
and selenium that might help people
choose between the two
qtp is used commercially and hence it
requires license
while selenium is an open source tool
and is free for everyone to use
qtp can be used to test both web paste
and desktop application
while selenium can only come in handy
while testing
web-based applications only qtp ide
can be used while doing qtp test while
in case of selenium tests
multiple ides can be used like netbeans
visual studio
eclipse qtp can only support vb scripts
while selenium supports multiple
programming languages like dotnet
ruby perl php java
javascript etc qtp supports multiple
types of dialog box
while selenium can only support dialog
box partially
developing time is high in selenium than
qtp
authentication windows can be automated
in uft
whereas in selenium we have to use auto
id or use
robot class in java qtp has a very good
official technical support
while selenium has community technical
support
qtp is comparatively more user friendly
and the scripts can be developed in a
short time
on the other hand selenium has less
functionality
as it is low level and the scripts take
up more time
to come and to be maintained hp uft is a
tool
used to integrate qtp on the other hand
selenium does not have any tool used for
integration
speaking of execution qtp can test one
application per machine whereas selenium
can execute
multiple tests on a machine at the same
time moreover
selenium takes lesser cpu and ram power
in the time of execution
as compared to qtp so why should one
then shift to selenium
a slight modification in the code has to
be tested to make sure that the code is
running fine
and fulfilling the target now repeating
the tests again and again can get costly
the high portability of selenium allows
the automation engineers
to write codes without worrying about
the os
the testing is ideally kept
self-contained within the program
and they can be modified as desired this
approach
makes sure that any change in quotes
does not increase the development
and improves maintainability the
flexibility offered by selenium
allows coders to manage tests better
since selenium is open source users can
extend
share and modify codes thus saving a
great deal of time and effort for the
programmers
so how to migrate from qtp to selenium
choose the script language keeping the
team's experience and the relevant kind
of automation framework in mind
put off building frameworks and write
simple selenium scripts in the beginning
keep tracks of the issue that come up
with time and
make use of the solutions to build
larger test suites in future once
comfortable with selenium
start discovering tools that can be used
with selenium for example maven
test ng etc selenium jobs and salary a
very interesting topic so the market
trends for test automation are
continuously changing and selenium has
seen an exponential growth in a very
short time period
this selenium makes it convenient for
clients to receive an roi
much faster and how does that happen by
reducing the number of test cycles
involved in testing their product in
present scenario selenium is a perfect
automation for
any of your web web application testing
and automated web application testing
and it is the first
choice of your automation tester as well
as the companies also
so as the softwares are becoming more
and more complex so is the test
automation and selenium is a key
skill set for any test automation
engineer to have
but of course it's not the only skill
set one needs to have so if you look at
a typical job description here so gone
are the days when the engineers were
hired as a manual tester
every company today wants to hire
engineers who knows how to do automation
and since selenium is the most popular
web application automation tool
companies look specifically for selenium
automation engineers
and this is the typical job description
of any automation engineer to develop
test cases to detect bugs and errors
automation framework designing it's not
just about automating your test cases
one should have the ability to design
the complete framework related to the
project to improve and automate test
practices
to participate in communicating best
practices
defining test strategy test manuals for
tracking and fixing your
software issues let's look at the
compensation part of it
so compensation varies from company to
company and it also depends on your
experience level
so according to the stacks if you look
at the us market it can vary anywhere
from twenty one thousand dollars to one
fifty thousand dollars
average could be of course somewhere
around ninety thousand dollars and if
you look at the indian market range it
ranges anywhere from two to ten lakhs
per annum
for a startup with an average of five
lakhs so the more and more you're going
to get experience the better is going to
be a compensation package
and the market has always been very
lucrative for automation engineers so
since selenium is so powerful web
automation tools there are some of the
top end companies who use selenium in
their various project
they want to provide their customers the
best quality software
and help them reduce the time to market
and hence
they going for selenium so a lot of
these companies have selenium
deployments
in this video we will look at most
commonly asked questions in the
interview
and some guidelines on how to answer
them nowadays automation tool and
especially the
selenium skills is a very key
requirement for an qa engineer or even
an automation engineer jobs
so if you're on an outlook of automation
engineer
or a qa engineer positions i'm sure this
question bank will definitely help you
prepare for your interview so this
video consists of three parts basically
three different levels of set of
questions
one is the beginner level second is the
intermediate level
and then the advanced level questions
and each level has a set of 10 most
probable questions which you might be
asked in the
interview so let's begin with the
beginner level questions
question 1 what are selenium suite
components
so selenium is a set of tools and
libraries to facilitate automation on
web applications
you already know this it is not a single
tool so what are those
components which are comprised in the
selenium so
selenium comes with four major
components the first one is the id
id happens to be the most simplest tool
in the whole suite of selenium it is
nothing but an integrated development
environment
which has a record and playback
functionality this was earlier available
as only firefox plugin
however you need to know that the new
version of selenium ide is available
as a chrome extension as well as a
firefox plugin
so that means you can either use any of
the browsers that is firefox or the
chrome for recording your test scripts
also you should also know that the new
ide comes with many new features
and now this new ide has become more
powerful than what was available earlier
so some of these new features are like
reusability of your test cases
it comes with a better debugger now and
most importantly it supports parallel
test execution
and how does it do that it has a utility
called selenium side runner that's about
selenium id
the next component is the selenium
remote control so selenium remote
control
or popularly called a selenium rc is
used to write web application test in
different programming languages
it supports multiple programming
languages like java c
perl python ruby and php it is nothing
but it's a server
which interacts with your browser using
a simple
http get and post request for
communication
selenium rc is also called as selenium
1.0 version or
selenium core third component selenium
webdriver
it is a programming interface to run
your test cases
and web driver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006
and this was introduced to overcome some
of the limitations of selenium rc
so rs architecture was very complex
because
it required an additional server in its
setup
and why was that additional server for
communicating with the browser
and what webdriver did was it removed
this dependency completely web driver
interacts directly with the browser and
also makes your test cases run much
faster than your rc
the last component the selenium grid a
very important tool
this is used to run multiple test
scripts on multiple machines
at the same time now with the selenium
webdriver you can only do sequential
execution
but in real time environment you always
have the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment so this grid
allows parallel execution of tests on
different browsers as well as different
operating system
so the design is in such a way that
commands are distributed on multiple
machines where you want to run the test
and they are executed simultaneously
this uses a simple hubbard node concept
where
hub controls the all execution of your
test cases on the nodes
and this is how we achieve parallel
execution and what is the major
advantage of having this grid it is to
reduce your overall test execution type
question two
what are the limitations of selenium now
like any other tool
selenium also has certain limitations so
when you are answering this question
you will also be expected to talk about
what is the work around available for
all these limitations
so let's look at them one by one no
reliable tech support
of course selenium is an open source so
if you look at it you do not have much
technical support available
however there are loads of documentation
available
there are forums available which you can
refer to seleniumhq.org
is the website is your bible if you're
working with the selenium
and then there are there are a lot of
selenium google groups and the forums
which are available for any kind of
support
so selenium has been there for quite
some time so it's it's one of the
most mature tool available today so even
though we do not have a technical
support available there is
enough documentation available on the
internet
the second limitation selenium can test
only web application
selenium is an open source tool that is
designed to automate
web-based applications on different
browsers but it cannot handle
windows gui or non-html pop-ups in the
application
now what is the workaround available for
that selenium provides a support for
integrating other tools like auto it so
autoeta is a tool for handling your
windows based activity selenium also
cannot automate mobile applications
but then what is available with that it
can integrate a tool called apm tool
which is a
mobile automation tool the third
limitation limited support for
image testing selenium is a de facto
tool for functional web
web application tests so standard api
allows interacting
only with the browser and it's hard to
test the images based applications using
selenium what is the other tool
available
securely is a very good tool to use for
image testing and this again
you can integrate securely with selenium
that's how you can achieve your
image testing through selenium but using
the security tool
no built-in reporting facility so
selenium does not have any reporting
capability as such of course it does
provide a very limited reporting
capability where some basic reports are
created
but definitely when you are working in a
framework you need a
better support for uh good reporting
tools
so that way selenium supports some of
the tools like test ng
report ng and extent reports using which
you can integrate these tools with
selenium and generate
beautiful reports limited test
management selenium does not provide
any test tool integration with test
management tools may require knowledge
of programming languages
so since selenium supports multiple
programming languages the developer of
the test
automation will require to have some
basic knowledge of
any of the supported programming
language why one in order to write your
effective
automation scripts and of course because
selenium tool you want to use it at its
full potential
question three what are the testing
types supported by selenium
so selenium supports regression testing
and functional testing
these can be called as a very high level
categories
so what is regression testing regression
testing is a full
or partial selection of already executed
test cases
which are re-executed to ensure
your existing functionality does not
break so let's look at what are these
attributes of regression testing and why
we say that selenium
helps us in doing regression testing so
regression tests are
run every time a new fix has been
received
or a new feature has been deployed so
that is called as
retesting you can always select a full
suite
or select a test to test a fix or a
complete product so your selection can
be based on recently added features
a test area where most defects are there
or integration areas or even
end-to-end kind of tests you can also
prioritize your test cases
based on critical functionalities and
business impact of this test cases
according to the
priority set so all this can be done
using selenium now what is the second
category of the testing which it
supports
functional testing so functional testing
includes what
your smoke does sanity tests say
installed as database test
basically any kind of functionality
which you are going to test
and if you look at the kind of steps
which are involved in that it
involves identification of your test
inputs expected outputs
or the results the test case logic
itself and the assertions
so a typical flow will be you identify
your test inputs first then you derive
your test outcomes or the expected
outputs you design
and execute your test cases and then
assert on the
expected versus actual outcomes question
four
what are selenium 2.0 and three daughter
versions
so selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004
and that was selenium version since then
this tool has gone through multiple
changes to make it
better and better so if selenium two dot
version
had a major change it took a leap
forward in terms of browser automation
the selenium rc the remote control had a
disadvantage
of having the need of an additional
server
to talk to the web browsers and because
of this the text execution was
much slower and the com architecture
itself became very complex
so if you look at this selenium 2 it had
two components
a successor to rc and the rc itself
which is called as your
core so this successor was nothing but
your web driver api
so web driver apis made it easier to
write your automation scripts for any
browser
by simply using a suitable driver for
any browser which you want to run the
tests on
apart from these two components the
selenium 2.0 version
also had the id and the grid components
so in summary if you look at it selenium
2.0 version has an
ide it has selenium rc which was on its
way of deprecation
webdriver api which was just introduced
in there
a very very earlier version of webdriver
api and the
grid so what is selenium 3.0 consists so
selenium 3.0
rc was completely eliminated now because
in 2.0 it was already on its path of
deprecation
and web driver replaced rc completely
so if you look at the components of 3.0
we have ide
we have a web driver and grid as the
major components
so now with this introduction of web
driver a full-fledged web driver
selenium became the most powerful tool
for web application
automation question five a very
important question what is same
origin policy and how was it handled now
same origin policy is a security id
feature
so it is a very important concept in web
application
security model and what is this
according to this policy
a web browser allows scripts from one
web page
to access the contents of another web
page
provided both these pages are on the
same origin now what does origin mean
origin is nothing but a combination of
your url schema
the host number and the port number it's
basically your domain
now if a such question is asked how are
you going to explain it
so let's say you have a javascript
program which runs in a certain domain
say google.com okay so this program can
access
all the programs which are from the same
origin now origin here is what
google.com so
for example you can access other pages
like your google drive your google email
or your google calendar
however now if you use the same
javascript
right so if you use the same script from
the google.com to access
another page or an element in a
different domain
say yahoo.com then the security model of
the web application
itself prohibits you to do so so what
happens because of that is you
are limited with access only to those
elements and pages
which are in the same domain but now
look at the case that
you want to run your test on multiple
servers
and you might also want to access
multiple domain so due to the same
origin policy you will not be able to
do so and this became a major limitation
with a very early selenium tool
so how was this handled so this got
handled
by paul hammon who created the selenium
remote control
so he created the selenium remote
control server to trick the browser in
believing that the selenium
core and the web application under test
actually came from the same domain
and this is how the same origin policy
was handled and this
selenium rc which is selenium remote
control became the version one of
selenium question six what is celine's
and how is it classified selenium
commands for selenium
ide are often called as selenis they are
a set of commands that run your test
and sequence of this command is called
as a test script
now these commands are categorized into
three major categories
one is the action command now action
commands are the commands that generally
manipulate the state of your application
for example they can do things like
click on this link or select a
particular option
open a url type certain text into an
input box
click or double click on any web element
and so on so these are called as
action commands the second set of
commands is the accessors
now accessors examine the state of the
application and store the results in a
variable so it basically allows the user
to store certain values to a user
defined variable
for example if i want to store the page
title of a web page
i can do that by defining a user defined
variable
and then these stored values can be
later used to create your assertions or
verifications in your test
now few examples of such commands are
you can just use a store
story or a store text store title
or a store value so these are some of
the accessor commands the third category
is the assertions
assertions are like your accesses but
they verify the state of your
application and conforms to what is
expected
so basically it is a comparison of your
actual versus expected results
there are two types of assertions
available one is the softer sessions and
the harder sessions
an example of a soft assertion can be
verify title
wherein you verify the title check
whether the expected and the actual
outcomes are the same and continue with
your test case now whereas in hard
assertion is you do an
assert title using the command assert
title and if at
all the assertion fails the test case
stops from executing question 7
mention the types of web locator what is
web locator a locator
is a command that tells the selenium
which ui
element you want to operate on selenium
uses locators to find and match the
elements
of your web page which it needs to
interact with
and there are around eight locating
techniques in selenium
the first one is by id now this is the
most common way of locating elements
why since the ids are supposed to be
unique for each element
the ids can also be dynamic in nature so
you can identify
them by inspecting the attributes of the
web element
so let's look at an example so if we go
to a facebook
right so if you go to the facebook and
say if i want to identify this element
email so if you look at this highlighted
text here it has a unique id which is
email so if i am going to operate on
this particular element
email i can directly use the id locating
technique
link text and the partial link text so
this type of locator applies only to the
hyperlink text
so we access the link by using this
locator which needs the hyperlink text
to be
provided so for link text you can give a
complete text in the link text
or let's let's look at an example of
that so let's if you go to
say one of the e-commerce site which is
say amazon dot in
and say you want to click on this
today's deal link so if you look here in
amazon.com there are a lot of hyperlinks
available here and if an example if you
have to take an example say we want to
click on the today's tale now if you
inspect this element
you will see that it has an anchor tag a
it has an associated href
link here and also it has a text which
says today's deal
right which is what is displayed on your
web page now similarly there is
also a link available here called
customer service so if you inspect that
customer service it also has something
similar what the today's deal had
it has an anchor tab it has an href link
and it has a
long text which says customer service
which is what is displayed now if you
have to use your
web locator which is a linked text you
need to provide the complete text which
is displayed on your web page
and there is another way of using the
link text by saying partial link text
where you can just give a partial text
which can be matched against the
complete text of your
link and this is how you can use your
partial link text or the
link text the next id is by name so
locating elements by name is very
similar to locating by id
just that your attribute instead of
using an id you're going to use
name in this case now if you look at the
same example of say facebook
we identified this email element using
its id you can also locate the same
element by using the name
attribute which is also unique in this
case which has a value called email
tag name that's the next identifier so
locate element using tag name of the
element now say if you want to identify
all the elements on your web page which
are of type button so that you can do by
using the tag name as
button there for example again on your
facebook page
i know that there is a single button
here which is
of type button and which has a tag as
button and this is the only button which
is available on this page
so if i want to access this particular
element i can simply use a locator
technique called
tag which is button in this case next
locator class name so locate an element
using its class name
attribute so you can use this identifier
only
if you find that a class name is unique
for a web element which you want to work
with
class names are sometimes unique a web
element can also have multiple class
name or even you will find some elements
which has no class name
so depending on what is available in the
attributes you can
use this class name for identification
so example
the shown on your screen here where it
says find element by class name
input text basically this is going to
list out all elements on your web page
which has a class name called input text
the next identifier is by
xpath now xpath is a language used when
locating xml nodes what is xml
extendable markup language
it can access almost any element even
those
without any class names or names or even
id attributes so whenever you do not
find a unique attribute for id
name or class name you can construct an
expat to create an unique identifier for
that particular element
now for example on this facebook page if
you observe here there is a
label here called create an account so
if you inspect this particular label
it has no attributes other than a tag
called spam so if you want to identify
this particular element and say display
it
this is one of the ways to do it is
through xpath
css selector so css selector are string
patterns
used to identify an element based on the
combination
of either the html tag id class or any
other
attributes locating by css selector is
little more complicated
than any of the previous method however
the advantage is
css selectors work much faster than the
xpath
the performance of your test scripts is
much better when you use css selector
than any other locating technique
now again as an example if you see the
facebook again
you can identify the same email here
right
i used an id here or a name attribute
here to identify it
so assume that if you did not have any
of those things or if you want to use a
css selector here
you can still do that by using this
syntax
this is how you use the css selector to
identify an element
question 8 what are the types of weights
supported by
webdriver now before even you answer
this question
you should know why do we need weights
in selenium
weights play a very important role in
executing test cases
most of the web applications are
developed using using
ajax and javascripts so when a page is
loaded by the browser
the elements which you want to interact
may load at a different time intervals
not only this makes it difficult to
identify the elements but also if the
element is
not located it will start throwing
element not visible exception
and how do we resolve this by using the
weights so there are three different
kind of weights available in selenium
first one is the implicit weight the
implicit weight
tells the browser or your web driver to
wait for a certain amount of time
before it can throw a no such element
exception now the default setting is
zero for this
once we set a time what webrt webdriver
does it it will wait
for that time so if you have mentioned
10 seconds it will wait for 10 seconds
until it finds the element and even in
the 10 seconds it is unable to find that
element only after that it throws an
exception
now what is the syntax of this implicit
weight is
this is the syntax of this where you use
driver.manage timeouts
implicit weight and there is a timeout
value say 10 seconds
and the unit whether it's in minutes
seconds or milliseconds is what you can
mention
implicit weight is applied globally to
all the elements which means
it is available for all the web elements
throughout the driver instance
implicit weight is defined only once and
it will remain
same throughout the driver object
instance now let's see what explicit
weight is
so explicit weight is used to tell the
web driver
to wait for certain conditions
before throwing an element not visible
exception
it is defined to wait for certain
expected conditions only
now these expected conditions can check
whether the element is displayed on the
web page or not
or can be clicked or not so any kind of
conditions you can mention there
so these are called as conditional
weights and they are applied on a web
element
on a single web element unlike the
implicit weight which was kind of
applied globally to all elements it is
definitely recommended to use
this explicit weights when your elements
are taking longer time to load and also
for
verifying the property of the elements
like say visibility of the element
located
element to be click clickable or element
to be selected
then we have fluent weight now fluid
weight is used to tell the web driver
to wait for a condition that is very
similar to the explicit weight
as well as a frequency with which we
want to keep checking the condition
before throwing the not visible
exception
so fluent weight is used to define the
maximum amount of time you want the web
driver to wait
for a condition then if you look in the
syntax then there is
polling every second so polling every
and you give a timeout this could be
like five seconds so start
pulling to see whether the web element
is available or not say once in three
seconds once in four seconds depending
on
your use case and then dot ignoring so
you can also try to ignore specific type
of exceptions while waiting
now for example such as no such element
exception which is sometimes thrown when
searching for an element on the page so
you can mention even that here so fluid
weight takes two parameters one is the
timeout value and the pulling frequency
so when we have web elements
which sometimes are visible after few
seconds or sometimes it takes more time
than usual like
we have ajax applications as an example
we can set a default polling period
based on our requirement
and then as i said you can also ignore
some of the exceptions by
pulling this element question nine
mention the types of navigation commands
available in selenium so webdriver
provides
a basic browser navigation commands that
allows the browser to move forward
backward
refresh and using the browser history
and this is done
using some of the driver.navigate
methods right so these are some of the
commonly used navigation methods
first one is navigate2 so this method
loads a new web page in the existing
browser window
and it accepts string as a parameter and
returns nothing so it's a void
so the url you mentioned here needs to
be a fully formed url
driver.navigate.refresh so this method
refreshes or reloads the current webpage
in the existing browser window
it neither accepts anything so there is
no value path or it returns
nothing forward so this method enables
the web browser to click on the forward
button in the existing
browser window again this has this has
no arguments to be passed or it returns
nothing
driver.navigate.back so this method
enables the web browser to click on the
back button in the existing browser
window
again this returns nothing nor it needs
any argument
question 10 what is the major difference
between driver.close and driver.quitter
so this is again a very important
question
and pretty confusing also sometimes so
selenium webdriver provides two methods
for closing the browser window one is
browser.close
and the other one is the browser.quit so
you might think
to use them interchangeably and that's
that's what everybody thinks that both
anyway does the same function so it can
be used however it is not so
both are two different methods now
driver.close command is used to close
the current
browser window which is having the focus
and in case if there is a only
single browser window open then calling
this driver.close actually quits the
complete browser session
now it is used when you're working with
say multiple browser tabs or windows and
you want to just close one of them which
is in focus
in the test whereas the driver.quit is
used to quit the complete browser
session
along with all its associated windows
tabs pop-ups and everything
so when do you use browser.quit it is
best to use use browser.quit or sorry
driver.quit when you no longer want to
interact with the driver object
along with all its associated windows
tabs and pop-ups
generally it is one of the last
statements of your automation scripts
so in case you are like working with
selenium with test ng or g
j unit we usually call this driver dot
quit in the after switch that is at
after switch method
of our test suite thus by by doing that
we close
the complete browser session at the end
of the test fit execution
now let's look at some intermediate
level questions
question 11 how to type in an input box
using selenium so selenium provides a
method or a command you can say to
insert value into
any of the input box and this command is
called as a send keys command
so send keys is a method available in a
web element
now this is how you use the send keys so
here is an example so first
you need to find the element using any
of the eight locating techniques
and once you find the element in this
case which is an email field
you need to call a method called send
keys send keys takes an argument
which is of type string so you can pass
the value which you want to
pass to the web element so in this case
you will be passing a
gmail id or any id which will be your
email id here and then similarly
you do it for your password field so
first you find the element password
and then you send the password using
send case
this is a very simple method to use
question 12 how to click
on a hyperlink in selenium so whenever
you are testing the e-commerce
application you are going to find
lot of hyperlinks on your web pages
which you will obviously need to test
now selenium provides two locating
techniques
using which you can identify this
hyperlinks and using these
is what you need to operate on the
hyperlinks on your web pages so one is
using link text and other one is using
partial link text so using link text you
give a complete text
in the link text that is if you look at
in your e-commerce site let's say amazon
dot in let's
let's go to that website and see what it
means so in the amazon dot in if you
look at
some of these hyperlink text called
today's deals or amazon pay or sell or
customer service
if you inspect this element you will see
that
this is associated with a linked text
which is called as today's tea
along with is href and of course an
anchor tag so one way of identifying
this link is to use this complete text
which is today's t
also there is another way by using
partial link text for say example you
have a link text which is pretty long
and you do not want to use this complete
text instead you can use the locating
technique called partial link text
and give a partial text from that in
this example
instead of giving the complete customer
service here you can just say
use a customer or you can just use
service as your text
only thing whatever will be required
here is this has to be unique on this
page
there shouldn't be two elements which
would have this text which you are going
to
use so let's quickly see this in action
how do we
use this link text and partial link text
now we will be using the same example of
amazon.com so my use cases first i will
click on this today's deal
and after a sleep of two or three
seconds i will also click on customer
service
and i am going to achieve this one by
using link text so if you see in this
program so i have this method written
which is going to click on today's tale
and this is using a locating technique
link text and then
i also have another method here by using
partial link text i'm going to be
clicking on
the customer service link right so let's
see how this works so i'll just go ahead
and execute this
so this launches the amazon dot in and
the first thing what we are doing is it
is going to click on today's tale
all right that is done and then it will
click on the customer service link
right so this is how you can achieve
clicking on the
hyperlinks in your web applications
question 13
how to scroll down a page using
javascript
this is a very important question and
usually this gets asked quite often in
the interview
you should know that you can run java
scripts through selenium and selenium
provides a way to do this
selenium provides an interface called
javascript executor
javascript executor and this helps in
executing
any kind of javascripts through the
selenium webdriver so this javascript
executor it has basically two methods
one is execute script and the other one
is execute its
async script to run the javascript on
the selected window or on your current
page but why do you need this
right so if if you are answering this
question you should also have a
background that
why at all this is required because
sometimes you
need to perform certain functions which
cannot be done
using the locators what has been
provided like say scrolling down the web
page itself
also sometimes you will see that you are
unable to even identify some web
elements using all the
locating techniques which is made
available by selenium so in such
situations
what you can do is you can directly
write a javascript and
execute it using this javascript
executor
and if you look at it the syntax is
something like this so it says
javascript
executor js is equal to javascript
executor and driver now if you look at
this
javascript executor is an interface that
means you cannot create an object of it
and hence you type cast it to your
driver object
now how do you do this now first thing
what you do is you launch your web
application
on whatever web application is under
test and then
on that current window you call this
particular
execute script method using the
javascript executor
and then you can perform any functions
here in this example we are seeing a
function which is crawling down
vertically so this function takes an
attributes or arguments like x
coordinate and the y coordinate
now in this example our x coordinate is
0 and y coordinate is 1 000.
that means when this command gets
executed the page is going to
get scrolled down vertically by 1000
pixels
so why don't we just see this in action
so let's go to
another program here called the
scrolling test.java so basically what
i'm doing here is i'm going to be
logging into amazon.com
and then i will show you how to scroll
down by 600 pixels so it's a very very
simple code to write
you launch your application then you
create your object of javascript
executor
right actually you type caster to the
driver and then you just use an execute
script command
or a method this you see is your actual
script which gets executed
which says windows dot scroll by 0 comma
600 which is x coordinate and y
coordinate let's go ahead and execute
this so when amazon dot in is launched
and you should see the screen scrolling
down yes there we go so it just scroll
down by
few pixels and that is 600 pixels what
we mentioned see i could scroll back
again
and that is how you can achieve
scrolling functions and when do you
usually use this
say if you have a very long web page and
you want to go and identify or do some
operations on the web element which is
probably available to you towards the
end of the page
and that is when you can use some of the
scrolling functions
question 14 how to assert the title of a
web page
selenium web driver provides web driver
methods and one such method is called
get title so what get title does is it
fetches the title of the current page
how to use this command get titles
returns a string which is nothing but
your title of your page
that means you need a string variable in
which you can store this value so what
you do is you define a string variable
like it is defined in this example to
store your
title and then you execute this command
driver.gettitle which is going to fetch
the title and that value gets stored in
your
actual title once you get the title you
can do any operations with that
in this case what we are doing is we are
trying to verify the title
there are two ways which you can verify
them one is using an if else statement
where you compare your actual title with
the expected title or
alternatively you can also use assert
statements here right so selenium
provides a search statement so using
assert
you can validate whether your title of
the web page is as expected
question 15 how to mouse hover over an
element
in automation many times it is required
to perform some action
on the element which gets visible only
on the
mouse hovering on those elements now in
selenium
action is a class which we can use to
achieve this functionality
so action class is defined in a package
called as selenium.interactions
this has a set of apis to emulate
complex user gestures
it helps in building the patterns of
action
and then perform that action on a web
element now this action class provides a
rich set of apis
like so for mouse events and even the
keyboard events so say for to perform
any kind of mouse event
it provides a method called move to
element now in this example what you do
is you initiate an object of mouse class
and then use this move to element method
and what it does is the element is
scrolled into the view
first even before the move operations
happen so you could have multiple
actions like
here in this example we are just using
move to element but also you can if you
want to do a drag and drop observation
you can still have that
so in such case where you have multiple
actions like a drag and drop
then you use a method called build along
with this
so you say actions dot move to element
dot build and then dot perform
so dot build method is called before the
perform method and what it does is it
generates the composite actions
which has all those multiple actions
which you want to perform on a web
element then after the building
action is done you call a perform method
which actually performs that action on
your web element
and this is how the move to element
method of the action class is used
why don't we just see that in action
let's say let's go to our
eclipse here and i have a mouse over
test written here
so let's say we go to amazon.website so
in the amazon
uh if you go to the shop by category you
see that so the moment i mouse over it
it is going to give me this drop down
list so for me to select any element
from this my first
action on this web page should be to go
and just
hover my mouse over this web element
called shop by category and that's
exactly i'm going to achieve through my
automation now here in my methods here
what i have written
i have said okay first launch your
website which is amazon.n
and then i'm finding that element which
is shop by category using an xpath
so you could use any available locating
technique to find the element first
and then i instantiate an object of
actions and then
simply i'm doing is i'm using the method
move to element
and then i'm just going to say perform
that means my mouse would actually
get moved or over onto that particular
element okay so let's see this in action
so i'll just
execute this test case okay so amazon
dot is launched
and now we should see yeah the mouse
actually moved to shop by category and
because of that
we got this drop down list so and this
is how you can achieve your mouse over
functionality question 16
how to retrieve the css properties of an
element now css is nothing but cascading
style sheets
it's a style sheet language used for
describing the presentation of a
document
written in your markup language it
basically describes your html elements
as how they need to be displayed on the
screen
it's basically the look and feel like
your font size the width
height color and so on so it provides a
special and easy way
to specify various properties of the
element now why do we need this
we need to use a special method called
get css value to retrieve such chs
properties of web element
why because we already have a method
called get attribute
which can retrieve the value of the
attributes right however
the get attribute method can only
retrieve
those properties where the attribute and
its value are mentioned in your dom
and hence all this font size color
cannot be retrieved through the get
attribute method
and that is why we use the get css value
so basically it works like your get
method
and you need to provide the attribute
which you want to fetch using the get
css value so in this example what we are
trying to do is
we have a web element called the email
id
and of that we are trying to fetch the
font size so let's
again check this in action so if i go to
my web page here
let's close this so if i go to my
facebook and
if i inspect this particular element
which is the email id
and on the right if you see there are
multiple
other attributes of that element you see
right so you see the background color
you see the color here then you
see something called as font size and
say for example we want to
retrieve the font size of this
particular web element
and you will also see on the left where
you are seeing the dom here
you do not see that font size anywhere
as an attribute and its value here and
that is why i cannot use the get
attribute method to retrieve it
now instead of that what i am going to
do is i am going to use the get css
value
and use this font size for that so let's
go to my eclipse
i have a method written here where i log
into the facebook
and then i'm going to first find that
element which is by id
and i'm going to retrieve the css value
and i'm just simply printing it on the
console
so if i execute this so it's going to
launch the facebook
and since i'm not going to do anything
on the facebook web page as such let's
go to my console here
because this is where i'm expecting the
output so here it has given me the an
output in the console saying
12px which is nothing but your actual
font says what you see here in your
html page right and this is how you can
extract your css properties of any web
element on your
web page question 17 what is page object
model popularly known as
pom page object model is a design
pattern that
helps create object repositories for web
elements
so writing selenium test cases without
say using any patterns
may lead to co-duplicacy and also the
code becomes
unmaintainable after some time and say
if you have web element locators which
changes over time
then you will have to go through the
entire code base to make all the
required changes
so under this model for each web page in
the application
there should be a corresponding page
class and this
page class will have all the web
elements of the web page
and also it contains the page methods
which perform operations on the
web elements and the verification steps
required in your test cases are the
separate test cases
they are not combined in the same class
now the tests that use the methods of
this page object class
whenever they need to interact with the
ui of that page
the benefit here is if the page ui
changes that the test
need not be changed only the code within
this page object class needs to be
changed that is you go and just change
the web elements or the locators of the
web elements only in one place which is
your page class
and not in any of your test classes or
not test classes
so how does this form help so it makes
the code more readable
maintainable and reusable so there are
two ways you can implement a bomb
or a page object model one is done using
the page factory
which is offered by selenium and then
you can also achieve a page object model
without using the page factory
right using directly the objects and the
classes question 18 can capture
be automated this is again a very
favorite question of the interview
captcha is a security feature that
prevents bots and automated programs
from accessing sensitive information
yes and captcha cannot be automated you
will see that there are many
applications today who have captcha
why because it's a security feature it
is a concept to differentiate between
human and computers
the idea of capture itself is to prevent
any automated process
or a robotic process to do any kind of
actions
and say if you're going to automate it
then the entire idea of having the
captcha is lost
so you should never attempt to automate
it but then what do you how can you
handle this then
one either you can ask your developers
to disable it in the test environment
so that you can test the whole
application without having to hit on
this captcha
other way of doing is you can use static
data for your captcha
so that you can hard code that value in
your test for the time
being and then since your application
has capture as one of its functionality
if you really need to test that
you can just test that separately as a
manual testing itself but not
automated question 19 how does selenium
handle
windows based popup selenium is an
automation tool for automating web
applications
it cannot handle windows based
application however
we can use tools like auto it and robot
class
along with selenium to handle such
pop-ups so what are these tools
robot class is a java class which along
with selenium
can simulate your keyboard and mouse
events
it also helps in upload and download of
files and
also to manage the pop-ups so wherever
you have a requirement
of doing a file upload operation in
which if your native dialog box opens up
then one of the way to handle it is
using robot class
other tool which is available for us is
the auto it tool
it is a freeware and what it does is it
uses a combination of your mouse
movement keystrokes
and window control manipulation to
automate any such task
which is not possible by selenium web
drivers and again this auto it tool can
be integrated with selenium
and thus you can achieve the automation
of native window based
pop-ups question 20 how to take
screenshots in webdriver
take screenshot interface can be used to
take screenshots in
webdriver so selenium provides us this
interface for managing our screenshot
operations
now screenshots are desirable for bug
analysis
so selenium can automatically take this
screenshots during your
execution you know that it is very
important to take screenshots when we
execute the test scripts
say if we have a huge number of test
scripts running and if some of the test
case fail
we need to check why this test case
failed so using the screenshot
functionality it helps us debug and
identify the problem by looking at the
screenshots
so webdriver has this built-in
functionality to take the screenshot
across the page and it's pretty easy to
use
take screenshot interface is used to
capture the screenshot during the
execution
now this interface has a method called
grid
get screenshot as which captures a
screenshot
and it also stores in a location
specified by us
so let's take an example of our facebook
page and say
we fail a particular test case on the
facebook application and then
let's see how we take a screenshot at
that particular moment when the test
case fails
so let's go to the facebook page first
and let's understand the use case
so in this facebook page say if i am
signing up on this page
i need to enter all this field now as a
part of demo what i will do is i just
enter the first name and the surname
and i will click on the sign up button
with this test case it should basically
not sign me up rather it should give me
some error saying that you need to enter
all the fees
and at that minute we are going to take
a screenshot okay so that's our use case
so let's see how do we achieve that so
if i go to my eclipse
and let's say we go to my screenshot
test.java i have a method written here
so and these are the operations which i
just described which i'm doing it here
so i'm going to just
send keys my first name to the first
name field second name into the third
name field and then i'm just going to
click on the signup button now there are
few things required
for us to do before we use the take
screenshot interface along with its
method which is the get screen shot as
so i said that this method stores
the screenshot taken in a file so that
means i need to provide it a file name
and also a location where it needs to be
placed so in our demo here
in this test class what i have done is i
have created a folder called screenshot
in the same project directory and then i
i'm giving it a file name called
fblogin.png so that means after the
screenshot is taken
it is saved in a file called fblogin.png
and then
it is stored in the location screenshot
folder and these are the simple file
operations of java which i use to
achieve this so let's
execute this and see how this happens so
right now i have this screenshot folder
and it's an empty folder
so after the execution i'm expecting
that this particular file would get
created so let's see that in action so
i'll go ahead and execute this
java program okay so we have launched
the facebook.com
and then i entered the my first name
second name and it has also clicked on
signup after which it has given all this
red marks here
and now this is what i'm expecting in
the screenshot so let's go back to our
eclipse
i will refresh this folder so i'll say
right click and refresh
okay i have this file created so let's
open this file and see
right so do you see this this whole
image has been captured so now as a
tester if at all this test case fails
for me i can always open this png file
and see
what actually happened and i can debug
my test case
so this is how you use screenshot
functionality in
selenium level questions question 21 can
you type in a text box
without using send keys so you need an
alternative way
to use instead of using the send keys
function and one such alternative
is using javascript executor so selenium
provides an interface called javascript
executor
and this helps in executing any
javascripts through your selenium
webdriver
so you can do any kind of function using
this javascripts and one of the
functions which we can do is
the send keys kind of a function now how
to replicate a send keys function using
javascript
so let's see an example here now since
this javascript executor is an
interface you cannot create an object of
this interface
so what you do you type cast it to your
driver object the way it is done here
in this example and then you use
document
dot get element id to get the actual
element
on which you want to perform the
operations of sending the keys
now what is this document so it is an
object right so this document it's an
object that represents your html
document
which is displayed in that window and
this document object has various
properties that refer to
other object which allows you the access
to modify
any of your document content so the
argument which you're passing to the
java execute script is nothing but
your javascript now this javascript uses
the document object to identify your
element and then send the value which
you need to send to that element
so let's see this in action as how it
works so let me show you a small program
here
all right so i have a method here
wherein
i'm trying to identify the email field
of your facebook page
so if this is your facebook application
this is my email field
and instead of using send keys here i'm
going to pass a email value to this
and how am i doing that using a
javascript executor
right so if i execute this particular
java program
it is exactly going to do the same
function what i would do otherwise using
the send case
so let's execute this and see if i can
see my user's
id email in the facebook application so
the facebook application is launched and
there we go so we
this is the value which i have sent
using my javascript
okay so this is how you can use a
javascript executor
to replicate a send keys method question
22 how to select
a value from your drop down list in the
selenium webdriver
so select class is a selenium webdriver
it is used for selecting
and deselecting options in your drop
down list
the objects of select type can be
initialized by passing the drop down web
element as a parameter to its
constructor like in this example i am
saying select
drop down equal to new select of test
drop so test drop is nothing but the web
element which i have identified
using any locating techniques after you
create the select object
then you have three different methods
available
for actually selecting your methods and
what are these methods
one is select by index now the index
starts with 0 in the list
so you can select any element from your
list using the
index side and then the second one is
select by values
so this is used to select an option
based on its value
attribute select by visible text so this
is an option
wherein you can select a particular list
item or an option
based on the text displayed in the
option so that means whatever text
you can see on your drop down list is
what you will use it to identify that
particular element
so let's see the demo for this so i have
again
a same facebook application which i have
considered here for demo
so if you go to our facebook application
first you know that there is a drop down
menu here
now this drop down is for selecting your
bird date
this has a day values which you can
select the month values
right and the year now what i have done
in my code is
first thing is i've identified all these
drop down boxes
using one of i'm using mostly the id
locating technique here so you can use
any of your choice
so once i identify the element i created
the select object class
for each of this and i pass that web
element to the constructor of the select
class
so now my select element or the object
is ready to use
so my next step what i need to do is i
need to go and select the actual dates
now in this use case what i want is i
want to select a date which is 10th
june 2005. that means on my select drop
down of the day
i should be able to select the day 10.
now this i am achieving by using
select by value and then i am selecting
the bun
month based on the index which is the
index in this case is 6
which will select the june for me and
then the third one i'm trying to select
it by visible text
wherein i am selecting the year 2000 y
so when i execute this program
let's see how the date selection happens
okay there we go so it selected the 10
the day 10 the june month and the 2005.
so this is how you use select objects in
selenium question 23
what does the switch to command do so
switch to command is used to switch
between windows frames or even the alert
pop-ups
within your application right so there
are multiple things which you can do
with switch to
now sometimes in your web application
say when you click on a button
it opens up a completely new browser
window or you will also see it opens up
another tab in your browser say for
example
let's look at one of this application
which i have let me
go to my browser and say i
launch hdfcbank.com all right
so this is my application say which you
want to test and when you launch this
first thing is i see this advertisement
pop-up which comes up which is right now
an unwanted pop-up so right now i'll
just close this
and now if i want to enter this hdfc
bank application first i need to do a
login so if i click on this login button
see there is a new window which opens up
and i need to go and operate
into this window so for any further
operations i want to do it on this web
page i need to switch to this window
and then say i want to click on continue
to netbanking and then continue with my
use case
so now in this application there are two
windows open
one is your base window from where we
actually logged in and after i clicked
on the login there is a new window
opened up right
so this is where your switch to command
will help us to switching to this
particular window to do
any of the operations on this web
elements present on this window
okay now let's see how do we actually do
this so in order to do this
first you need to get the handle of the
window
by using a command called driver dot
get window handle all right so now when
you use driver.get window handle what
you get
is a unique alphanumeric value which is
an identifier for that window
and once you get this you use a command
called driver.switch2
dot window and you pass that handle
which you have fetched
previously and this command will
actually switch
to the current window which is in your
focus now you will also come across a
case where there are multiple windows
open
right now the example what we saw we
just had a single window but say if you
whenever you launch an application say
there are multiple windows which are
open so in such case you can use
something called as get
windows handles right now get windows
handles what it does it picks up all the
active windows at that point of a time
and using a for loop you can read into
every handle
and then you do your operations specific
to your window handles
also there is another way wherein you
can switch back to your parent window so
if ever you want to switch back to your
parent window you have to use the same
command driver.switch2 and
the handle what you need to provide here
is your parent handle all right so this
is about windows then i
also said switch to can be used for your
frames
so what are frames frames are usually
used to divide your web application or
your web page
or the on the same domain into various
different windows or sections
right so for us to operate on elements
which are in different frames we need to
first switch to a particular frame
and then use the web elements on that so
the same command will be using
now instead of window here i would say
driver dot switch to
dot free similarly even the alert
pop-ups can be handled using the same
command
so in the case of alert what you need to
do is you have to say driver dot switch
to
dot question 20 how to upload a file in
selenium webdriver
right a very important concept in
selenium webdriver we know that selenium
webdriver is designed
for automating web application right and
file upload is a very common scenario
which we get with every web application
which we are working with now there are
two ways to do a file window
file upload operation one is using the
send keys which is the simplest method
and the other way is using robot class
now there are certain prereqs
required for you to work with the send
keys option
now if you are using the send keys
option what you basically need to do is
you need to type in the complete
path of the file along with the file
name right in the file select input
field
now this element where you're going to
enter your file name
should have certain attributes one of
the attributes it should have the tag as
input
right and also it should have an
attribute called type
which should have a value of file only
then
it is possible for you to enter a file
name and upload the file okay that is by
using the
send keys method then the other way is
using robot now when when is that we
need to use robot
where whenever you have an application
and in your application
usually for your file upload you have a
button which says
upload a file and when you click on that
it opens a new window
and this window is your windows explorer
window or a finder window depending on
what operating system you're working and
these are the native windows
and we know that selenium webdriver
directly cannot handle the
native applications so in such case the
robot class helps us
in managing these native windows so what
happens in the robot classes
it helps you manage your file upload
dialog box
by simulating all the actions required
for
selecting a particular file from your
dialog box and then you go and upload
them
all right so this is the example of
using the send keys
question 25 how to set browser window
size
in webdriver so you can either maximize
the window or set it to a certain value
now to do this you use a simple
functions provided by driver.manage
one of the functions using driver.manage
is driver.manage
now this command maximizes the current
window
and say you want to set a particular
window size rather than maximizing it
and then for that you have a command
called driver.manage.window
now this set size takes an argument of
the type
dimension class so this is basically
when you create a dimension class
you are passing the size of the window
which you want to
create here right so we use the
dimension class define the new
dimensions
of the window and then pass the object
of this dimensions to the
set size method this is one way of doing
it we also saw that
using javascript executor we can do any
kind of functionality
so if you want to minimize or maximize
or
set a different size to your browser
windows this can
also be done using a javascript okay
let's see a quick demo
on how do we use this driver.manage dot
set size or the maximize command so
let's go to my eclipse here
so i have this method written here so i
have two methods
one method where i'm saying i'm going to
maximize the window this particular
command
is where i'm saying
driver.manage.window.maximise and i'm
launching a facebook application so
first let's
run this particular method and see how
our browser window behaves
so i'll just say execute this
so now you will see the whole window
your browser window is in maximized mode
so now from here i'm going to execute
the other set of
lines here using which i'm going to set
a certain size
now i'll just comment out these two
lines and then
these are the two commands which i'm
going to use right so here what i've
done is
i've defined an object of the class
dimension
and i've used 600 600 which is the size
of the window which i want it to be and
then using the set size
and passing this dimension object to the
set size method now let's see how do we
look at this browser window now
did you see that so it was at a certain
size and it just shrunk it shrunk
because i have used a smaller size
window
question 26 when do we use find element
and find elements now find element
you can use this command to access any
single element
on your page and what does it return it
returns an
object of the first matching element of
the specified locator
and this is the most common command what
we use for working with
every web element on the web page what
is find elements
find elements is used to return a list
of web elements
right so each element which it
identifies is indexed
with the number starting from zero it's
just like an array
i'll show you an example of that so that
you can understand it better
so let's go to my eclipse here right so
if you look at
this locators.java i have different
elements which i have identified using
different locating techniques
right so for that i use a simple command
called find element
now say i have a use case right wherein
i want to fetch all the web elements who
have a class name
starting with the text input let's see
what that is so if i go to my facebook
application
if i try to inspect this say first name
right so i'll say inspect element now
here if you see
this particular web element has a class
name starting with
text called as input text likewise there
are many
elements here like even the surname if
you look at it it has a class name
starting with input text
okay so if i have a use case like that
where i want all the web elements on the
facebook page
who have the class name starting with
the text
input if i have to do that that is when
i say
i am going to use the driver.find
elements so i say driver dot find
elements i give an x
path which is going to pick up all those
elements which has the class name
starting with input
this is my x path expression once i get
all the elements what am i doing i am
going to store it in a list array
once i have all these elements created
it's in an array
i'm just going to traverse through the
array using an enhanced for loop
so in this program in this test case i'm
just picking each and every element
and printing the attribute id of each
element
so if i execute this now we should see
all the elements
on the facebook page which has the class
name starting with input
and we should see all the ids of that so
this is what we are getting so you are
around getting 9 to 10 elements it has
picked up
and all of them have the class name
starting with input
and these are the different ids question
27
what is pause on exception in selenium
id
so pause on exception is a new feature
of selenium ide it is one of the
brilliant debugger function
which this new selenium id provides us
what it does is it enables
us or when this particular option is
enabled the execution of your test
pauses
if at all there is any exception which
occurs in your test scripts
and because of this what you can do is
you can go and handle that error by say
changing your command in the script
and then continue your test execution so
this helps in debugging your code pretty
well so whenever there is an exception
say for example and web element which
you are trying to identify
has a wrong identifier or it changes on
your web page
then you can correct that command which
cause the exception
and then resume the test execution from
that point onwards
so let's look at a simple use case and
see how exactly this works
so for example let's go to my browser
here
okay so i have a simple use case here
where i want to login
into facebook using my email id and
password and what i have done
is i have created a script or recorded a
script using my selenium id so these are
all the steps which it has
wherein it logs into the facebook
account then it clicks on the email
field
enters the email this is my value which
i'm passing clicks on the password field
enters the password and then clicks on
the login button now this is
a clean test script and all my web
elements are correct here so whenever
i'm running this test with this test
script is going to pass
now say as an example say this
particular element which is my password
element say this id
changes so now deliberately what i'm
going to do i'm just going to give a
wrong id here so if i give a wrong id
and if i execute a test script now it is
going to throw an exception at this
point
so let's do that so it's going to throw
an exception but now since i want to use
the pause and exception feature what i
do is
it's available here it says pause and
exception by default it is switched off
so
when you select this that means this has
been switched on
and now if i execute the script this is
going to
come into a debug mode at this point
where my exception is going to be
through so let's see that so now i have
this i have changed this id to a wrong
id so i'll just say go and
run this current test so let's see how
it operates so let me just bring this
side by side so you can see here
it has entered the email and if you look
here in the console it is saying
trying to find the id for which i've
given
pa and 4s which is a wrong id so it will
look
for some time whether it can find an
element with this particular id so let's
wait for it to throw the exception
there we go so now it tried enough and
actually that step
has failed and there is an exception
saying that that particular web element
is not found
however my test case or the test script
did not exit
it has come and paused and it has
entered into a debug mode here
paused and debug now as a tester or an
automation script writer what i can do
here is i can simply go and
correct this now i know this is my
correct id
once i correct this i can execute the
rest of the script right from this point
so now i have this option here if you go
here it says resume test execution
so i'm just going to click on that so it
is going to go ahead and
enter everything yes if you see here i
entered email password and in this test
script what i'm doing is i'm entering my
first name and my surname instead of
clicking on the login button so it went
ahead and if you look here it says fb
test completed successfully
this is how the pause and exception
feature helps us question 28
how to login into any website if it is
showing an authentication pop-up for
username and password which will be
something like this so this is a typical
authentication pop-up which you normally
see when you are dealing with
some web application right and to handle
them we use something called as an
alert class and alert class comes with a
method called authenticate using
basically by using this method what we
are trying to do is it helps us skip the
basic http authentication box so how do
we handle it it is handled
exactly the way we handle any kind of
alert box and selenium now in this
example first what we need to do is we
need to create a weight object
using an explicit weight now this weight
is for what it is for the alert
to pop up so we basically wait until
that authentication alert pops up
and set the conditions in this explicit
way for
as alert is present so that means you're
going to wait until your
authentication pop-up is seen on your
screen and then
once you have that authentication pop-up
which is on your screen that is when you
need to go and handle it
now to handle it for your alert class
you are going to call a method as i said
using
authenticate using and to this you pass
a parameter
now this parameter has to be your
username and password
however the way the parameters are
passed here is using
a class object called user and password
now this user and password class it is a
part of selenium security package
all right and this is implemented from
an interface called credentials
so you create this object of class user
and password
using the authentication information
which you have and then
pass this as parameter to your method
called authenticate using
and this way you can handle your
authentication pop-up
question 29 what is the difference
between single and double slash in
x-path a very important question and
it's a very important thing for each of
you to understand
single slash is used to create an path
with absolute path
that is the x path would be created
right from the starting node and the
starting node is
slash html and the double slash is
created
or it's a x path with relative path now
relative path this x path would be
created
uh using any starting location or
anywhere within the document
for example i could start with a div tag
wherein if i mention double slash
ender so this is going to be treated as
a relative path
and whatever conditions i am going to
give it is going to try and match those
attributes with the stack right this is
called as a relative path so why don't
we just go and take a look at
how do we identify an element using a
relative as well as an absolute path
so if i go back to the same application
of the facebook
this is my facebook application now i
have this crow path installed which
helps me in identifying x parts of an
element
now say i want to try and see what is
the x path of my
element first name so in the inspector
tool i can see that it has a tag input
and it has a long class name
and it has multiple attributes which i
can use to identify this element so if i
go to my crow path
and again try to match this element so
if i just hover my mouse here
now here you can see this crow path
gives me both the path one is the
relative x path and one is the absolute
x path now look at the big difference
between these two now relative path was
as simple as
using a slash slash input which is the
tag and an attribute called id
we are able to identify this particular
element same thing if you want to use an
absolute path and
you if you see here it will start right
from the slash html which is your
starting node of your html page and then
it travels down
looking into each of the parent and
child under this until it found this
element input
right so this is absolute path so you
can use either of these paths to
identify
your elements question 30 how do you
find broken links in
selenium webdriver now http is designed
for what
to enable communications between your
clients and servers
and if you know there are few commands
like get put post
now get is used to request data from a
specified resource
put command is used to send data over
your server and post is used to send
data
to the server right now by using these
links and
trying to figure out if the link is
valid or not what you can do is you can
use something called as head requests
now what are head request head requests
are nothing but they are something like
a get request
but they do not have a response body and
usually this is used for checking that
what a get request can return before
actually making a get request
like say before downloading a large file
you would send a head
request before sending the complete get
just to know whether the link
which is provided for downloading a
large file is
a genuine link or not and then looking
at the response code is what you decide
that
so how do we do this programmatically
now selenium provides something called
as
http url connection class which has
some methods to send http request and to
capture the http response codes like the
ones which you see it on the screen so
if we have to see how do we do that
now first thing the logic behind how do
we get this broken links is you get all
the urls on your website first
after getting all the urls now how do
you get the urls by using the tag a
like it is done here so once you get the
complete list of all urls you also check
for a non
val a non null or a blank ones that is
one kind of a check which you can put
after that you create an http connection
object with each of the url
and you open the connection of the url
and you send the request
now this request whatever you're going
to send you are going to send the header
request
to just to get the head and not the
complete get request
now only thing what you're interested in
getting a response code
so once you get the response code what
you have to do is you have to check the
response code against
all your response code now typically
when you're checking for your response
code any response code above 400
is treated as a client error rest all
the links below 400
are all the valid links so here if you
see 404
you have a response call as link not
found 400 is a bad request 401 is
unauthorized
so you can do a simple check there where
it says if your response code is
above 500 then that particular link has
an error and that is probably going to
be your invalid link so let's
see that in action as how exactly the
code is going to look and how do we
achieve that
now i have a test case written here
called broken links.java
now here what i'm doing is i'm logging
into facebook.com
and then i'm fetching all the elements
with the tag a
now when i say i'm fetching all the
elements with the tag that means i'm
going to get all the href element
from the page and once i get that using
a for loop i'm going to inspect each and
every
url what i'm going to fetch as i said my
first
check would be to see if it is a null or
is it an empty if i find an
empty or a null value in the url i am
just going to ignore that
and continue the loop and this is where
i actually do the connection with my url
so i create an http url connection
with the url which i have picked it up
from my website then i do this
i send a request here the head request
to get a response code
so once i get this response code is what
i put a if-else statement and check
if my response code is greater than or
equal to 400. so if i find that if my
response code is more than 400 that
means this particular url link is broken
and that is how i identify
so once you identify a particular url
which is broken you can make use of that
information
share it with your developers and get it
fixed so let us go ahead and execute
this
so in this test case basically what i am
going to do is i am just printing out
all the urls and i am printing the ones
which are valid and ones which are
broken
since it's a facebook.com website i do
not have any broken url
but this is just a logic of how do we
find a broken url so if you look here
a lot of websites which is getting
listed which says is a valid link so
that means
it is getting a response code which is
more than 500.
so this is what we saw in the demo as
how do i
i trade after i select all the links on
the page and then how do i determine
whether it's a
valid link or it's a broken link so with
that we have come to an end of the
selenium full course
if you have any queries regarding the
topics covered in this session then
please feel free to drop them down in
the comment section below
our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning